EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT WILL COME
TO ORDER. A GOOD AFTERNOON
RESPONSE CODE NINETEEN NUMBERS
SEEM TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
CLOUDS LEADERS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER. TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. TODAY EACH SIDE WILL
BE PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME WE WITNESSES WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES FOR EACH WITNESS AND
THERE IS NO RESERVING TIME FOR
OTHER WITNESSES. ALL OTHER
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES BEFORE US. FOR THESE
WITNESSES WILL BE A LIMIT OF
TEN MINUTES FOR ALL SUPPORT
WITNESSES COMBINED IN TEN
MINUTES FOR ALL OPPOSITION
WITNESSES COMBINE. TWO OF THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
REQUIRE. AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE YOU WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-692-8953 AGAIN.
877-692-8953 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN OH FIVE SIX NINE
OH NINE. AGAIN THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN OH FIVE SIX NINE OH
NINE FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TOTAL COMFORT SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND- COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT. IN THE SAME FOR
OPPOSITION. THIS IS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE A MUTED IF YOU ARE
THEN READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY IN TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST. MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE
pTESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE. MAYBE REMOVE
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTE.
WELL EVERY EFFORT IS MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS THIS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT.
SO ALL PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. WE
HAVE TEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA WE HAVE ONE BILL ON
CONSENT. HE AND- I AM GOING TO
BEFORE WE DO ANY OF THAT WITH
THE BILLS WERE GOING TO-
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO
CONSULTANT WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR IS
CRITICIZING. ATTESA HERE FOR
TROUBLED. BUT TROUBLE HERE TO
WRESTLE THE REST HERE LAYARD
NEWMAN. NEWMAN HERE THOSE NOTED
CENTER WHERE IT IS- IN THE
BUILDING AND ANOTHER. THE
LEGISLATIVE ME OF SOME
IMPORTANCE SO HE WILL BE
JOINING US SHORTLY WE
UNDERSTAND WITHIN THE FIRST
THIRTY MINUTES OR SO- THAT
SAID- WHY DON'T WE- POSTPONED.
DEALING WITH THE CONSENT ITEMS
WE DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT- RIGHT
NOW IN ANY PARTICULAR ORDER.
THAT'S ONE LESS BILL TO PUT ON
CALL LATER AND- JUST ASKS ONE
THING TO ISSUE OR SOMEBODY HELP
REMIND ME TO COME BACK TO THAT
AND WE'RE GOING TO- START WITH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES WHO
HAS TWO BILLS. TWO BILLS BEFORE
US TODAY I WILL START WITH AB
NOT EIGHT NINETEEN IS A
SUMMER'S COMING FORWARD LET ME
JUST SAY AFTER THE TWO BILLS OF
THE TWO CERVANTES BILLS WE WILL
TAKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS BILL.
A LOT OF ORDER US A MATTER OF
FEATURES PROVOCATIVE SO THAT
WOULD BE THE THIRD BILL AND WE
HEAR INSTEAD OF THE TENTH BILL
EVERYTHING LIKE THAT EVERYTHING
AFTER THAT WILL. FOLLOW IN THE
ORDER OF THE AGENDA LET ME JUST
INDICATE THAT. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT. THE AGENDA IN
TERMS OF THE WAR MEASURES HEARD
IN FILE ORDER HAS BEEN
MODIFIED- MORE RECENTLY BUT
THOSE OF THE AGENDA ORDER ON
THE DISTRIBUTED AGENDA IS
CORRECT- IN THE BILL'S IS
LISTED ARE CORRECT THOSE ARE
HERE IN THE BUILDING. AND ALSO
I BELIEVE FOR ON THE WEBSITE OR
WHEREVER YOU MIGHT BE LOOKING
ONLINE SO IF YOU'RE CONFUSED AT
ALL STICK TO WHAT'S IN THE
BUILDING HERE. IN THE ROOM IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM OR OR WHAT'S
ONLINE SOME MEMBERS CERVANTES
WELCOME. AND YOU MAY PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY WITH
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT NINETY
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT NINETY
WHICH WILL ENSURE TRANSPARENCY
AND PROMOTE THE INCLUSION OF
WOMEN AND BY PARK MONEY
MANAGERS. IN THE ASSET
MANAGEMENT MANAGEMENT INDUSTRY
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE CALPERS
AND CAL STIRS TO PROVIDE A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE UTILIZATION OF EMERGING AND
DIVERSE MONEY MANAGERS. CALPERS
AND CAL STIRS HAVE A COMBINED
ASSET OF OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
BILLION BUT A RELATIVELY LOW
RATE OF PARTICIPATION OF
EMERGING AND DIVERSE MANAGER IS
WHEN IT'S COMPARED. TO THE
OTHER PUBLIC PENSION SYSTEMS IN
OTHER STATES IN THE WORLD THE
BUSINESS FEW THINGS ARE MORE
DETERMINATIVE OF THE ABILITY TO
SUCCEED IN THE AVAILABILITY OF
INVESTMENT CAPITAL. IT IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A BUSINESS
THAT GROWS TO BECOME THE NEXT
TESLA FACEBOOK OR GOOGLE MY
BUSINESS IS THAT START SMALL
AND STAY SMALL BECAUSE THEY
LACK ACCESS TO CAPITAL. THEY
NEED IN ORDER TO GROW AND
THRIVE TODAY ONLY 1% OF VENTURE
CAPITAL BACKED OFFENDERS ARE
BLOCKED IN LESS THAN 2% ARE A
LOT AND. NEXT DISSENT IN A
COUNTRY THREE WERE WOMEN MAKE
UP ON THE- OF OUR POPULATION
WOMEN RECEIVE A DISMAL TWO
POINT 7% OF VENTURE CAPITAL
FUNDING. AND DESPITE BECOMING
AN INCREASINGLY DIVERSE COUNTRY
WOMEN OF COLOR RECEIVE LESS
THAN 1% OF VENTURE CAPITAL
FUNDING. HOW CAN I LOOK MY
DAUGHTER OR MY SONS- IN THE EYE
AND TELL THEM THEY CAN START
AND BE THE NEXT GREAT AMERICAN
COMPANY WHEN INVESTORS EXCLUDE
THEM FROM ACCESSING THOSE VERY
FUNDS. IT IS CLEAR THAT
SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES EXIST AND
HOW THE SYSTEM SELECT MANAGERS
TO INVEST THE CAPITAL THAT THEY
OVERSEE. AND AS THE SAYING GOES
IF YOU CAN'T MEASURE IT YOU
CAN'T MANAGEMENT AB EIGHT
NINETY. IS STRICTLY OBTAINING
THE DATA WE NEED TO MEASURE HOW
THESE FUNDS APPROACH DIVERSE
CITY. CALIFORNIA CANNOT HAVE
SHARED SUCCESS WITHOUT SHARED
OPPORTUNITY. IN ORDER TO HELP
ADDRESS THESE INEQUITIES WE
MUST ENSURE THAT WOMEN IN BY
PARK INDIVIDUALS HAVE MORE
EQUAL ACCESS TO CAPITAL. AND
THAT'S PART OF THE ON GOING
PROJECT THE LEGISLATURE WILL
NEED ACCURATE INFORMATION ON
HOW CALPERS AND CAL STIRS
DISPERSE OUR CAPITAL TO WOMEN
IN BY PARK MANAGERS. WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SPOT AND IS
A SPONSOR OF THE BILL SELANDER
BROKE. WITH THAT NEW AMERICAN
ALLIANCE AND JIM PARK CEO OF
THE ASSOCIATION. OF ASIAN
AMERICAN INVESTMENT MANAGERS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND-
WE WILL CALL FIRST ONES BROOKS
THE FIRST LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS.
WHO IS CALLING ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE SO IF
YOU'RE AVAILABLE YOU MAY
PROCEED. MY NAME IS SOLANGE
FERNANDEZ BROOKS I'M THE CEO OF
THE NEW AMERICA ALLIANCE. IN A-
IN A IN THE NATIONAL NONPROFIT
ASSOCIATION OF LATINO BUSINESS
LEADERS DEDICATED TO ADVANCING
THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OF THE
AMERICAN LATINO COMMUNITY. OUR
GOAL IS TO INCREASE THE
AVAILABILITY OF INVESTMENT
CAPITAL TO WOMEN AND MINORITY
OWNED FIRMS AND TO PROMOTE
DIVERSITY LEADERSHIP AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP CORPORATE
AMERICA AND PUBLIC SERVICE. AS
WAS MENTIONED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES. THE
AVAILABILITY OF CAPITAL MEANS
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
COMMUNITY CAN THRIVE AND BUILD
SUCCESS AMONG ITS MEMBERS AND
ONE THAT- THAT STAGNATE AND-
WHENEVER HIGHER LEVELS OF
POVERTY AND LACK OF OPPORTUNITY
IN A BELIEVES THAT THIS BILL AB
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT AND AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT WILL
REINSTATE. AND TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY BY HAVING
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS REPORT ON
HOW THEY DEPLOY THEIR
INVESTMENT THAT IT. CHARGES
ICICLE ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS COMBINED.
CURRENCY YOUR FIRST STEP PRIOR
TO WIN A TEN OF MY FIFTEEN
YEARS AS A PORTFOLIO MANAGER
WITHIN CHARACTERS INVESTMENT
BRANCH I SPENT REPORTING
DIRECTLY TO THE CIO THE CHIEF
INVESTMENT OFFICER TO HELP
CREATE LEAD AND MANAGE THE
FUND'S INVESTMENTS WITH WOMEN
AND MINORITY MANAGERS. THE LAST
FIVE YEARS I MANAGE A GLOBAL
CRITICAL. WOMEN WORKING IN THIS
COUNTRY PLAN TO GOOD
INTELLIGENT PEOPLE AND THEY DO
THE WORK TO THE BEST OF THEIR
ABILITY. HOWEVER THEY WORK IN A
CULTURE WHERE THE LARGE
INVESTMENT FIRMS ARE FAVORED IN
IN INVESTMENT A LARGE
INVESTMENT FIRMS ARE
TRADITIONALLY MALE AND THEY'RE
QUITE SH. WE BELIEVE THAT IT IS
A COULD DO SHARE RESPONSIBILITY
TO ENSURE ALL OPPORTUNITIES ARE
BETTER TO ENABLE DIGITAL ACTION
OF THE BEST INVESTMENT FIRM.
FOR THE STRATEGY AND GENERATE
THE BEST RETURNS FOR THE
PENSIONERS. WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE ALMOST 70% OF THE
POPULATION AND ACCORDING TO A
TWENTY NINETEEN NINETY
CONDITION STUDY. ONLY MANAGE
ONE POINT 3% OF THE SIXTY NINE
TRILLION ACTIVE MANAGEMENT
INDUSTRY. THAT IS THAT. SHINGLE.
THIS IS NOT A QUESTION OF
ASKING CHARACTERS ARE CALPERS
TO ENTRUST THEIR **** LOCAL
FORMING MANAGERS MEETINGS ABOUT
ASKING THEM TO IDENTIFY HELP
PUBLIC FUNDS ARE MANAGED AND
INVESTED WITH A HIGH PERFORMING
WOMEN AND MINORITY MANAGERS
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY.
ULTIMATELY MOVING THE NEEDLE ON
THIS ISSUE REQUIRES ACTIVE
LEGISLATIVE ENGAGEMENT. THIS
WILL TIS BILL WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE DATA THAT YOU NEED TO
ACCURATELY ASSESS HOW THE FUNDS
ARE PERFORMING ON DIVERSITY-
BUT CRUCIAL FIRST STEP. THANK
YOU AND I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IN
FREESHEET TO- TRYING TO KEEP TO
THE TWO MINUTES JIM PARK IS THE
NEXT. SUPPORT WITNESSES LISTED
A FEW THERE YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE V. EIGHT
NINETY MY NAME IS JIM PARKER
CEO OF ASSOCIATION OF ASIAN
AMERICAN INVESTMENT MANAGERS
PAYING. THIS BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT WILL
REINSTATE AND ENHANCE
TRANSPARENCY IN HOW CALPERS AND
CAL STIRS THE BOARD THEIR
RESPECTIVE INVESTMENT CAPITAL.
NOT A NEWER FOR THE STATE
PENSION PROGRAM BUT LARGELY A
REINSTATEMENT OF SOMETHING THAT
WAS IN PLACE PREVIOUSLY.
INTERNATIONAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION FOUNDED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX DEDICATED TO
PROMOTING DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION OF ASIAN AMERICANS
PACIFIC ISLANDERS IN THE FIELD
INVESTMENT MANAGER. AS WELL AS
SUPPORTING DIVERSITY IN THE
INDUSTRY OVERALL LAST YEAR IN
RELEASED A STUDY WHICH FOUND
THAT FOUND THAT U. S.
APPREHENSION FARMS WITH
MAJORITY ASIAN AMERICAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER OWNERSHIP MANAGED JUST
POINT 7% OF ASSETS UNDER
MANAGEMENT. DESPITE THEIR
PERFORMANCE OF MEETING OR
EXCEEDING INDUSTRY BENCHMARKS
THE PERFORMANCE RESULTS.
SUPPORT THE EARLIER STUDY BY
THE AMERICAN FOUNDATION BUT
SALONS MENTIONED TRUMP A
DRAMATIC UNDER REPRESENTATION
OF WOMEN AND OTHER MINORITY
OWNED FIRMS ANDINVESTMENT
BEALL DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THESE BONDS. DID NOT SEE ANY
DROP IN PERFORMANCE TOO OFTEN
DISCUSSION AROUND BROADENING
OPPORTUNITIES TO MORE MINORITY.
AND WOMEN OWNED FIRMS DEVOLVE
INTO BASELESS ASSERTIONS ABOUT
MOORING RETURNS WHICH IS
ACTUALLY NOT THE CASE. BUT LACK
OF ACCESS TO THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS UNDER OUR COLLECTIVE
ABILITY AS A SOCIETY TO PROVIDE
INVESTMENT CAPITAL FOR DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES. WE KNOW THAT BLACK
MINORITY AND WOMEN OWNED
INVESTMENT FIRMS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO SUPPORT. OTHER
MINORITY AND WOMEN OWNED LOCAL
BUSINESSES CALIFORNIA CANNOT
BENEFIT FROM THE FULL POWER OF
DIVERSITY. UNLESS WE PROVIDE
SURE OPPORTUNITY AND THIS CAN
BE DONE WITHOUT SACRIFICING
RETURNS FOR THE TWO PENSION
PROGRAMS AB EIGHT NINE IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP IN
PROVIDING POLICYMAKERS WITH THE
DATA THEY NEED TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THOSE ALLOCATION DECISIONS
ARE. ENHANCING THE LIVES OF ALL
COMMUNITIES IN THE GREAT STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR THE%
OPPORTUNITY. TO SPEAK ON THIS
CRITICAL MATTER EXPECT. YOU
THINK YOU WE WILL COME. TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM NO NOW IF
THERE'S ANY COMMITTEE WHO WISH
TO SEE AND SO OF AB EIGHT
NINETY. THE SCENE NONE I WILL
CHECK THE- THE OVERFLOW ROOM-
THERE'S NO ONE TERE TO TESTIFY
WILL GO TO THE MODERATOR KNOWN
AS A MODERATOR TO PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES ON AB
EIGHT NINETY. AND PLEASE LET US
KNOW THE NUMBER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO AT THIS TIME PRESS ONE AND
ZERO TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. MR
CHERNOBYL THE SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR- WE'RE GOING TO.
REPEAT THE PROCESS WE JUST WENT
THROUGH WITH THE OPPOSITION
NOW- IT'S INDICATED THAT
THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK
THERE'S ANYONE OPPOSITION IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WISHES TO
SPEAK AT THIS TIME. AS SEEN
NONE- WE WILL LOOK AT THE
OVERFLOW ROOM AND- IT'S CLEAR
THAT THERE'S NO ONE THERE
WISHING TO TESTIFY PLUS A
MODERATOR TO QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION. TESTIMONY ON AB
EIGHT NINETY THANK YOU. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THE FUTURE KNOWING TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR WILL
COME- BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND
ASK MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
COMMITTEE IF ANYONE HAS A
QUESTION OR CONCERN YOU'D LIKE
TO RAISE AT THIS TIME. SENATOR
ROSALYN NO POSTED ROSE WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL- BEFORE
WE MOVE ON THE MOTION LET ME
COME BACK TO A SIMMER CERVANTES
AND GIVING OPPORTUNITY CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
AND- CONSULTANT THERE IS A
MOTION BY SENATOR ALSO AND IF
YOU CAN CALL THE ROLL NOW
PLEASE WE PURCHASE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COURTESY ALL
RIGHT COURTESY I'D ULTRABOOK
BUT TROUBLED I. WRESTLE THE I
LAYERED. NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN AYE.
OKAY SO WE HAVE FOUR EYES SO WE
HAVE ZERO NO VOTES SO WE HAVE
ONE- ABSENCE WILL KEEP THE BILL
ON CALL THANK YOU. WE ARE NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO. AB ELEVEN OH
SIX- I DON'T USE THE WRONG
AGENDA SO. THANK AYE IF YOU
WEREN'T LISTENING I DID MENTION
THAT EARLIER THE CORRECT AGENT
IS SOMEONE POSTED ONLINE
CURRENTLY AND ALSO POSTED IN
THE ROOM HERE A. B. ELEVEN OH
SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES-
YOU MAY PROCEED IF YOU'RE READY
SENATORS AB ELEVEN OH SIX A
BILL I AM JOINED THE AUTHORING
WITH MAJORITY LEADER RAY IS
ESTABLISHES A PILOT PROJECT TO
SUPPORT. THE ENHANCEMENT OF THE
STATEWIDE TRAINING CENTER
NETWORK WHICH WOULD WORK HAND
IN HAND WITH BUSINESS OWNERS
SMALL BUSINESS SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND OTHER WORKFORCE
PARTNERS TO GET PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK OVER TWENTY MILLION
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTING CLAIMS
HAVE BEEN FILED IN CALIFORNIA
SINCE THE PANDEMIC CAUSED THE
CLOSURE OF BUSINESSES IN MARCH
OF TWENTY TWENTY. AND AS OF MAY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THERE ARE
STILL OVER ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION UNEMPLOYMENT WORKERS IN
OUR STATE A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
BEEN MOST ECONOMICALLY IMPACTED
OUR WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
WITH LIMITED ACCESS TO
EDUCATION AND TRAINING BEYOND
HIGH SCHOOL. AB ELEVEN OH SIX
LEVERAGES IS EXISTING PROGRAMS
AND EXPERTISE TO RESPOND TO
THESE KOBE NINETEEN
UNEMPLOYMENT CHALLENGES QUICKLY
AND HELP WORKERS GAIN THE
SKILLS SMALL BUSINESSES NEED IN
ORDER TO SURVIVE DURING
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. I HAVE
SEVERAL WITNESSES TODAY I WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ONE OF
THEM BEING JOHN MILBURN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING INSTITUTE
AT COLLEGE OF THE. CANYONS OF
COMMUNITY. EXCUSE ME THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY. OKAY
THANK YOU SO MOVE BRUTAL
MILBURN IF YOU'RE ON THE
TULKAREM SIGN YOU MAY PROCEED.
HELLO MY NAME'S JOHN WILL BRING
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK YES WE CAN
THANK YOU. RIGHT I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF EMPLOYEE
TRAINING INSTITUTE COLLEGE OF
THE CANYONS S. AND CREATE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT. THE
COLLEGE IS LOCATED IN SANTA
CLARITA ABOUT THIRTY MILES
NORTH OF DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES.
THE LAST YEAR THE COLLEGE
OFFERS MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
FORTY ASSOCIATE DEGREE AND
CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS AND SERVE
MORE THAN THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
STUDENTS. IN ADDITION OUR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT DIVISION
PROVIDED TRAINING JOB PLACEMENT
AND BUSINESS ASSISTANCE
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS FOR MORE
THAN FORTY TWO HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS AND MORE THAN EIGHT
HUNDRED EMPLOYERS IN OUR AREA.
WE ARE ALSO PART OF THE IS IT
EXISTING STATEWIDE NETWORK OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CONTACT
EDUCATION CENTERS PROVIDING
RAPID RESPONSE TRAINING AND
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
STATE. WE ARE COLLABORATING
WITH A LOCAL HIGH SCHOOLS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
EMPLOYERS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHERS TO
PROVIDE THE EDUCATIONAL AND
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS
NEEDED FOR. MEANINGFUL CAREER
PATHWAYS FOR STUDENTS. OUR
LOCAL EMPLOYERS INCLUDE SOME OF
CALIFORNIA'S PREMIER AEROSPACE
AND BIOMEDICAL MANUFACTURERS IN
THE SUPPLY CHAIN OF SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT SUPPORT THEM.
DURING CODE NINETEEN ANY OF THE
MANUFACTURER SUFFERED LOSSES
HAD TO DIVERSIFY AND SOME MOVED
OUT OF THE STATE OR CLOSE
COMPLETELY THIS AFFECTED THE
SMALLER BUSINESSES THE MOST. WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO LOSE THESE AND
OTHER CALIFORNIA BASED
COMPANIES TO OTHER STATES AND
COUNTRIES BECAUSE THIS
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS OUR WORK
FORCE AND SOME OF THE MOST
UNDERSERVED INDIVIDUALS FEEL
THIS IMPACT THE MOST- THE TIME
IS RIGHT FOR US TO ESTABLISH
THIS PILOT PROJECT. TO SERVE
THE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING NEEDS
OF SMALL BUSINESSES. AND ENSURE
THAT WORKFORCE TRAINING NEEDS
THE JOB DEMANDS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES NEW EMPLOYEES AND
DISLOCATED WORKERS. AND THAT IS
WHY I SUPPORT AB ELEVEN OH SIX
AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU IN A-
I UNDERSTAND THIS IT FRUITS
SUPPORT WITNESSES OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE'LL COME
BACK TO COMMITTEE ROOMS YOU
THERE'S ANYONE HERE WHICH IS TO
TAKE A SUPPORT POSITION ON A.
B. ELEVEN OH SIX THE C. KNOWN
COME FORWARD I WILL CHECK YOUR
FULL ROOM AND THERE'S NO ONE
THERE TO TESTIFY MODERATOR UP
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT
WITH THIS IS ONLY BE ELEVEN OH
SIX AND AGAIN WOULD APPRECIATE
KNOWING. THE NUMBER WITNESSES
THANK YOU. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THE FUTURE NO ONE IS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU MODERATE
APPRECIATE THE LOWER INCOME
BACK TO. THE OPPOSITION SIDE
NOW- THERE IS. NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS LISTED FOR
TODAY WHEN ASKED THERE'S ANYONE
HERE WAS TAKEN OPPOSE POSITION
ON THE BILL IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. SCENE KNOWN. WILL CHECK
YOUR FOR ROOM AGAIN SEEN
KNOWING THERE TO TESTIFY.
UNLESS ONCE AGAIN MODERATOR FOR
YOU TO QUEUE UP. A WITNESSES
THIS TIME IN OPPOSITION AB
ELEVEN OH SIX AND AGAIN PLEASE
LET US KNOW THE NUMBER IF ANY.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO SURE NO
ONE IS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK OKAY FREESHEET THE
MODERATOR THANK YOU WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ASKING
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE C. CENTERS RUSSELL-
WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. IF I COULD
ASK A QUESTION EITHER OF THE
AUTHOR OR OF- MR MILBURN YOUR
EXPERT WITNESS WILL LEAVE IT TO
THE AUTHORS OF PROVOCATIVE-
BECAUSE MIGHT MIGHT APPROVED BY
SUPPORT- I THINK REACHING OUT
TO PARTICULAR BUSINESS SECTORS-
AND TO GET A BETTER IDEA FROM
THEM AS TO WHAT. THEY NEED. YOU
KNOW FROM OUR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. I DIDN'T QUITE GET
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
EXAMPLE THAT MR MILBURN- GAVE
IN TERMS OF. CERTAIN SECTORS-
THAT WERE HURT- IN THE- DURING
THE PANDEMIC ESPECIALLY. AND
THE IMPACT THAT THAT HAD ON
SMALL BUSINESSES I DIDN'T QUITE
GET THE CONNECTION BETWEEN.
WHAT KIND OF TRAINING JUST AS
AN EXAMPLE WHAT KIND OF
TRAINING. WOULD BE NEEDED FOR
THE SMALL EMPLOYERS. OUR TO GET
BACK ON TRACK AS FAR AS AS A
BUSINESS- AND ALL AND THE
REASON I SAY I ASK THIS
QUESTION IS BECAUSE I'VE SEEN
MANY MANY PROGRAMS. WHERE THE
TRAINING IS DONE BUT THERE'S NO
FINAL CONNECTION TO A GOOD JOB.
AND SO IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING
THAT MEN AND WOMEN HAVE TO YOU
KNOW GET THE EXCITEMENT AND
THEY'RE SO MOTIVATED AND THEY
GO THROUGH THESE TRAINING
PROGRAMS. BUT REALLY THERE'S NO
FINAL CONNECTION TO A JOB THEY
GET SOME- GETS THEM TO WORK SO
THAT'S WHERE I'M GOING WITH IT-
AND BUT MISTER BROOKE MILBORNE
GAVE AN EXAMPLE MY BODY FOR YOU
OR HE COULD. JUST COMMENT ON
THAT ONE CERTAINLY I WILL GIVE
MR MILBURN AND OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMONSENSE HE DID GIVE A
SPECIFIC EXAMPLE YOU KNOW AT
THE END OF THE DAY OUR GOAL IS
TO GET THESE FOLKS BACK TO WORK
THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE UNEMPLOYED
AND SO. AGAIN YOU KNOW HAPPY TO
REVIEW EVALUATE LOOKING AT
PERHAPS FUTURE MA'AM AND SHOULD
THAT BE NEED NEED TO BE
CLARIFIED A MADE UP BUT LET ME
GO AHEAD AND TURN IT OVER TO MR
MODI MOD BORNE OUT IF HE'S
STILL AVAILABLE TO. COMMENT YES
YES I'M HERE. AND IN DIVERSE
DATA QUESTION THANK YOU- THE
HEIGHT OF THE RECORDS I WAS
MAKING IS THAT THESE- SMALLER
BUSINESSES ARE CONNECTED. TO
EACH OTHER AND TO OTHER
BUSINESSES. A LARGER BUSINESS
AS A AND- AS YOU KNOW THE
IMPACT- AFFECT SOME OF THE
LARGER BUSINESSES. THE SMALLER
BUSINESSES IT TRICKLES DOWN TO
THEM NOW. YOUR QUESTION
DIRECTLY I THINK THAT- WE
STRIVE TO PROVIDE PROGRAMS THAT
DO LEAD IN A- CAREER PATH%
ORIENTED JOB PLACEMENT. AND
TRAINING AND UPSKILLING THAT
LEADS TO INCREASED WAGES AND
PROMOTIONS ON THE JOB AND SO
THE- YEAH I CAN GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE OF A PROGRAM- IF YOU'D
LIKE ONE- BUT BUT THAT IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT. OF THE
TRAINING AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS THAT WE
RUN- AND THAT ARE- STATEWIDE
NETWORK RUNS- MUST RESULT IN-
YOU KNOW WHAT TYPE OF CAREER
ORIENTED JOB PLACEMENT THAT
PAYS WELL AND HAS FUTURE UPWARD
MOBILITY. AND HE'LL UPSKILLING
WITHIN THE JOBS THAT RESULTS
IN- INDIVIDUALS NOT ONLY
KEEPING THEIR JOB AND BEING
ABLE TO MOVE UP AND EARN HIGHER
WAGES- TO THAT KIND OF ADDRESS
YOUR QUESTION. THIRD ROW ZERO
FOUR WELL- YES I MEAN IN A
BROAD SENSE SO I LOOK FORWARD-
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT
THE RESULTS ARE OF THIS- PILOT
PROGRAM AND HOW. ISSUES LIKE
THAT ARE INCLUDED- IN THE PILOT
TURKISH AID THANK YOU AND A
FIVE A FIVE MADE JUST TO TOUCH
ON THAT AND ADD TO THAT YOU
KNOW WITH THIS PILOT PROGRAM AS
WELL DOESN'T JUST PROVIDE
RELEVANT JOB TRAINING- BUT
ALSO. A THESE INDIVIDUALS WILL
RECEIVE GUIDANCE ON HOW TO
EXPAND ON THEIR TRAINING AND
RECEIVE HIGHER LEVELS-
CERTIFICATES AND EVEN ACADEMIC
CREDIT SO HAPPY TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THOSE WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN THIS. THANK YOU
SOME OF ANYTHING ELSE IN TERMS
OF. CONCERNS ARE DEBATE FROM
THE DAIS- YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH THAT THANK I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. HE WITH THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
RUSSELL AND- WE WILL TAKE THE
ROLE IN AB ELEVEN OH SIX. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COURTESY. OF THE
ARTIST CHAU CHOI BO HI. THE
TROUBLED I'D WRESTLE. WRESTLE I
LAYERED. NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN NINE. OKAY SO WE HAVE
FOUR TWO ZERO BUT WE HAVE ONE
MEMBER OUT SO PLACE A BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU- WE AS A NOTED
EARLIER WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
SOME MEMBER WORKS AT THIS
POINT- RATHER THAN LATER ON THE
AGENDA HE AND THE SUMMER WORKS
WELCOME. SHE'S HERE TO PRESENT
EIGHTY FOUR OH TWO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER SHARE THANK
YOU FOR THE ACCOMMODATION MY
LITTLE ONES APPRECIATE IT- SO
IN MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WERE
LEFT UNEMPLOYED AND CRITICAL
NEED OF ASSISTANCE TO REPLACE
LOST INCOME USED TO PAY FOR
ESSENTIALS SUCH AS HOUSING FOOD
AND CHILD CARE. TO ANY TODAY
MANY CLIMATE STILL LACK ACCESS
TO THE REPLACEMENT INCOME THAT
RIGHTFULLY BELONGS TO THEM DUE
TO VARIOUS SYSTEMATIC ACCESS
ISSUES WHICH WE'VE ALL HEARD
ABOUT IN THE PRESIDENT A MANY
OF US HAVE. EXPERIENCE WITH OUR
OWN OWN FIRST HAND WITH OUR
CONSTITUENTS SEEKING HELP-
COMMITTEE. AB FOUR FOUR TWO
ESTABLISHES THE OFFICE OF
CLIMATE ADVOCACY RESPONSIBLE
FOR PROTECTING CALIFORNIANS
RIGHTS TO SEEK BENEFITS
ADMINISTERED BY EDIE. EXACTLY
THE OCA WILL WORK TO ASSIST
CLAIMS THAT CLAIMANTS AND
RESOLVING VARIOUS SELF REPORTED
VIOLATIONS AND WILL COLLECT
DATA TO IMPROVE CLAIMANTS
ACCESS TO BENEFITS. AB FOUR TO
ALSO ESTABLISH THE STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY GROUP TO INFORM THE
DEPARTMENT WITH POLICY
EXPERTISE AND FIRST HAND
KNOWLEDGE OF CLAIMANT
EXPERIENCES. THIS ADVISORY
GROUP IS CHARGED WITH CREATING
THE CLIMATE BILL OF RIGHTS AND
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH
THE- OCA TO ENSURE POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS ADDRESS THE
IMMEDIATE BEARS CLAIMANTS FACE
WHILE SEEKING ACCESS TO THEIR
BENEFITS. ALTHOUGH ETV HAS MADE
NOTABLE EFFORTS TO IMPROVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OPERATIONS
BOTH THE OCA AND THE
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY GROUP ARE
NEEDED TO ENSURE CLAIMANTS
VOICES AND EXPERIENCES ARE AT
THE FOREFRONT OF FUTURE POLICY
AND SYSTEMATIC CHANGES. MOVING
THIS BILL FORWARD IS CRITICAL
FOR ENSURING CLAIMANTS CAN
ACCESS THEIR BENEFITS WHEN THEY
NEED THE MOST THE BILL HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION AND IS
SUPPORTED BY THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS.
UTILITY WORKERS UNION OF
AMERICA AND MANY OTHER ADVOCACY
GROUPS I KNOW ALL OF YOU ON THE
DICE TODAY AND MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES HAVE DEALT WITH VERY
FRUSTRATED UNDERSTANDABLY
FRUSTRATED CONSTITUENTS WHO
WERE TRYING TO ACCESS THEIR EDT
BENEFITS. THERE WERE SO MANY
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE
STATE THAT WE FAILED. AND IT'S
COMING UPON US TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO BETTER THAT OUR
GOVERNMENT WORKS FOR PEOPLE
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE SENT US HERE
AND IN MY OPINION THIS IS PART
OF THE SOLUTION NOT THE WHOLE
SOLUTION. BUT IT'S PART OF THE
SOLUTION I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SO. WE DON'T WE DO NOT HAVE A
LEAD TO A SUPPORT WHEN THIS
TODAY'S WILL BE DISASTROUS
ANYONE HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WHICH SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. A SEEN NONE AGAIN
THIS IS A BEFORE O. TWO WILL
CHECK YOUR FULL ROOM FOR.
POSSIBLE WITNESSES THERE ARE
NONE. ASSEMBLY NASA MODERATOR
TO PLEASE QUEUE UP. ANY SUPPORT
TESTIMONY ON AB FOUR OH TWO.
AND PLEASE LET US KNOW THE
NUMBER OF WITNESSES IF ANY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
TO SUPPORT. MR CHURTON SNOW
WHEN THE SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK THANK YOU MODERATOR IN
WE DO NOT HAVE A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS ON THIS BILL
SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WISHES TO TAKE A POSITION
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
HAVE SO PLEASE STEP FORWARD
LET'S SEE NO ONE WILL CHECK
AGAIN THE FOUR WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WE SEE NONE
THERE WILL COME BACK TO THE
MODERATOR. AND ASK YOU TO
PLEASE CHECK TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE
BEFORE- TO ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ON THANK YOU.
THANK IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THE TEACHER KNOW
WHEN A SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU MODERATOR THE
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ITSELF
ANY DEBATE OR QUESTIONS
CONCERNS ON THE BILL FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SEEN
NONE- YOU MAY CLOSE TO SOME
HOPE HOLD ON ONE SECOND THE
SENATOR ALSO. SORRY AND THAT'S
OKAY. WHEN A LITTLE FAST MAKING
QUICK- I APPRECIATE THE FOCUS
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE GIVING TO
THE CLAIMANTS- BECAUSE I THINK
OTHERWISE. IT'S UP TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE YOU NEVER KNOW WHERE IT
REALLY COMES UP WITH- AND TO ME
IT KIND OF IS CONNECTED I'M
GOING TO MAKE A PITCH FOR. THE
PROPOSALS TO MAKE CHANGES IN
THE LABOR AGENCY. AS FAR AS A
FOCUS ON THOSE SERVICES LIKE
EDIE D. LIKE LEAVES- LIKE
DISABILITY THOSE ARE REALLY
SPECIFIC. BENEFITS THAT I THINK
ARE REALLY DIFFERENT FROM. THE
WORK FORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE DONE AND
THE LABOR AGENCY BUT I THINK
WITH YOUR BILL. THEY'LL BE THAT
FOCUS THAT'S NEEDED AND I HOPE
THAT WE CAN MAKE EVEN BIGGER
DEEPER CHANGES IN THE LABOR
AGENCY SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND I WILL GIVE ENOUGH TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I JUST
APPRECIATE THAT SENATOR AS I
KNOW THAT'S A CONCERN OF YOURS
AND I THINK. YOU KNOW IN THE
END OF THE DAY WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE- PROVIDING
SERVICE FOR CONSTITUENTS. AND
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT THE
CLAIMANTS EXPERIENCE AND WHAT
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH AND WHAT
THEY'RE LIVING IN THEIR DAY TO
DAY LIFE. WHEN THEY ARE TRYING
TO ACCESS THESE RESOURCES AND
SO I THINK ALL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES TO TAKE THAT INTO
ACCOUNT WHEN FOLKS ARE TRYING
TO ACCESS GOVERNMENT. AND IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON US TO MAKE SURE
GOVERNMENT WORKS BETTER FOR
PEOPLE IN SEARCH OUR
CONSTITUENTS SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
A MOTION. VISITORS CENTER
NEWMAN MOVES THE BILL. AND WILL
COME BACK TO. OUR CONSULTANT
AND ASK HER TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THANK YOU. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COURTESY.
COURTESY I AM A CHOI BOGUE HI
BUT TROUBLED I WRESTLE. WRESTLE
I LAYERED. NEWMAN RIGHT TWO
NINE OKAY YOU HOPEFUL FOR HI
VOTES SOON WILL KEEP THE BILL
ON CALL TWO OR THE MEMBER COMES
BACK THANK YOU. IS- AS WE GET
THE HOUSE IN ORDER HERE WE WILL
WELCOME UP ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ WHO'S HERE TO PRESENT.
ON TWO BILLS IN CONSECUTIVE
ORDER CHEN THE FIRST. EIGHTY
SEVEN OH ONE. BOTH OF THEM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
START BY ACCEPTING ALL THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE WITH US ON
THIS LANGUAGE WHICH RESPONSE TO
SEVERAL THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS TO MAKE TO MAKE IT
NEXT DAY DELIVERY POSSIBLE
CORPORATIONS LIKE AMAZON HAVE
FORCED WAREHOUSE WORKERS TO
MOVE FASTER SERVICE MORE
CUSTOMERS WITH MORE ORDERS IN
RECORD AMOUNT OF TIME AND RISK
THEIR OWN BODIES IN THE
PROCESS. THESE COMPANIES HAVE
CREATED ENVIRONMENT WHERE
WORKERS ARE TREATED LIKE
MACHINES EVERY DAY THEY FACE
CRUSHING WORK SPEEDS TO MEET
RELENTLESS PRODUCTIVITY QUOTAS
THEIR TIME MOVEMENTS AND HOW
QUICKLY THEY CAN PACKAGE UP TO
FOUR HUNDRED ITEMS IN AN HOUR
OFTEN REGARDLESS OF THE SIZE OR
WEIGHT OF THE ITEM IS STRICTLY
MONITORED MINUTES BETWEEN
SCANNING PACKAGES WHERE THEY
ALL GO OVER THEM DETECT THE
WORKERS OFF TASK CAN RESULT IN
AUTOMATIC DISCIPLINE AND EVEN
TERMINATION. CORPORATIONS LIKE
AMAZON OR SETTING THE INDUSTRY
STANDARD. WHAT'S CONSIDERED
COMPETITIVE AND WHEN THE MOST
PHYSICALLY DANGEROUS FIELDS
WORK AND THE NUMBERS DON'T LOOK
GOOD. AMAZON WORKERS ARE
INJURED ON THE JOB AT. AT TWICE
THE AVERAGE RATE OF THE OVERALL
WHERE HOUSING INDUSTRY AND
THREE TIMES THE AVERAGE RATE.
ACROSS ALL PRIVATE EMPLOYERS IN
TWENTY TWENTY AMAZON SERIOUS
INJURY RATE WAS 80% HIGHER THAN
THE RATE FOR ALL OTHER
WAREHOUSING EMPLOYERS. ALMOST
89% OF THOSE INJURED WORKERS
HAD TO MISS WORK AND EXPERIENCE
LONGER RECOVERY PERIODS THAN
OTHER WAREHOUSE WORKERS. THESE
DANGEROUS PRACTICES ARE CAUSING
AMAZON TO CHURN THROUGH WORKERS
AT AN UNPRECEDENTED RATE AND
IT'S SIMPLY UNSUSTAINABLE. THE
ANNUAL TURNOVER RATE FOR
WAREHOUSE WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES WITH AMAZON
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS HAS SHOT
UP TO OVER A 100% A YEAR A
HUNDRED PERCENT. TURNOVER IN AN
INDUSTRY A YEAR. WORKERS HAVE
REPEATEDLY GOT INJURED ON THE
JOB BECAUSE THEY WERE FORCED TO
RUSH THROUGH SAFETY PROTOCOLS
TO TRY AND MEET GREAT. YET MOST.
STILL CANNOT SPEAK OUT FOR FEAR
OF LOSING THEIR JOB. WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO SPECIFY IN
LAW THAT WORKERS HAVE THE RIGHT
TO USE THE BATHROOM INSTEAD OF
URINATING IN. WHEREVER THEY
CAN'T OR WHEN THEY CAN THAT
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO WASH THEIR
HANDS AND SANITIZER EQUIPMENT
DURING A PANDEMIC. WE CAN'T
STAND BY AND ACCEPT THAT THESE
UNDIGNIFIED AN UNSAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS ARE THE NEW FUTURE
WORK IT'S CLEAR THAT A CHANGE
IN LAW IS LONG OVERDUE. AB
SEVEN NO ONE WOULD MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT WORKERS COULD NOT BE
DISCIPLINED FOR FAILING TO MEET
A QUOTA THAT DIDN'T ALLOW THEM.
TO COMPLY WITH EXISTING HEALTH
AND SAFETY LAWS IN THE LABOR
CODE. THAT COMPLIANCE TIME
COULD NOT BE COUNTED AGAINST
THEM IS BEING OFF TASK. IF A
WORKER FACES DISCIPLINE WITHIN
NINETY DAYS AFTER THEY FILED A
COMPLAINT. ABOUT HEALTH AND
SAFETY CONCERNS RELATED TO A
QUOTA. IN AB SEVEN OH ONE WOULD
CREATE A REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION
THAT THE ADVERSE ACTION TAKEN
BY THE COMPANY WAS RETALIATORY.
AB SEVEN A ONE BUT ALSO ALLOWS
STATE AGENCIES TO INSPECT
WAREHOUSE QUOTA RECORDS WHEN
THEY RECEIVE WORKER COMPLAINTS.
INTERNET CAL OSHA TO CRAFT
WAREHOUSE SAFETY STANDARDS TO
MINIMIZE WORKER INJURIES IN
WAREHOUSES THE USE PRODUCTION
QUOTAS. THIS BILL ONLY APPLIES
TO LARGE WAREHOUSES WITH MORE
THAN A THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
STATEWIDE OR HUNDRED IN A
SINGLE LOCATION. WE WORK HARD
TO TAKE SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS. INCLUDING DEFINING
HEALTH AND SAFETY LAWS.
SPECIFYING THAT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S ROLE IN
ENFORCEMENT. COULD FIND THAT
EMPLOYERS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
CURE ANY ALLEGED VIOLATIONS
UNDER PAGA. AND WE PREVIOUSLY
REMOVED NOTICE REQUIREMENTS AND
OBLIGATIONS FOR EMPLOYERS TO
UPDATE EMPLOYEES ON THE QUOTE
IS EVERY TIME THEY CHANGE.
SHOULD THE COMMITTEE PASSES
BILL WE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK. WITH THE
OPPOSITION IN DISCUSSIONS TO
SEE WHAT ELSE WE CAN DO TO
ALLEVIATE THEIR CONCERNS. IT'S
CLEAR THAT SOMETHING HAS TO
HAPPEN. IT IS CLEAR THAT NOBODY
WOULD SUGGEST THAT AMAZON
WORKERS IN PARTICULAR BUT
WORKERS IN LARGE WAREHOUSES
THAT USE ALDER THEM'S. ARE
GETTING HURT AT
DISPROPORTIONATE RATES. WHAT'S
NOT CLEAR IS WHAT ANYBODY WANTS
TO DO ABOUT IT. THAT SEEMS TO
BE THE PROBLEM WITH THE
OPPOSITION- THAN THEIR CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS BILL. THEY THINK-
THE LAW SHOULD TAKE IT. TAKE IT
IS TAKING CARE OF IT DESPITE
THESE ASTONISHING NUMBERS. I
HAVE A WITNESS TESTIMONY ON
THE- ON THE PHONES ROSE MERRY
MOLINA THE ORGANIZING DIRECTOR
FOR THE LA FEDERATION OF LABOR.
AND SAYS R. CASPER. THE UPS A
UPS WAREHOUSE WORKER. THANK YOU
SOME FOR. ROSE MARIE MOLINA IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE YOU MAY
PROCEED TO TESTIFY AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M ON CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF MY MILLION
ORGANIZING DIRECTOR FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR. WE WORK WITH THOUSANDS
OF WAREHOUSE WORKERS IN LA.
WHERE HOUSING HAS GROWN
DRAMATICALLY SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC WITH
THE NUMBER OF FACILITIES
CRIPPLING IN OUR REGION. MORE
COMPANIES ARE COMPETING TO MEET
ONE DAY AND TWO HOUR DELIVERY
BUT THERE'S A HUMAN COST THIS
CONVENIENCE. I'VE SPOKEN TO
WORKERS IN THE EARLY TWENTIETH
TWO OF TORN LIGAMENTS HAVE
BOXES ON THEIR HEADS AND WALK
UP TO TWENTY MILES A DAY TO
MEET THE FAST PACE OF THE WORK.
pINJURIES THAT LEAD THEM OUT OF
THE WORKFORCE FOR MONTHS AT A
TIME. WORKERS ARE REPEATING TO
IT IT'S JUST IMPOSSIBLE TO KEEP
UP WITH THE RATE. WE NEED
EIGHTY SEVEN I WONDER
TRANSPARENCY IN FOR PROTECTION.
I WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE ARGUMENTS WE HAVE HEARD
FROM THE OPPOSITION. BIRTH
ABILITY TO BROADEN GEGEN
REFERENCE TO HEALTH AND SAFETY
LAWS- ARE RESPONSIVE ADDED
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT I'M NOT BETTER FOR
HELPING US TO TIGHTEN UP IN
LIMITS HOW WE DEFINE THOSE
TERMS FOR THE ARE NARROWLY
TAILORED. TO OCCUPATIONAL
HEALTH REQUIREMENTS. THE LABOR
CODE. HELLO SHOULD STANDARD.
SECOND THAT THIS BILL. WILL IN.
CATION ARE IS CAN. IT'S THE
KEYBOARD STATE. EXISTING ONE
FAILED TO ADEQUATELY FOR.
WORKERS LIKE ALL. INJURIES DUE
TO THE PACE OF WORK
REQUIREMENTS. AGENCIES HAVE
FAILED TO ADEQUATELY PROTECT
WORKERS EVEN IN THE MIDST OF A
PANDEMIC THAT IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY BECAUSE
ILLNESS AND DEATH FOR WORKING
PEOPLE OF COLOR. IN CALIFORNIA.
NEVERTHELESS WE AMENDED THE
BILL TO CLARIFY THAT EMPLOYERS
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
VIOLATIONS. OUR GOAL IS NOT TO
PENALIZE EMPLOYERS. IS TO
PROTECT WORKERS AND PREVENT
INJURIES. WE'RE COMMITTED TO
MAKING SURE THAT THIS BILL IS
WORKABLE AFFAIRE. WE HAVE TAKEN
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS AN
EFFORT TO ADDRESS SOME QUITE
OPPOSITION AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK TO ADDRESS ADDITIONAL
ISSUE. BUT WE CANNOT AND WILL
NOT SETTLE FOR A BILL THAT
FAILED TO PROTECT WORKERS FROM
PREVENTABLE INJURIES. I WANT
SETTLE FOR A BILL THAT LEAVES
WORKERS WITH NO RECOURSE WHEN
STATE AGENCIES FAILED TO ACT.
NORMALLY SETTLE FOR A BILL.
THAT ALLOWS WHERE HEALTH
COMPANY TO CONTINUE TO TREAT
WORKERS AS DISPOSABLE. AMAZON
IS NOW THE BIGGEST EMPLOYER IN
CALIFORNIA AND IS SETTING
STANDARDS THROUGHOUT THE
INDUSTRY. WAREHOUSES HERE HAVE
THREE TIMES THE INJURY RATE AND
150% YEARLY TURNOVER IN SOME
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA.
WASHINGTON STATE OSHA HAS FOUND
DIRECT TIES BETWEEN AMAZON
PIECE OF WORK REQUIREMENTS AND
THEIR INJURY RATE. AND IT'S
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO SET
MINIMUM STANDARDS TO PROTECT
VULNERABLE WERE HEALTH WORKERS.
IN OUR GREAT STATE. OUR THING
OF WORK SHOULDN'T HURT EIGHTY
SEVEN NO ONE HELPS TO SET THAT
STANDARD. WE URGE YES VOTE
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK RETURNS.
HAS SAYS COSTA- ARE YOU ON THE
IF YOU ARE. YOU MAY PRESS. YEAH
COME ON I CAN HEAR YOU YES WE
CAN HEAR LONGER THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR LETTING
ME SPEAK TODAY. MY NAME IS EVA
CASTRO AND I'M A UPS WORKER FOR
SEVEN YEARS AND A MEMBER OF
TEAMSTERS LOCAL NINETY SIX. OR
HOUSE WORKING VERY BRUTAL NOT
EVERYONE REALIZED THE TOLL IT
TAKES ON YOUR BODY. DOING IT
EVERY DAY. FOR AND IT IS THE
TIME YOUR BODY STARTS TO HURT
ANY. I DON'T WANT TO SHARE BUT
I WANT TO SHARE WITH IT LIKE A
UPS TO SHOW THAT IT'S POSSIBLE
TO WORK HARD. WORK FAST AND
WORKSTATION. I WORK IN SMALL
START AND IT'S MONSTER WE HAVE
TO PRODUCE CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
PACKAGES PER MINUTE. AND
WINDOWS PACKAGES PER MINUTE WE
DON'T HAVE COMPLAIN OVER OUR
HEAD REST YOU KNOW OUR MAKING
US FEEL LIKE WE'RE FALLING
BEHIND. WE HAVE TO MEET THE
COMPANY STANDARDS BUT WE DON'T
HAVE TO HAVE THE BRUTALITY THAT
WORKERS HAVE AN AMAZON. AND
WALK AND WHILE MY WAREHOUSES.
OUR WORK IS FAST PACED BUT WE
STILL BUT WE'RE STILL WORKING
STAGE. I'M THANKFUL FOR THE
LOCAL AND THE COMPANY THAT
COMES TOGETHER AND MAKES A
SAFE. SAFER WORK ENVIRONMENT
FOR IT. EVERY DAY WHEN YOU. GO
TO WORK. YOU REACH. WE RISK
INJURY YOURSELF SEEN A CO.
GETTING I THINK THE BIG. FOR
MICHAEL. BECAUSE WE KNOW HOW.
THE JOB CAN BE. ENTERED CAN IN
GIVEN. FUNDING CAN FOLLOW IT
YOU CAN BE CHAOTIC.
KNOWLEDGEABLE COMING IN AND
OUT. I'M GOING TO BE FOR
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. THERE HAVE
BEEN TIMES THAT I'VE BEEN TOLD
TO DO A TASK THAT IS IN PHASE.
I HAVE GONE TO MY SUPERVISOR
AND I REFUSED TO DO IT. I HAVE
THE ABILITY TO GO TO. TO GO TO
MY SUPERVISORS WITH PROTECTION
OF MY UNION. I DON'T HAVE THE-
UNLIKELY FEAR SPEAKING. UP AND
LOSING MY JOB WHEN I DECLINED
TO WORK. IT THEY DIDN'T SAY. IT
MY RIGHT IT'S A MY BODY. I
DON'T. I UNDERSTAND IT IS
WORKING. AT THE END OF THE DAY
I HAVE TO THE HOME PROVIDE FOR
MYSELF AND MY FAMILY THIS IS MY
HUMAN RIGHT AND I KNOW MY LOCAL
HAVE MY BACK AS WELL. I DON'T
HAVE TO PERFORM WORK AT IN
STATE WORKING STATE CAN BE DONE
I'M ATTACHING IT TO THAT
WORKERS SHOULD IF YOU'RE
FIGHTING FOR A SAFE ENVIRONMENT
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL IS ABOUT.
THIS WORK SHOULD BE DONE
WITHOUT. DOUBT SO MUCH INJURY I
HEARD YOUR SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
SEVEN A ONE THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER CONSTRUED HOME
WE'RE GOING TO ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVEN OH ONE OF SO PLEASE
STEP FORWARD. C. NONE WE WILL
CHECK YOUR FULL ROOM FOR
TESTIMONY WE SEE NO ONE THERE
TO TESTIFY. AND WE'RE GONNA S.
MODERATED PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
SUPPORT WITNESSES FOR A. B.
SEVEN OH ONE. AND PLEASE LET US
KNOW THE AMOUNT IF ANY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MISTER CHERYL I APOLOGIZE WE
ALSO WANT TO ALERT YOU TO THE
FACT THAT WE MAY HAVE HAD
PEOPLE WHO. HAD WISHED TO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WANTED TO
SPEAK ON A PREVIOUS BILLS. WHO
WERE UNABLE TO DO SO AT THAT
TIME- WE WILL. PROCEED WITH
THE- PEOPLE WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE CURRENT BILL
BUT I LEAVE IT YOU. WOULD LIKE
TO DO WITH THE- PREVIOUS PEOPLE.
JUST A MOMENT. AND JUST ANOTHER
MOMENT WE DO HAVE SOMEONE THAT
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK WITH REGARD TO THIS BILL
AS A REMINDER TO THE WITNESSES
YOUR PHONE LINES ARE OPEN
PLEASE USE TO MUTE BUTTON WHEN
NOT ARE CALLED UPON TO SPEAK.
GOING TO GO TO LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT ONE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE. IS OPEN. HI JOSH YOUR
CONVEY ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN
ALL. BY. FIFTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEDIA THE NEEDS THAT
ARE GOING STRONG SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY SEVEN NO ONE OUR
WAREHOUSE WORKER RESEARCH
CENTER WORKSAFE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER AND PUBLIC COUNCIL THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIR WE DO HAVE
PEOPLE THAT MAY HAVE WISHED TO
SPEAK I'M PREVIOUS BILLS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PROCEED WITH THEM
OR WAIT UNTIL WE'RE FINISHED-
DISCUSSING THIS BILL NO WE
CAN'T TAKE THEM NOW BECAUSE THE
SUBJECT MATTER HAS CHANGED AT
THIS MOMENT HOWEVER- WE GET AN
OPPORTUNITY LATER. A
PARTICULARLY AT THE TIME WHEN
WE LIFT THE- A CALL SO TO SPEAK
WHEN WE CALL IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS TOWARD THE END OF
TODAY'S AGENDA. OF AS A MATTER
OF COURTESY AND THEIR THEIR
RIGHT TO SPEAK WILL GIVE THEM%
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK-
OBVIOUSLY THEY WILL STILL BE
LIMITED TO THEIR NAME- THEIR
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. BUT
WE NEED TO DO THAT. WHEN WE'RE
NOT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
SUBJECT MATTER OF A DIFFERENT
BILL THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR LETTING US KNOW. BUT THAT'S
A IT'S THEIR PRODUCT OF WHICH
TO STAY ON THE LINE UNTIL THAT
OINT IN TIME BUT IT MAY BE- TO
GIVE YOU AN ESTIMATE. I'M
GUESSING TO BE OVER AN HOUR
BEFORE WE GET TO THAT POINT OF
THE AGENDA. THANK YOU. THE END
OF APRIL. MISTER CHAIR PARDON
ME AGAIN- JUST SO THAT WE'RE
WE'RE CLEAR ON THIS I TOTALLY
UNDERSTOOD WHAT YOU'D LIKE TO
DO WITH THE PREVIOUS BILLS. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO STILL WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
SPECIFIC BILL WE'RE DISCUSSING
RIGHT NOW. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AGAIN. AND THERE IS NO
WENT OUT TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OKAY
THANK YOU FOR DOUBLE CHECKING-
WE'RE GOING NOW TO OPPOSITION
AND WE DO HAVE. AN OPPOSITION
WITNESS ROBERT MUTRIE. HEY YOU
MAY PROCEED IF YOU'RE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ON MR MOULTRIE.
YES THANK YOU A LITTLE OF THE
WEATHER BUT HOPEFULLY I'LL SEE
YOU ALL AGAIN SOON- AGAIN
ROBERT MUTRIE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE NEAR
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
SEVEN I WON A JOB KILLER. QUICK
CLARIFICATION. THE BILL DOES
NOT AFFECT ONLY ONE COMPANY ARE
TOO WHICH IS WHY OUR COALITION
COVERS AGRICULTURE
MANUFACTURING LOGISTICS AND A
RANGE OF INDUSTRIES EVERYBODY
WHO USES WAREHOUSE. I'M
GENERALLY SPEAKING I WANT TO BE
CLEAR ABOUT SOMETHING THAT I'M
I'M GLAD THE SECOND GROUP TO
DELIVER THAT WORKERS ALREADY
HAVE SHOULD AND DO HAVE THE
RIGHT USED BATHROOMS WASH THEIR
HANDS BUT STILL NOT CREATE NEW
SUBSTANTIVE PROTECTION PERRANCE
SAID IT IN OUR ON OURCONCERNS
AT THIS AYE PAGA INTO A NEW
PLACE FOR POCKET UP AND WORK TO
CREATE THE PERENNIAL
PRESUMPTION OF RETALIATION THAT
CAN LAST FOR ENTIRE CAREER
ENDED AT THE DUPLICATIVE
REGULATION REGULATION CALLOSUM
FELDER WHERE OUR CONCERNS ARE
WITH THE BILL I SHOULD BE CLEAR
NOTABLY MY TESTIMONY IS FOCUSED
ON THE ISSUES THAT REMAIN AFTER
THE COMMITTEE AMOUNT. WHICH WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE BUT DO NOT
RESOLVE OUR CORE CONCERNS AT
THE PAGA EXPANSION OUR PERSONAL
SIR BILL ALLOWS OUR- FOR ALL
OUR STATE- HEALTH AND SAFETY
LAWS REGULATION. BUT DOES NOT
PRESERVE EXISTING PROCEDURAL
FOR CAL OSHA RELATED PAGA
CLAIMS NOTABLY UNDER CURRENT
LAW HE CLAIMED MEET THE
PARTICULAR REQUIREMENTS ARE
LAID OUT LABOR CODE TWENTY SIX
NINETY NINE POINT THREE BE.
MAINLY NEED ON THE TRANSPLANT
LIST PROVIDED TO CALLOW CHAU
AND CALIFORNIA. FIRST RT JUST
BUT ADDRESS THAT THEY- TO MAKE
SURE FOLLOW THE PATTERN THAT
ARE THE KEY MARKET TRENDS THE
PARK MANAGER- I DON'T HAVE TIME
TO ADDRESS THE RIGHT IT TO
CAROLINE. THAT THE- FIX OUR
CONCERN- HELLO FOR TO TALK THE
AUTHOR ABOUT IT- I THINK IT'S
THE BILL COULD DIFFICULT
REGULATION- A TELEVISION.
ALREADY HAS A REGULATION FOLKS
AND REPETITIVE MOTION INJURIES
MUSCULOSKELETAL INJURIES- ADDED
ET ARE. SECTION FIFTY ONE TEN
THE BILL CREDIT CALLED A
DUPLICATIVE REGULATIONS STATE
THAT WE THINK IT SHOULD BE
AMENDED IN. THAT COMPLEX. SHARE
THE BILL COULD NEVER AN
EXEMPTION RETALIATION ISSUE
HERE IS WHENEVER I REQUEST MY
DATA I HAVE A NINETY DAY OPTION
OF. RETALIATION FOR ANY
DISCIPLINE AND I'VE BEEN
REQUESTED. I'M SORRY OUT OF THE
BAG REQUESTED REPEATEDLY AND
THEREFORE TRIGGER THE
PRESUMPTION ON GOING- FOR THOSE
REASONS I- WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE A. B. SEVEN A ONE. OF
THE JOB KILLER I THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. EVERYTHING
MOTION APPRECIATE- WITH THE
TIME LIMITS- THAT WAS TO. A
WE'RE GONNA COME TO THE ROOM
AND ASKED ANYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO.
TAKE IN OPPOSE POSITION ON THIS
BILL. C. KNOWN COME FORWARD
WILL CHECK YOUR FULL ROOM. AT
SEA NO ONE THERE- I'M GONNA S.
MODERATELY QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN OH ONE END. AFTER
YOU'RE DONE WITH THAT MISTER
MODERATOR- IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
CHECK THE SUPPORT LINE ONE MORE
TIME I KNOW THAT THE COMMITTEE
STAFF WAS CONTACTED THAT
SOMEBODY DIDN'T GET THROUGH WE
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE GIVE.
THEM AN OPPORTUNITY SO WE'LL
TAKE OPPOSITION NOW AND THEN
COME BACK AND CHECK THAT
SUPPORT Q. ONE MORE TIME THANK
YOU. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
PRESS ONE BEEN TERRIBLE TIME
PRESS. ONE ZERO. SURE NO ONE IS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU-
UNDERSTOOD AND IF YOU COULD
JUST. A IF IT'S TECHNICALLY
POSSIBLE TO CHECK OR CALL FOR
SUPPORT WHEN THIS IS ONE MORE
TIME AND CHECK THAT LINE OR
THOSE WINDS- AGAIN WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T CUT SOMEBODY
OFF EARLIER ON THIS BILL. THIS
IS FOR A. B. SEVEN ONE STILL.
AND WE ARE GOING TO- GO AGAIN
HERE. TWO INVITE THOSE THAT
WISH TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT.
ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR.
THE
FUTURE WE DO APOLOGIZE FOR THE
DELAY JUST ANOTHER MOMENT BY.
THAT'S CORRECT. WE'RE NOT GOING
ANYWHERE. ALTHOUGH SOME PEOPLE
IN THE ROOM PROBABLY HAVE
PLACES TO GO.
WE JUST EXPLAIN
TO THOSE LISTENING IN THOSE HER
PRESENT THAT THE JUST A
QUESTION BECAUSE OF SOME
REPEATED COMMENTS HE HEARD SOME
EARLIER FOR THE MODERATOR AND
WE RECEIVE SOME DIRECTLY TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF THAT SOME FOLKS
TO GET THROUGH ON COMMENTARY
SEPARATE BILLS- IN A RAISES THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER THERE'S A
SYSTEM ISSUE OR IF THE SYSTEM
NEEDS TO BE REBOOTED OR-
SOMETHING ALONG THOSE LINES-
AND I. T. ISSUE- SO. FOLKS ARE
TAKING A LOOK AT THAT NOW THE
MODERATORS SO. TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT. IN THE MEANWHILE THAT
ANYONE'S ON THE LINE WHO'S ON
THE LINE AND THIS BILL IS SO
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
MR CHAIRMAN AGAIN I APOLOGIZE
FOR THE DELAY WE ARE ATTEMPTING
TO RESOLVE THE ISSUE I
APOLOGIZE AGAIN. WE NEED
ANOTHER MOMENT PLACE OKAY THANK
YOU FOR THE UPDATE.
BUT MR
CHAIRMAN AGAIN I APOLOGIZE FOR
THE DELAY I'M GOING TO TELL YOU
OF RESOLVE THE ISSUE THIS IS
GOING TO TAKE US- PROBABLY A
MINUTE OR SO I WILL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH YOU SIR. THE CITY OF
DIETZEN THEM AGAIN FOR THOSE
WHO ARE PRESENT IN THOSE
LISTENING. ORDINARILY WE HAD.
AN ISSUE THAT WE THOUGHT WAS
GOING TO TAKE A FEW MINUTES WE
WOULD RECESS I HATE TO DO THAT
TODAY BECAUSE- FOR ONE THING
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE BILL
PRESENTATION AND SECONDLY IT'S
HARD TO GET EVERYONE BACK. IN
TIME AND ALSO AWKWARD
SOMETIMES. SITTING HERE BUT IF
YOU TURN YOUR MICROPHONES OFF-
THOSE WHO HAVE MICROPHONES AND
YOU NEED TO. BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE INFORMAL FOR A MINUTE I
WOULD SAY STAY IN THE ROOM DO
THAT AND WE'LL JUST I'LL JUST
BANG THE GAVEL AND DRAWS BACK
TO ATTENTION AS SOON AS WE NEED
TO START- BUT I'D WANT TO TAKE
A FORMAL REVIEW SAYS HERE- THE
LASTTIME I DID THAT IT. SERVES
BACK ABOUT FIFTEEN TWENTY
MINUTES. IT WAS. WEEK I THINK.
SECURA I HAVE HEARD AND I WOULD
LIKE TO AGAIN TRY AND GET
PEOPLE WHO SYMBOL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK OF WITH REGARD TO
THIS BILL. THANK YOU TO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN PLAYS.
OKAY AND- AGAIN- MATURE I
BELIEVE I DO HAVE PEOPLE IN Q.
IT IS HOPE THAT THEY DO WISH TO
SPEAK WITH REGARD TO THE
CURRENT BILL THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE SPEAKING ON NOW BUT IF
NOT. IF YOU'RE IN QUEUE AND NOT
FOR THIS BILL WE ASK THAT YOU
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN TO
REMOVE YOURSELF FROM THE QUEUE
AND YOU WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK LATER ON.
RESHAPE EVERYONE'S PATIENCE.
THE GO TO LINE SEVENTY FOUR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN- CAITLYN BAKER
OF THE HEALTH OF THE TEAMSTERS
PORT DIVISION ELECTRICAL ELEVEN
AND JOBS TO MOVE AMERICA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN OH
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
THINK WE'RE ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
LINE. SEVENTY FIVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS RENEE
BAYARDO WITH SEIU CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT. BLIND FIFTY
ONE. OUR OVER TOLD ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY WAGE
THEFT COLLISION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE. SIXTY FIVE.
AUSTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
LINE. SIXTY SIX. UNITED
STEELWORKERS DISTRICT TWELVE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE. EIGHTY
SIX. FINALLY THE SEXUAL ONES
OPEN. TO MOVE ON TO LINE NINETY
FOUR. MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO EXPORT. AND AGAIN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK UP IN SUPPORT FOR I
BELIEVE EVEN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL WE'RE GOING TO INVITE YOU
TO PRESS ONE AND ZERO SO LONG
IT IS FOR THE BILL BUT BEING
DISCUSSED PRESENTLY. PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. GOING TO GO TO
LINE. EIGHTY SIX. HELLO AGAIN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. AND WE
HAVE ONE THAT WE HAVE- TWO
ADDITIONAL UP PHONE LINES THAT
HAVE SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. I'M GONNA GO TO LINE.
FORTY FIVE. ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES SORRY GOOD
AFTERNOON BRIAN LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO LINE. NINETY SIX.
YEAH JOINT COMMITTEE CALIFORNIA
HISPANIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. BLIND.
EIGHTY SEVEN. TRAGER MEMBERS
STEVE MCCARTY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIR I BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE ACCOUNTED FOR AT
EVERYONE WHO WISHED TO SPEAK
WITH REGARD TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU ORDERED APPRECIATE WORKING
THROUGH THAT- IN AGAIN AS A
REMINDER WILL COME BACK TO
ANYONE THAT DROPPED OFF OR WAS
IT CALLED UPON PRIOR BILLS WHEN
WE GET A CHANCE TO DO SO IF
THEY CAN BE PATIENT. ON THIS
BILL AB SEVEN A ONE IS OR-
ANYTHING- THAT MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS
AT THIS TIME. CENTER NEWMAN.
THANK YOU MISTERTO FIRST I
WANT TO COMMEND THE MODERATOR
FOR COMMITTING ITSELF BACK ON
TRACK- THAT'S NOT EASY TO DO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ NICE
TO SEE YOU I'M BY BECOME KIND
OF A CONSPIRACY WERE OF- CAMINO
SHE'S ALWAYS IMPRESSED WHEN YOU
BRING A BILL. THAT COMES WITH
THE LONGEST LIST OF SUPPORTERS
THAT ANYBODY'S EVER SEEN. ALSO
TYPICALLY WITH THE LONGEST LIST
OF OPPOSITION- SO I GUESS WE'RE
DOING SOMETHING IMPORTANT HERE
I DO HAVE A BUNCH OF QUESTIONS.
BUT ON THE AMENDMENT AMENDMENT
NINE IT REFERS TO- PERSONAL
WORK SPEED DATA- AND I'M NOT AN
EXPERT IN THE SHOWS IS SET UP I
MEAN IS IT A TERM OF ART WILL
EVERYBODY. INVOLVED IS THERE AN
ACCEPTED DEFINITION TO THAT IF
SOMEBODY REQUEST THEIR-
PERSONAL WORK SPEED DATA
PURSUANT TO PARAGRAPH ONE-
WOULD ALL EMPLOYERS INCLUDING
AMAZON KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS IS
AN ACCEPTED DEFINITION FOR THAT
I WOULD EXPECT THAT WE'VE NEVER
ACTUALLY- BEEN ASSET BECAUSE
THOSE COMPANIES THAT HAVE THAT
DATA. KNOW WHAT IT IS AND THAT
WOULD BE AMAZON COMPANIES THAT
DON'T USE QUOTAS AND PERSONAL
WORK SPEED DATA- GET WE'VE
WE'VE HAD QUESTIONS FROM WHAT
SOMEWHERE HOUSES THAT ARE LIKE.
WE DON'T KNOW THEY GET THE JOB
DONE YET THAT'S NOT WHAT WITH
THAT'S NOT WHO WERE. PERTAIN
THIS BILL TO SO THOSE WHO HAVE
IT DO YOU KNOW WHAT APPRECIATE
BUT I EAN SO. HOW DO WE MAKE
THAT DISTINCTION BETWEEN THOSE
WHO DO AND THOSE WHO DON'T IF.
YOU DON'T HAVE A QUOTA YOU'RE
NOT TRACKING BY ALDER THEM THE
WORK SPEED OF OUR OR THE OR THE
WORK SPEED HOW MUCH YOU'RE
DOING THEN IT DOESN'T APPLY THE
BILL. IN ESSENCE DOESN'T TO
THERE'S A REASON WE CLEAR
DIVISION HAS TO RELATE TO
ALGORITHMIC TRACKING OF
PRODUCTIVITY. AT FISHER THAT TO
ON ON THE NINETY DAYS IS
BETTER. MR MOULTRIE MENTIONED
HIS B. IS THERE ANY THOUGHT
GIVEN TO DEMEAN I DON'T TAKE
SERIOUSLY HIS. CONCERNED LIKE
YOU KNOW THAT THAT IS. AT LEAST
THEORETICALLY SUBJECT TO GAMING
LIKE WHAT WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON. PREVENTING AN
EMPLOYEEFROM USING THAT
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION AS A WAY
OF. STAVING OFF. MANAGEMENT WE
ARE WORKING THROUGH AND I
ANTICIPATE WILL TAKE- ANOTHER
SET OF AMENDMENTS COMING OUT
WE'RE WORKING PACKED WITH THE
STAFF OF THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL
AS IF THEY SHOULD MOVE THE NEXT
COMMITTEE. TO TALK ABOUT
LIMITING THAT TO A ONE TIME-
USE FOR THE PERSONAL DATA- THE
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION OF
PERSONAL DATA SAID THAT IT
WOULDN'T BE GAME MOBILE FEEL
WELL. THAT AND THEN ON TO MY
LEAST FAVORITE- TOPICS PAGA- IT
AGAIN THERE THERE'S A CONCERN
HERE THAT THAT INTRODUCING THE
POCKET ON HERE. MIGHT MIGHT
SERVE MATURE EXPAND CARGO
ACROSS A BUNCH OF SPHERES WHICH
WHICH MY SPEAKING TO THAT. WELL
WE DON'T ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S TRUE AND THERE'S NOTHING
TO SUGGEST THERE'S NO CASE LAW
TO SUGGEST THAT THAT'S TRUE WE
ARE LOOKING DEEPER INTO THAT IF
NECESSARY WE CAN- FURTHER
CLARIFY THE POT. THAT PORTION
OF THIS BILL. ONLY IS. IN THE
BILL WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT SURE-
THAT. COULD USE FOR COUNTY-
COUNTY NECESSARILY LIKE THAT
HAVE THEIR OWN. RULES AND
REGULATIONS- AS FAR AS THE
OTHER THINGS THAT WERE BROUGHT
UP ABOUT PROJECT. I FEEL LIKE
IT'S A LITTLE DISINGENUOUS TO
BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
CHAMBER. THEY LIKE TO CALL THEM
EVERYTHING IN THIS BILL ABSURD
BUT IT'S ABSURD TO SUGGEST THAT
WERE WERE SAYING THE RIGHT TO
CURE ON PAGA IS ONLY. THE
ELEMENT THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THAT ONE ON YOU NOT
LOOKING AT TWENTY SIX NINE NINE
POINT THREE AS A WHOLE. SO
WE'RE WE'RE WILLING TO CLARIFY
THAT LANGUAGE AND CONTINUE TO
CLARIFY THAT LANGUAGE. WE PUT
THE SPECIFICALLY PUT IN THAT
THIS IS SUBJECT TO WRITE HERE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE NOT
EXPANDING PADA AS FAR AS A
RESULTING IN- I NECESSARY IF
YOU WELL LITIGATION THAT. FOR
LITIGATION SAKE WE WANT PEOPLE
TO. BE ABLE TO GET THEIR JOB
BACK IF THEY'VE BEEN FIRED TO
BE ABLE TO- CHANGE THE
CONDITIONS UNDER WHICH THEY ARE
GETTING INJURED- WE'RE NOT
LOOKING TO. JUST PAY PEOPLE
COMPENSATION THERE ARE OTHER
WAYS TO DO THAT. SHOULD THAT BE
WHAT ONE OF THE POINTS I MAKE
IS WITH RESPECT TO PAGA. AND
APPLYING CARGO TO- THE FORTUNE
OF REGULATIONS IN WHICH CLEARLY
HAS SOME LARGE IMPLICATIONS SO
AGAIN THEY'VE SHOWN US NO
REASON TO BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL DOES WERE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THAT PIECE WE'VE WE'VE
ACTUALLY. CONTACTED OUTSIDE
ATTORNEYS YOU KNOW THAT IT
WASN'T FLAGGED AS SOMETHING
FROM FROM- ARE LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL THAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING WE ARE CONTINUING TO LOOK
AT THAT. WE THINK IT'S A RED
HERRING BUT WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT TO ENSURE THAT IT
DOESN'T DO THAT INTO. MOVING
KIND OF IN A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION. WITH RESPECT TO
CALLOW SHUCKS- THEY MADE THE
POINT THAT DID MANAGE THESE
ISSUES CAN BE ADDRESSED
SPECIFICALLY. THROUGH AN BY CAL
OSHA SO WHY DO THIS
pLEGISLATIVELY AS OPPOSED TO FOR
US IN SENDING A LETTER. TO CAL
OSHA URGING AND MAKE THE
APPROPRIATE CHANGES WERE
ACTUALLY TELLING THAT'S WHAT
LEGISLATIVE WE'RE DOING WHERE
WHERE. WHERE FORCING HELLO
SHOULD TO DO THIS WHAT THEY'RE
CONCERNED WITH THERE ARE
REFERENCING IS EXISTING
REGULATIONS OR STANDARDS IN CAL
OSHA BUT THOSE STANDARDS ARE
ACTUALLY- NOT SUFFICIENT AND
THAT IS THE WHOLE REASON THAT
WE'RE HERE TODAY SO. WHEN THEY
TALK ABOUT REPETITIVE- THE
REPORT OF INJURY STANDARD TO
CAL OSHA HAS BASICALLY THAT
SAYS A COMPANY HAS TO HAVE. YOU
KNOW A POLICY AND PROCEDURE AND
THAT THEY HAVE TO. TALK TO
THEIR EMPLOYEES ABOUT IT WELL
THAT'S HAPPENING AND YET STILL
WE'RE SEEING THIS
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
INJURIES AND IT'S NOT JUST
REPETITIVE USE INJURIES IT'S A
VARIETY OF THINGS THAT ARE
MAKING THIS WORKSPACE. AND SAFE
SO TO SUGGEST THAT STANDARDS
THAT EXIST CURRENTLY AND THAT
WE ASSUME OF COURSE AMAZON AND
EVERYBODY ELSE IS A PRIME BY.
WHICH AREN'T STANDARD TELL YOU
AND I WOULD THINK OF STANDARDS
IT'S NOT SAYING YOU CAN'T DO
THIS FOR YOU YOU THIS IS THIS
IS TOO FAST THIS IS GOING TO
MUCH. THIS IS EXPECTING TOO
MUCH OF A RATE OF SPEED. OR
EXPECTING PEOPLE TO CARRY TOO
MUCH OF. A CERTAIN WEIGHT
REQUIREMENT AT THE SAME TIME AS
THE RATE OF PACE THAT THEY'RE
GOING- WHAT IT SAYS IS YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A POLICY. YOU HAVE TO
TELL YOUR EMPLOYER THAT POLICY
PROVIDED TRAINING AND TELL THEM
TO TELL YOU IF THEY GET HURT
THAT'S THE REGULATION RIGHT NOW
THAT IS INSUFFICIENT AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IN THIS BILL.
THAT DOES NOT ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THAT ARE GOING ON IN
AMAZON WAREHOUSES JAY AND WHY
WE'RE ASKING CAL OSHA. TO
PROVIDE- GUIDELINES THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
JERRY I IDEA TO DO APPRECIATE
THAT SO. A LOT OF THE
DISCUSSION FACT MOST OF TODAY
REVOLVES AROUND AMAZON I
ASSUME. BY EXTENSION YOU KNOW
BUSINESSES THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD. SERVE BASE THEIR- MODELS
ON AMAZON'S BUT BUT HOW HOW DO
YOU RESPOND TO. CUT THE BROADER
CONCERN AMONG SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION THAT. AT THESE NEW
STANDARDS. AND BUT- THE. THEIR
APPLICATION WILL WILL THEN ONE
TO BE APPLIED TO BUSINESSES.
BASE MODELS ARE VERY. THAN A-
AND FOR. THIS IS. PLUGGABLE IF
YOU'RE NOT FORESEEN A QUOTA OR
WORK PACE FROM YOUR EMPLOYEES
THEN IT'S NOT YOU'RE NOT
SUBJECT TO THIS BILL YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO BE SUBJECT TO THE
REGULATIONS PUTTING OUT BY CAL
OSHA. SO I'M SORRY SIR WHAT
WOULD YOU SAY QUOTIT
SPECIFICALLY WITH RESPECT TO
WORK PACE AS OPPOSED TO FRANCIS
FROM PACKING OR SOMETHING ELSE
WHICH IS YOU KNOW THE MATERIAL
UOTA LIKE X. NUMBER OF BOXES.
A QUOTA THAT DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
WORKERS TO- THERE BY UTILIZED
OTHER HEALTH AND SAFETY LAWS
USE THE RESTROOM WASH THEIR
HANDS PROVIDED A SAFE WORK
SPACE THAT. ACTUALLY EVEN
COMPLAIN ABOUT A WORKING
CONDITION IT'S TAKEN OFF OF
YOUR TIME ON TASK YOUR YOUR
PRODUCTIVITY SO IF YOU'RE NOT
USING THIS TYPE OF- ALL THE
RHYTHM IN STANDARD. THEN THE
BILL ITSELF DOES NOT APPLY TO
YOU HOWEVER THE REASON WE CAN'T
SAY OBVIOUSLY WE WOULDN'T JUST
SAY IT ONLY APPLIES TO AMAZON
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
THAT LARGER WAREHOUSES ARE
STARTING TO USE THE SAME MODEL.
THAT AMAZON IS USING AND WE
FEAR THAT GIVEN THAT THEY'RE
SETTING THE STANDARD ON NEXT
DAY DELIVERY ON HOW FAST PEOPLE
HAVE TO WORK- ON WHAT'S
EXPECTED THAT MORE AND MORE
WAREHOUSES WILL USE THIS. AND
SO- IT DOES CURRENTLY JUST
APPLIES TO THOSE WHO HAVE A
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES AND WAREHOUSE
A THOUSAND STATEWIDE- THAT'S A
LARGER. WAREHOUSE PRODUCTION-
IT'S NOT YOU KNOW MOM AND POP.
BUT WE ALSO IT ALSO ONLY
APPLIES IF YOU'RE USING THIS
WORK PAY STANDARD. IN THE
INSURANCE YOU KNOW SO READ
THROUGH ALL THE HOUSES IN THE
BILL BUT HOW EXPLICIT. FOR
SPECIFIC IS AROUND THE YOU KNOW
THIS THE DEFINITION OF AN
ALGORITHMIC STANDARD STANDARD
APPROACHING OUR PARTY IF YOU
CAN'T USE A WORK PACE YOU CAN'T.
YOU CAN'T IN ITS BASE IN SOME
WAYS THE CHAMBERS RIGHT RIGHT
THIS IS THE LAW YOU ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO PENALIZE PEOPLE FOR
USING THE RESTROOM. HOWEVER
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THAT AMAZON
CURRENTLY IS JUDGING A
PERFORMANCE STANDARD AND
BECAUSE THERE'S NO IT'S NOT A
HUMAN INTERACTION RIGHT IT'S A-
YOU CAN'T TELL YOU CAN'T TELL
THE COMPUTER. HOLD ON I I'VE
GOT A BIGGER PROBLEM. THAT'S
NOT SUFFOCATING ME TO USE THE
RESTROOM TODAY- IT'S AN
AUTOMATIC AT ISSUE AND IN THERE
BEING SPENT UP AUTOMATICALLY
THERE'S NO- PROCESS BY WHICH
THIS WOULD AFFECT IT. SO IN
THAT SENSE WE HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM THOSE WHO AREN'T USING
THIS WE HAVE WE'VE HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH- SMALL
WAREHOUSES THAT ARE SAID SO YOU
KNOW. HOW DOES THIS APPLY TO US
WHAT DOESN'T- WE'D BE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO REFINE THAT BUT WE
HAVEN'T REALLY HEARD THAT AS A
FEAR FROM THOSE WHO DON'T USE.
THIS TYPE OF- PACE SETTING
STANDARD. DID YOU YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT. THE
PROVISIONS THIS BILL MAKE MAKE
CLEAR THERE'S A VERY CLEAR
DELINEATION BETWEEN. IS THIS IS
FROM THIS DOES APPLY BUSINESS
FOR THE PROMISE I THINK IT'S
VERY CLEAR THAT WE'VE HAD
DECADES OF WAREHOUSES. WE
PROBABLY SENTRIES WAREHOUSES-
OBVIOUSLY WENT WHEN WAREHOUSES
FIRST CAME OUT WE MIGHT HAVE
SOME RULES BUT WE'VE HAD
DECADES WITHOUT THE TYPE OF
INJURIES THAT WERE SEEN NOW. AT
AMAZON BECAUSE OF THE WAY THAT
THEY'RE REQUIRING A WORK SPEED.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS IS. IT
IS THE OBLIGATION OF WORKS BE
THAT SO FAST IT DOESN'T EVEN
ALLOW YOU TO- BASICALLY BE A
HUMAN BEING. AND SO AS YOU KNOW
THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE THAT PACE
AND QUOTA REQUIREMENT I DON'T
SEE HOW. THESE ISSUES- WHAT A
RISE IN THE SAME WAY. IF
SOMEBODY WANTS TO SAY I WORK AT
A WAREHOUSE THERE IS NO QUOTA
BUT- I'M PENALIZED FOR GOING TO
BATH AND THAT WAS ALREADY
ILLEGAL I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S YOU KNOW. THAT THAT'S
NOT THE SOLUTION AND EVEN SO
THEN. YOU'RE ALLOWED TO GO THE
BATHROOM WAS A LOT BEFORE. BUT
AND IT MAKES SENSE I DON'T KNOW
I GUESS I GUESS BUT YOU KNOW
LIKE I'VE HAD LOTS OF
DISCUSSIONS WITH- IF THE
OPPOSITION IN THE IN THE MADE A
VERY CLEAR ASSERTION THAT
NOBODY'S BEING PREVENTED. FROM
GOING TO THE BATHROOM TAKING
BREAKS TO EITHER YOUR SORT OF
COUNTERING I THINK IT'S CLEAR
THERE'S A LAWSUIT IN FACT THAT
WAS. FILED IN ONE BY- EMPLOYEES
OUT OF RIVERSIDE- AMAZON
FACILITY- THE JUDGE FOUND THAT
WAS AND REASONABLE THE BATHROOM
WITH SEVEN MINUTE WALK FROM
WHERE THEY WORK AND OF COURSE
EVEN THAT MEANS THAT EVEN
DURING. A REST PERIOD A FIFTEEN
MINUTE REST PERIOD. YOUR WALK
TO THE BATHROOM AND BACK TAKES
UP FORTY MINUTES OF A FIFTEEN
MINUTE BREAK WHICH MEANS YOU
HAVE TO USE THE RESTROOM WASHED
HER HANDS WITHIN A ONE MINUTE
PERIOD OF TIME. TO NOT BE ON
TASK WHEN YOU RETURN AND THEY'D
BE. ACTUALLY FOUND YOU KNOW
GUILTY OF THAT SO WE KNOW THIS
IS HAPPENING AND WE AND WE
CONTINUE TO HEAR IT'S HAPPENING
FROM THE WORKERS THEMSELVES.
THAT AT. ANY TIME OFF TASK GETS
RECORDED BY ALL THE RHYTHM. AND
YOU KNOW THEY CAN BE- PENALIZED
IN A VARIETY OF WAYS FOR BEING
OFF TASK WITHOUT ANYONE. EVEN
CHECKING IN OF WHY. OKAY THANK
YOU- QUESTION. WOMAN PRITCHARD.
SO THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A CHEN.
SUBJECT THAT I APPRECIATE MR
THANK YOU FOR INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER NEWMAN THE- OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR ALSO AND THEN WILL
COME. TO OUR BY SURE SIR ROSA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL
I MEAN THE WAY OUR WAREHOUSES
ARE BEING RUN TODAY IS WITH
THESE ALGORITHMS IS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT FROM THE WAY
WAREHOUSES HAVE BEEN DONE IN
THE PAST. IT IS JUST SEEMS LIKE
ANOTHER TACTIC TO SPEED UP WORK
WE FIND THAT WHEREVER WE FIND
THAT IT'S DONE AS- A BUSINESS
MODEL. TO SPEED UP WORK THAT'S
WHERE YOU HAVE THE PROBLEMS OF
THE- THE SAFETY OF THE WORKERS
AT RISK THAT IS AN ISSUE YOU
KNOW DOING WORK IN THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY IT'S THE SAME THING IS
WHAT IS A TACTIC TO SPEED UP
WORK TO MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE TO
DO THE WORK AND STILL BE SAFE
AND SECURE AND I THINK I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR WITNESS SAW
WORKS AT- YOU PS WHO SAID YEAH
I HAVE TO WORK HARD. YEAH I
HAVE TO KEEP UP WITH A CERTAIN
PACE BUT I'M SAY I'M SAFE. YOU
KNOW I'M SAFE AND HOW I DO IT
NOW I COULD RAISE THE ISSUE AND
THAT I THINK IS WHAT'S- VERY
DISTURBING ABOUT THE AMAZON
MODEL- AND HOW. THAT'S USE THAT
MODEL IS USED FOR THIS OWNER
THIS FOUNDER. TO BE THE RICHEST
PERSON ON EARTH I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S THE OTHER THING THAT I
THINK IS A EXTREMELY-
BOTHERSOME. AND AND TRAGIC
ABOUT THE WORKERS WHO WERE-
GETTING HURT SO BADLY WELL
SOMEONE IS BECOMING THE RICHEST
PERSON ON THE ON THE PLANET SO
I AM I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE RAISING THIS AND- CAL
OSHA IS NOT KEEPING UP WITH ALL
THE CHANGES IN DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES IT'S NOT KEEPING UP
WITH HOW THE USE OF ALGORITHMS.
IS AFFECTING THAT ARE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF THOSE WORKERS AND
WE GOT A PUSH UP AND THIS IS A
GOOD PUSH IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THANK YOU. SOON GROWS
TO A MINIATURE. OF THE FOUR
THANK YOU- OUR SISTER SHARE
MINE IS MORE JUST OF A COMMENT
AND THIS IS COMING FROM A
BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE. IN MY
OPINION IT WOULD BEHOOVE ANY
EMPLOYER. TO CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE ITS EMPLOYEES
ARE ONE SAFE AND- AND NOT JUST
MAKE IT SO THAT THEY WANT TO
COME TO WORK AND ENJOY THEIR
WORK AND BE PRODUCTIVE BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT- WHEN YOU PROVIDE
AN ENVIRONMENT THAT IS OPTIMAL
THEN PEOPLE ARE GOING TO DO
THEIR BEST TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY DO THE BEST JOB. AND NOT
ONLY THAT BUT IT ALSO
INCENTIVIZES PEOPLE TO DO YOU
WANT TO DO HIRE THE BEST PEOPLE
POSSIBLE SO IT IS A LITTLE-
IT'S CONCERNING TO ME THAT. IT
AND I KNOW RIGHT NOW EVERYONE'S
REFERENCING AMAZON BUT I'M
THINKING IN GENERAL'S EMPLOYERS
THAT YOU'D WANT TO CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT WOULD BE
OPTIMAL FOR ONE NUMBER TWO. TO
CREATE AN AND SAVE BUSINESS
PRACTICE MODEL I THINK WOULD
BE. AN ABSOLUTE DISSERVICE TO
ANY EMPLOYER BECAUSE- YOUR YOUR
WORKERS COMP LIABILITY GOES UP.
WHEN YOU DON'T PROVIDE THE
OPTIMAL ENVIRONMENT SO I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. IN MY
MIND AS TO ONE. WHAT WOULD NOT
WHAT WOULD NOT HELLO NOT THAT
WAY. WHY WOULD AN EMPLOYER NOT
PROVIDE OR OR MODIFIED TO MODEL
SO THAT IT DOESN'T CREATE
HEALTH AND SAFETY HAZARD NUMBER
TWO- TAKING CONSIDERATION THE
SAFETY OF THE EMPLOYERS AS WELL
AS MAKING SURE THAT. YOU DON'T
WANT THE COST OF DOING AND NOT
ONLY THAT BUT ALSO THINKING OF
THE TURN OVER. BECAUSE WHEN YOU
DON'T HAVE AN ENVIRONMENT THAT.
IS OPTIMAL THEN YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE A HIGH TURNOVER SO NOT
ONLY IS YOUR WORKERS COMP GOING
TO GO UP YOUR TURN OVER FOR
TRAINING AND SO FORTH. I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT. WHAT
WOULD NOT Y. THESE EMPLOYERS
WOULD NOT WANT TO DO THAT
ALREADY WHY IS THIS NECESSARY
AND NOT IN THE BUSINESS PARTNER
SPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE AT THAT
CALIBER- THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WHY WOULDN'T YOU JUST ALREADY
DO THAT. WHAT THAT I THINK THAT
IS A FANTASTIC QUESTION- AND I
UNFORTUNATELY IT COMES DOWN TO
DOLLARS AND CENTS SO- JUST LIKE
KEVIN ALDER THEM TO DECIDE HOW
MUCH PEOPLE SHOULD WORK IN ALL
GRADE THEM TO DECIDE WHAT'S IN
THEIR BEST BUSINESS PRACTICE.
HOW CAN THEY MAKE THE MOST
AMOUNT OF MONEY AND WHAT THEY
DECIDED IT IS AN- YOU DON'T.
IT'S NOT I'M NOT GIVING YOU. M.
YOU KNOW I COULD TALK TO
WORKERS AND I HEAR WORKERS FEEL
THIS WAY AN INDIVIDUAL KIND OF
STORIES I CAN TELL YOU THE
FACTS. IN COUNTIES THAT HAD
NOTE AMAZON DISTRIBUTION CENTER
PREVIOUSLY. THE TURNOVER RATE
FOR WAREHOUSE WORKERS WAS ABOUT
38% A YEAR. AFTER THOSE SAME
COUNTIES COUNTIES IN FACT IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE. THAT THEN
HAD AMAZON DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS- DEVELOP IN THEIR
COUNTY. THE TURNOVER RATE
OVERALL FOR WAREHOUSE WORKERS
JUMPED OVER A HUNDRED AND 50% A
YEAR. THAT TELLS YOU THAT THEY
ARE NOT WORRIED ABOUT TURNING
THROUGH EMPLOYEES. THEY'VE
DECIDED THAT PAINT A CERTAIN
WAGE TO GET PEOPLE IN THE DOOR
AND UTILIZING THEM IT'S IN
THEIR BEST BUSINESS PRACTICE.
NOW THEIR THEIR WORKERS COMP
RATES LIKEWISE HAVE TO BE.
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT. BUT ANY
COMPANY THAT HAS- I GUESS THE
ABILITY TO MONETIZE HUMAN WORK
IN THAT WAY TO MONETIZE
PEOPLE'S INJURIES IN THE STATE
IS IT WORTH IT TO BURN
THRILLED. AND INJURE EMPLOYEES
BECAUSE IN THE LONG RUN WHAT
WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO DOMINATE
THIS FIELD WE'RE GOING TO GET
EVERYTHING OUT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE WE'RE GOING TO SET A
STANDARD WE'RE GOING TO MAKE. A
TON OF MONEY THAT'S WHAT AMAZON
HAS DONE. WE KNOW THAT WE CAN
ALL LOOK AT THESE ARE ALL.
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATA I'M
NOT. GIVING YOU SOME YOU KNOW
SECRET THIS IS PROBABLY ABOUT
AVAILABLE IT'S THE SAME WAY.
AND I WILL SAY WE THOUGHT WITH
UNIONIZING EFFORTS RIGHT SAME
WAY THEY BREAK LABOR LAWS IN
FIRE UNION ORGANIZERS BECAUSE
IT RATHER PAY THAT COST THAN
WHAT IT WOULD COST THEM TO HAVE
A UNION IN THEIR WORKPLACE.
IT'S ALL RATIONAL IF ALL YOU
CARE ABOUT IS YOUR BOTTOM LINE
IN YOUR BUSINESS MAKING MONEY.
THAT'S OFTEN NOT WHAT WE'RE
SEEING A MOM AND POP WAREHOUSES
AND THAT'S WHY. THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE IN THE WAY PEOPLE
ARE TREATED RIGHT THERE IF YOU
HAVE. THAT YOU KNOW YOU'RE THE
BIGGEST EMPLOYER IN THE UNITED
STATES YOU'RE NOT LOOKING AT
THE INDIVIDUAL WORKER YOU'RE
LOOKING AT HOW MUCH MY MAKING
FOR MIGHT. SHAREHOLDERS AND MY
C. E. L. THE WHAT WE KNOW
THAT'S A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY ON
AMAZON. SO AM. I KNOW THAT ALL
OF US WITH WOULD LIKE TO SAY
YOU KNOW THEY SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT THIS THIS DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
BUT IT BOB. MAKES SENSE FOR THE
BOTTOM LINE. AB THEIR WORKERS
THAT EVERY REPORT CAME OUT EVEN
WHEN I HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH
AMAZON THEY DON'T DENY THAT
THEIR WORK FORCE IS GETTING
HURT AT HIGHER RATES THAN OTHER
WAREHOUSES IN. IN A MUCH HIGHER
RATE THAN THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT IT DOESN'T
ONLY AFFECT THEM BECAUSE THE
WAY WORKERS COMP IS DONE. THESE
OTHER WAREHOUSES ARE PAYING
MORE WORKERS COMP CLAIMS NOW
BECAUSE AMAZON'S- IT THAT THEIR
INDUSTRY STANDARD IS SO WIDE
AND THEY HAVE SO MUCH OF THE
MARKET SHARE THAT THEY'RE
AFFECTING. ALL WORKERS COMP
RATES SO IF YOU'RE NOT.
OPERATING THIS WAY YOU'RE
GETTING HURT BY THEIR PRACTICES
AS WELL. BUT YOU'RE NOT GETTING
THE BENEFIT OF JUST TURNING
THREE WORKERS. THANK YOU. OR
SHOULD I SAY THERE'S ALWAYS AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD IT'LL TAKE A
FIFTEEN DOLLAR WAGED ON. MANY
YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY NOT
KNOWING THE CONSEQUENCES. FOUR
I APPRECIATE THE CONSEQUENCE OF
WHAT IT'LL DO TO YOUR BODY. AS
MY FELLOW COLLEAGUES ON THE
COMMITTEE I ACTUALLY ALSO SPOKE
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND- I WAS.
IS VERY INTERESTING BECAUSE I
DID NOT SEE- I JUST PERSONALLY
I'M ALWAYS NERVOUS ABOUT THE
STATE COMING IN AND PUTTING ONE
STANDARD ONE SIZE FITS ALL ON
EVERY SINGLE INDUSTRY- BECAUSE
THEY'RE SO DIFFERENT THEY'RE
THEY'RE- THEY'RE DIFFERENT. AND
SO MODELS ARE DIFFERENT AND
INTERESTING AND DIFFERENT AND I
JUST I'M I'M NERVOUS ABOUT.
ANYTHING THAT JUST SAYS OKAY
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
STANDARD WIRELESS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IN SPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO EMPLOYMENT AND
DIFFERENT DEALS A MODEL SO.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
I'M NERVOUS ABOUT THIS BILL AS
IT IS BUT- I HEAR YOU ON ON ON
YOUR CONCERNS. I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I'M NERVOUS AS WELL IF
I HAD MY WAY I WOULD NEVER WANT
THE STATE TO COME IN AND HAVE
BROAD REGULATIONS THAT THIS IT
JUST LIKE WE HEARD FROM THAT
WORKER AT THE UPS- DISTRIBUTION
CENTER THAT IS WHAT WE WILL
THAT IS THE- THAT THE BEST
OUTCOME WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL
WORKER IN A WORKPLACE HAS A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
AND HAS A WAY TO DISCUSS. A
SAFETY CONCERN WITH THEIR
MANAGER WITHOUT BEING- WITH
WITHOUT BEING RETALIATED
AGAINST AND HAVING THAT THAT'S
A FREE MARKET APPROACH TO
HAVING SAFETY IN THE WORKPLACE
IS ACTUALLY TO HAVE A UNION BUT
WE KNOW AMAZON WON'T ALLOW.
THEIR THEIR WAREHOUSES BE
UNIONIZED EITHER THAT WAS
ANOTHER THING I OPPOSED TO THE
COMPANY THEMSELVES WHAT IS THE
ANSWER IF NOT THIS BECAUSE I
AGREE I'D RATHER. US NOT HAVE
TO- GET INTO. WHAT IS AN
ACCEPTABLE STANDARD THE WORKER
KNOWS THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
TALK TO THE MANAGER ABOUT IT
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
SOMETHING THAT IS UNSAFE AND
REFUSED TO DO IT THAT'S WHAT
SHOULD HAPPEN. AMAZON WON'T LET
IT HAPPEN THERE SO THEN WERE
FORCED TO DO THINGS THAT ARE
ONE SIZE FITS ALL OUR FEEL MORE
LIKE A ONE SIZE FITS ALL. THIS
IS NARROWLY TAILORED. TO THOSE
WAREHOUSES THAT USE QUOTAS THAT
USE PERSONAL DATA ONON THE
EMPLOYEE AND EFFECTS THEIR
THEIR US. WHETHER THE FIRED
WHETHER THEY'RE THEY HAVE NOT
RETALIATED AGAINST AND THAT-
ARE JUST LARGE WAREHOUSES SO
IT'S NEARLY TAILORED AS MUCH AS
WE CAN BUT I I'M WITH YOU ON
THAT. I THINK THERE'S A BETTER
WAY TO DO IT. THE CONSUMERS WHO
CENTER NEWURGH HI I JUST WANT
TO. JUMP BACK INTO IT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CAN SELECT. EVERY SINGLE
THING HE SAID- BUT I ALSO WANT
TO ADD. TO ALL OF YOUR POINTS
THAT IS WHY WE NEED A AND AN
AGGRESSIVE ENGAGE CAL OSHA- AND
IF IT'S NECESSARY TO DO. THAT
TO LEGISLATION WHAT WHAT WE
WE'RE NOT DOING THROUGH YOU
KNOW APPROPRIATE PLACEMENTS-
ENFORCEMENT AND DAN AND
REGULATIONS. IT THAT'S A SAD
COMMENTARY- AND SO I WOULD SAY
AMONG OTHER THINGS TO DO YOU
KNOW WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO
FORCE. THE ISSUE WITH CAL OSHA
MAKE SURE THAT THAT. THESE
WORKING CONDITIONS AND
STANDARDS ARE SPECIFIC TO A
PARTICULAR. KIND OF BUSINESS-
AND- UNITARITY POINT HERE THAT
THE HOPEFULLY WE DON'T HAVE TO
RESORT TO VERY BROAD
LEGISLATION TO DO THAT SAID.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO.
DO HERE IS DIRECT HELLO SHOULD
TO DO THAT IN THIS CIRCUMSTANCE
TO ANSWER YOUR PREVIOUS
QUESTION SO IT PULLED UP THE
BILL JUST TO MAKE SURE. THAT I
WASN'T IMAGINING. THE
DEFINITIONS FOR EMPLOYEE WORKS
BE DATA WHICH ASKED ABOUT. IS
INFORMATION EMPLOYER COLLECTS
STORES ANALYZE OR INTERPRETS
RELATING TO AN INDIVIDUAL
EMPLOYEE'S PERFORMANCE OF THE
QUOTA. INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO DO QUANTITIES OF TAX
REFORM QUANTITIES OF ITEMS OR
MATERIALS HANDLED. OUR PRODUCE
RATES OF SPEED. MEASUREMENTS
ARE METRICS OF EMPLOYEE
PERFORMANCE RELATIONSHIP TO A
QUOTA. AND TIME CATEGORIZED AS
PERFORMING TASKS OR NOT
PERFORMING TASKS AND THEN.
AGAIN THE QUOTA. IS A WORK
STANDARD AND WHICH AN EMPLOYEE
IS ASSIGNED OR REQUIRED TO
PERFORM AT A SPECIFIED
PRODUCTIVITY SPEED. R PERFORM
A QUANTIFIED NUMBER OF TASK OR
TO HANDLE OR PRODUCE A
QUALIFIED. AMOUNT OF MATERIAL
WITHIN A DEFINED TIME PERIOD
AND UNDER WHICH THE EMPLOYEE
MAY SUFFER AN ADVERSE.
EMPLOYMENT ACTION IF THEY FAIL
TO COMPLETE THE PERFORMANCE
STANDARD. THIS DOESN'T SAY YOU
CAN'T HAVE A QUOTA THIS DOESN'T
SAY- THAT. WAREHOUSES DON'T
OPERATE WITH BECAUSE IT SAYS
YOU HAVE TO STILL WITHIN THE
QUOTA. BE ABLE TO FUNCTION-
UNDER OUR STATE HEALTH AND
SAFETY LAWS AND AS A HUMAN.
BEING- IT WITH NATURAL HUMAN
BEING FUNCTIONS- WITHOUT BEING
READ. AGAINST NOT BRIDGE AT ALL
THAT CERTAIN A ONE ONE THE
ISSUES HERE IS THAT M. TO THEIR-
HAS HAS AN- NEW WAYS TO RUN
EVERY SINGLE ASPECT OF THE
BUSINESS INCLUDING. QUANTIFYING
PERFORMANCE ACROSS A RANGE OF
MEASURES IN A WAREHOUSE IN EVER
THOUGHT ABOUT DOING- AND IT'S
APPROPRIATE CAL OSHA- SHOULD
KEEP UP. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THIS LOCATED- ANYTHING ELSE
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE. THE-
BEFORE WE GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE ALL THE AT
SOMEONE WILL FEEL SIMPLY HAD A
SERIES OF THOSE- WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT- LET ME JUST SAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR WORKING
THROUGH THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
CITED- WITH COMMITTEE STAFF- HE
AND IN GETTING TO THE PLACE
WHERE YOU ARE NOW- I KNOW THAT
I JUST WANNA MAKE A COMMENT. I
THINK THAT WE'RE- YOU ARE
MOVING INTO. A PERIOD AND WE'VE
SEEN SIGNS OF IT OVER THE LAST
COUPLE LEGISLATIVE SESSIONS-
EVEN FROM AFAR BECAUSE I'VE-
BEEN HERE JUST A MATTER OF
MONTHS BUT WE- AS CALIFORNIANS
WHO'VE BEEN PAYING ATTENTION
WE'VE SEEN. THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT LAWS NEED TO BE
ADJUSTED TO KEEP UP WITH A
DIFFERENT TIME. A DIFFERENT
BUSINESS MODELS. IT NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN A COLLABORATIVE WAY ALL
THE MORE REASON I APPRECIATE
YOU WORKING WITH COMMITTEE ON
ON AMENDMENTS AND SO FORTH. YOU
SAID AS A- AS THE AUTHOR.
WAREHOUSES HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR
CENTURIES- CODES HAVE BEEN
AROUND FOR CENTURIES MIGHT
MIGHT WELL GRANDFATHER CAME AS
A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD IMMIGRANT
KIND OF LISTEN. WAS PUT ON A
QUOTA. HAMMERING THE CLEATS
INSIDE CANNERY BOXES WITH THE
PEACE IN THE CORNER THAT'S THE
HARDEST PIECE TO. TO GET A
HAMMER AND INPUT MALES TO YOU
KNOW AND OF COURSE AS A HARD
WORKING PERSON ACCEPTED THAT
CHALLENGE. IN AND DID IT- I
WOULD LOVE TO GO BACK AND SEE
THE DATA- YOU KNOW ON ON ON THE
DAY HE WALKED OUT OF THERE. AS
TO WHAT HE WAS DOING THE PRIOR
NINETY DAYS WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN. PUT INTO THIS BILL
I DON'T THINK THAT'S- AN OVER
REACH I THINK THAT'S- IT IS A
SIGN OF THE TIMES IT IS
SOMETIMES WE EVEN HALF OF THAT
DATA THAT PEOPLE CAN. TRACK
THAT DATA NOW I'M NOT SURE THEY
COULD HAVE DONE IT A HUNDRED
TWENTY YEARS AGO. WITH ANY KIND
OF. EFFICIENCIES AND I'S
AVAILABLE NOW- SO YOU KNOW I
THINK WE'RE PROBABLY GONNA SEE
MORE OF THIS BUT I ALSO THINK
IT NEEDS TO BE A COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS WEEK WE'D- WE PROBABLY
DON'T WANT TO BE. AT ODDS WITH
THE VERY INDUSTRIES SAID OUR
POINT PEOPLE- IN WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO DO SOME OF IT THIS WAY
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK WE ARE
GOING TO GET. UNIONIZED A 100%
OVERNIGHT ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND ACROSS THESE KIND OF WORK
PLACES AND I DON'T THINK I CAN
COMPLETE DRIVEN IT. AGENCIES
THOSE THAT RECEIVED COMPLAINTS
AND TRY TO RESPOND TO THEM CAN
KEEP UP- YOU KNOW WITH THIS
KIND OF. OF POLLY NOT SO MUCH
THAT THERE'S NECESSARILY GOING
TO BE AN OVERWHELM OF
COMPLAINTS. BUT IT'S A
COMPLAINT DRIVEN MODEL IS A
TOUGH MODEL FOR- FOR ADJUSTING.
TO IN EQUITY AND FAIRNESS.
HINAULT AND MODERN BUSINESS
MODELS ACROSS THE WORKPLACE SO
I APPRECIATE YOU WORKING ON
THIS AND BRING IN A FORWARD IN
A OPOSSUM PRESHEAF HEARING THAT
YOU'RE- GOING TO CONTINUE TO.
WORK WITH- OPPOSITION AND OTHER
FOLKS. WHO ARE TRYING TO. HELP
MAKE THIS PIECE ALLEGE. THE
BEST PIECE OF ALSO IT CAN BE
GOING FOR. TRUMP SO I JUST
WANTED TO GET THAT OUT AND- IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE- HERE
WELCOME TO DO THAT AT THIS
TIME. I REFRAIN FROM- TALKING
ABOUT WHY IT'S SO. IMPOSSIBLE
WORK FOR THE OPPOSITION BUT- I
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO NONE THE
LESS- EVEN IF THE BAR MOVES
EVERY DAY- BUT WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER HIGH FAT.
LOW KEY. THANK YOU SOME MEMBER-
IS OUR MOTION ON THE BILL SAYS.
STE SENATE NEWMAN MOVE THE
BILL. AND THE CENTER DRAWS A
WE'RE GONNA WILL GIVE YOU TWO
MORE BEFORE THE DAY'S OVER HERE
SO. I SEE. THE NEXT ALL RIGHT
HE CENTER NEWMAN DIFFERS TO
SENATOR ALSO. AND SEND ROSA
MOVES A BILL SO BANKS WILL SHE
TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED AND BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE AND
YOU TO SHERRY COURTESY HI OR
DOES HE DIE OR CHOI BOGUE NO
THE SWITCH OF POCONO. BLUEGRASS
SILVA HI PRESS I LAYERED HI.
THERE I NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE.
OKAY SO THAT THE HOUSE IS ON A
FOUR TO ONE VOTE TO BILLS OUT
THANK YOU. SENATOR CONSIDERS
SOME MEMBER GONZALEZ I KNEW I
DO THAT ONE OF THESE DAYS IN
THIS ROOM. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONSOLES A. B. TEN SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE THANK YOU. WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT HERE WHEN YOU
ACCIDENTALLY A TEXT ME-
THINKING OR TEXTING SENATOR
GONZALEZ THAT'S WHEN THE
PROBLEMS ARISE SO. OTHERS YOU
CAN ASK OTHER SENATORS ABOUT
THAT. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AT FIRST I'D LIKE TO
ACCEPT ALL OF THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WHICH DEFINED THE
TERM GUEST SERVICES IN THE BILL
IN AGAIN THANK YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
ON THIS LANGUAGE. CAN'T SAY
ENOUGH ABOUT YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF AFTER SIGNIFICANT
DISRUPTIONS IN COVER NINETEEN
HAS BECAUSE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY WE MUST MINIMIZE ANY
FURTHER DISPLACEMENT JOBS IN
THE SECTOR AS THESE WORKERS ARE
GETTING BACK ON THEIR FEET.
WHEN A SERVICE CONTRACT IS
TERMINATED EXISTING LAWS
DEVILISH TWENTY YEARS AGO UNDER
THE DISPLACED JANITOR
OPPORTUNITY ACT PROVIDES
JANITORIAL AND BUILDING
MAINTENANCE SERVICE WORKERS THE
ABILITY TO CONTINUE WORKING AND
A NEW CONTRACTOR FOR SIXTY DAY
TRANSITION PERIOD. AB TEN
SEVENTY FOUR MAKES A NARROW
CHANGE BY SIMPLY ADDING
SIMILARLY SITUATED HOTEL
SERVICE WORKERS TO THIS
EXISTING LAW. HOTEL SERVICE
JOBS INCLUDING FOOD CLEANING
AND GUEST SERVICES ARE
SIMILARLY OUTSOURCED AT TIMES
AND PERFORMED BY CONTRACTED OR
SUBCONTRACTED EMPLOYEES. THESE
WORKERS GENERALLY REPORT TO THE
SAME WORKSITE EACH STATE WHERE
THE UNIFORM OF THE HOTEL THEY
ARE CLEAN AND REPORT TO THE
MANAGERS AND SUPERVISORS ON
SITE. REGARDLESS OF THE
SPECIFIC CONTRACTOR THAT THEY
ARE WORKING FOR. THE EXISTING
LAW ONLY APPLIES IF THE NEW
CONTRACTOR HAS TWENTY FIVE OR
MORE EMPLOYEES IN THIS BILL
DOES NOT CHANGE THAT. TO BE
CLEAR THIS BILL ALSO DOES NOT
REQUIRE NEW CONTRACTOR JUST
KEEP HOTEL WORKERS ON BOARD IF
THEY HAD PERFORMANCE OR CONDUCT
ISSUES AT WORK OR IF THE NEW
CONTRACTOR SIMPLY DOES NOT NEED
ALL THE WORKERS TO PERFORM THE
SERVICES UNDER THE CONTRACT. AB
TEN SEVENTY FOUR WILL MINIMIZE
IMMEDIATE DISPLACEMENT OF ALL
WORKERS IMPACTED WHEN HOTELS
CHANGING SERVICE CONTRACTORS
ENSURES THEY HAVE A REASONABLE
TRANSITION PERIOD. EXISTING LAW
HAS PROVED SUCCESSFUL IN THE
JANITORIAL INDUSTRY FOR DECADES
WE'RE SIMPLY TRACK TAKING THE
SAME APPROACH IN TARGETING VERY
SIMILAR LOW WAGE WORKFORCE MADE
UP PREDOMINATELY LATINO AND
IMMIGRANT WORKERS. THIS IS A
CRITICAL PART OF STABILIZING
JOBS IN THE SECTOR- I HAVE A
WITNESS ON THE PHONE. OKAY
THANK YOU IN- I BELIEVE LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESSES CAITLIN VEGA-
IN THE FIVE. HIS BIGGEST YOUR
ONLINE YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KEEP
AND DATA ON BEHALF THAT UNITE
HERE LOCAL ELEVEN REPRESENTING
OVER TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND HOTEL
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA AND
ARIZONA. HOTEL INDUSTRY LIKE SO
MANY OTHERS HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
BY THE FISSURED WORKPLACE.
CORPORATION THANK THE CUT COSTS
THEY REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
DIRECT EMPLOYEES AND RELY ON
TEMPORARY AND CONTRACT WORKERS.
THESE WORKERS ARE GENERALLY
PAID LESS HAVE FEWER BENEFITS
AND MAY NOT BE PART OF THE
UNION BARGAINING UNIT. AS
TEMPORARY WORKERS THEY ARE AT
GREATER RISK OF THE PIECES FROM
BLEACH STAFF TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. THEY KNOW THAT
ANYTIME THE CONTRACT CAN CHANGE
AND THEY WILL BE OUT OF A JOB.
IT'S STILL JUST GRANT THESE
WORKERS A MODICUM OF SECURITY
BY REQUIRING THAT WHEN A
CONTRACTOR HOSPITALITY SERVICES
CHANGES HANDS THE WORKERS WILL
NOT BE PUNISHED INSTEAD THE
SUCCESSOR CONTRACTOR WILL BE
ASKED TO MAINTAIN THE WORK
FORCE FOR SIXTY DAYS. TO ALLOW
WORKERS TO SHOW THEY ARE
QUALIFIED TO REMAIN IN THE JOB.
SIMILAR LAWS ALREADY IN PLACE
FOR JANITORS BUILDING SERVICES
GROCERYWORKERS TRANSIT WORKERS
AND RECYCLING WORKERS. FOR
THESE REASONS WE THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ OPTION IS THE
ONLY. REQUEST YOUR IDOL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE'RE GONNA
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM
AND THERE'S ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK UP SUPPORT OF AB TEN
SEVENTY FOUR. C. NONE WILL GO
TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM THE C. NO
WITNESSES THERE WAS A MODERATOR
TO PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON A. B. TEN SEVENTY
FOUR AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
VENTURA IT'S TIME. ONE NINE
ZERO. WE'LL GO TO LINE. SIXTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON SHOULD
INVESTMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED HERE INTERNATIONAL UNION
AND THE TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT.
BY SEVENTY FIVE. BERNAY BAYARDO
WITH AT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. BY.
NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER
SHURMUR'S MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO EXPORT. BY. NINETY TWO.
UNION MEMBERS STRIPPED OUT
MAYOR WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE ECONOMY AND BUT
BEFORE THANK YOU. THE FINAL
CALL FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
SURE THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THAT-
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITH THE SNOW. IN
THAT WOULD BE JOHN COLDWELL.
MISTER CALDERON IF YOU WERE ON
THE TELECONFERENCE WINE YOU MAY
PROCEED AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN CANARY YES WE CAN LOAN
CLEARED. OKAY RICHARD SHERMAN-
DUNK ALTHOUGH REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF BOUTIQUE AND
BREAKFAST IN. UNDER AB TEN
SEVENTY FOUR A HOTEL THAT
WANTED TO GET RID OF A POOR
PERFORMANCE SERVICE PROVIDER.
WOULD HAVE TO REQUIRE THE
REPLACEMENT COMPANIES HIRE
EMPLOYEES. FROM THE TERMINATED
COMPANY. HERE'S HOW ONE OF OUR
MEMBERS EXPLAIS PROBLEM. QUOTE
ONE OF MY HOTELS HAVE A THIRD
PARTY CONTRACT FOR OUR VALET
SERVICE. ALTHOUGH THE VALET
EMPLOYEES ARE NOT HOTEL
EMPLOYEES THEY DIRECTLY
INTERACT WITH MY CUSTOMERS. AND
CAN DIRECTLY IMPACT MY BUSINESS
IF THE PERFORMANCE IS POOR. IF
I CHOOSE TO CHANGE MY CONTRACT
VALLEY SERVICE WHY WOULD I WANT
THE NEW COMPANY TO HIRE BACK
THE SAME EMPLOYEES. OF THE
CURRENT VALLEY SERVICE IF THAT
IS THE REASON FOR CANCELING THE
CONTRACT. ON QUOTE. THE BILL
SUPPORTERS SAY THE NEW
COMPANIES WOULD NOT HAVE TO
HIRE THE BAD APPLES BUT IN
FACT. THEY COULD REFUSE TO HIRE
SOMEONE ONLY IF THE NEW COMPANY
NOT THE HOTEL HAS QUOTE.
REASONABLE AND SUBSTANTIATED
BECAUSE NOT TIRED THE
PARTICULAR EMPLOYEE ON QUOTE
OR- IF AFTER THE FIRST SIXTY
DAYS THEY HAVE TO PROVE THE
EMPLOYEE IS. THAT THEY HAVE TO
PROVE THE EMPLOYEE IS LESS THAN
QUOTE SATISFACTORY. ON QUOTE.
IF THE NEW COMPANY CAN'T OR
WON'T MEET THESE LEGAL
THRESHOLDS THE HOTEL IS STUCK
WITH THE BAD EMPLOYEES. BETTER
THE REASON FOR THE CANCELLATION
OF THE CONTRACT. UNLIKE THE-
AUTHORS HOTEL RECALL AND
RETENTION BILL WHICH ONLY
COVERS HOTELS WITH OVER FIFTY
ROOMS THIS BILL APPLIES TO EVEN
THE SMALLEST BED AND
BREAKFASTS. AND HOTELS BUT
TYPICALLY HAVE FEW STAFF AND
CONTRACT WITH SERVICE.
COMPANIES FROM- SERVICES. YEAH
AMENDMENTS SLIGHT NOW THE DE.
OF GUESTS. HOWEVER THE
AMENDMENTS DO NOT DEFINE HOTEL
SERVICES SO THE BILL COULD
APPLY TO COMPANIES THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES SUCH AS LEGAL
ACCOUNTING BOOKKEEPING SALES
MARKETING. SOCIAL MEDIA
COMMUNICATIONS OF FEDERAL. THE
LODGING INDUSTRY WAS DEVASTATED
BY COVERT PANT PANDEMIC THIS
BILL WILL SEVERELY IMPACT THEIR
RECOVERY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY OF I BELIEVE WE HAVE
ANOTHER OPPOSITION WITH IS.
LISTED AS LEADERSHIP HOFFMAN.
YOU'RE HERE PRESENT GREAT THANK
YOU WHAT WELCOME TO BEGIN THANK
YOU. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR TERM
MEMBERS ACTUALLY HOFFMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TEN SEVENTY
FOUR IT IS PLEASE GENERAL
PERTINI ACTORS ENACTED IN
RESPONSE IN UNDERGROUND ECONOMY
AND ISSUES ARISING OR THE LOSS
OF ONE CONTRACT MENTAL
JANITORIAL PLEASE HAD NO OTHER
WORK. UNDER THAT LAW FROM
TWENTY YEARS AGO ANYTIME
THERE'S A CHANGE IN A
CONTRACTING SERVICE THE NEW
CONTRACTORS REQUIRED TO HIRE
ALL OF THE FORMER CONTRACTORS
EMPLOYEES YOU CAN BE SUED IN
COURT IF THEY DON'T AND IT'S
NOT THAT YOU DON'T NEED TO HIRE
THEM IF YOU DON'T NEED THEM
IT'S ONLY IF YOU NEED A QUOTE
FEWER THAT ARE REQUIRED TO DO
THAT JOB SO EVEN IF YOU ALREADY
HAVE THE STAFF TO DO IT. YOU
WOULD STILL HAVE TO HIRE THE
OTHER CONTRACTORS EMPLOYEES
THAT LAWLER SAID ORIGINALLY
VETOED BY GOVERNOR DAVIS AND
THE CONCERN OF THE TROUBLING
PRECEDENT THE LAW WOULD SET FOR
REGULATING PRIVATE SECTOR
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONSHIPS AND
THIS BILLS EXAMPLE THAT CONCERN
COMING TO FRUITION. THE BILL IS
TAKING THAT STATUTE DESIGNED TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES FOR THAT
SPECIFIC INDUSTRY FOR TWENTY
YEARS AGO AND BROADLY APPLYING
IT TO NEARLY EVERY SERVICE A
HOTEL OR SMALL GRAIN BREAKFAST
CONTRACT FOR THE AUTHOR THE
PROPONENTS LARGE RECYCLE BIN
NINETEEN IS A NEED FOR THE BILL
AND POINT TO SIMILAR COMPANY
TEAM SPECIFIC LOCAL ORDINANCES
WITH THE BILL IS NOT LIMITED TO
COVER NINETEEN IT ANYWAY. WELL
RECENT AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN TO
SOMEONE CLARIFY WHAT WAS MEANT
BY GUEST SERVICES THE LIST OF
SERVICES IS STILL BROAD AND
VAGUELY ALSO INCLUDES ANY QUOTE
SECTION SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
SERVICES ANOTHER CONCERN WE
HAVE IS THE BILL APPLIES TO.
PNB'S IN HOTELS OF ALL SIZES
IT'S OFTEN THE SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE THE MOST NEED FOR
CONTRACTORS AND THIS BILL MAKES
IT EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO EVER CHANGE CONTRACTORS OR
TRACK NEW ONES EVEN SB NINETY
THREE THE RIGHT TO RECALL
MANDATE THAT WAS HE TOLD LAST
YEAR AND SUBSEQUENTLY NARROWED
CONTAINS A MINIMUM ROOMS ARE
SOLD IN THIS LIMITED TO COLD
IT. FOR THE WRONG EMPLOYEE MUST
WORK FIFTEEN HOURS PER WEEK TO
FALL UNDER THE SCOPE OF THIS
BILL IT DOES NOT STATE THAT THE
FIFTEEN HOURS MUST BE PERFORMED
AT ONE HOTEL EMPLOYEE WORKING
TWO HOURS AT HOTEL A IN THIRTY
EIGHT HOURS A HOTEL BE WHISTLE
AND FALL UNDER THE BILL IF THAT
CONTRACT WAS CANCELED WHICH
DOES NOT MAKE SENSE. FOR THESE
REASONS AND MORE WE ARE
STRICTLY. OPPOSE AN ORIGIN
ABOUT. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- THOSE ARE ANYONE
WHO PRO. COMMITTEE WHO WISH TO
EX. AND POSITION ON THIS BILL.
IN THIS ROOM- IT WILL TURN TO
THE OVERFLOW ROOM TO LOOK FOR
TESTIMONY THERE THERE IS-
NOBODY PRESENT WELCOME BACK TO
THE MODERATOR AS A MODERATOR ON
A. B. TEN SEVENTY FOUR. PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES PLEASE. TO GO TO LINE.
NINETY THREE- CHAIR NUMBERS
NEARLY THE MONEY CALIFORNIA
CALCIFICATION. BLIND SEVENTY
VERY. HELLO THIS IS FRED MADE
ON BEHALF OF THE TRI COUNTY
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ALLIANCE IN
OPPOSITION. AND THE FINAL CALL
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO PRESS. ONE ZERO.
SURE THERE'S NO ONE OUT TO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
OKAY THANK YOU- FOR THAT
MODERATOR WELCOME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE NOW FOR. INSURANCE
QUESTIONS AND DIALOGUE FROM
CENTER NEWMAN DID YOU WANNA GO
FIRST- I GUESS IDEA AB THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. SO WE'VE HAD
A LOT OF BILLS THAT COME BOTH
RATIONAL TO THROUGH THROUGH THE
FROM THE ASSEMBLY RECENTLY THAT
THAT ALL USE COVERT AS KIND OF
THE ORGANIZING PRINCIPLE BUT
DIED IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND OF DR
I GUESS THERE IS SOME MERIT I
THINK HIS OFFICE POINT YOU
COULD COULD YOU. CLARIFY THE
NEXUS OF ANY WITH CODE ON THIS
BILL AT THIS POINT TIME.
ALTHOUGH COVE IT HAS- DECIMATED
THE WORKERS IN THIS INDUSTRY
MORE THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WAS
NECESSARY BEFORE COVE IT AND
WILL BE NECESSARY AFTER CO BAD
AND I'LL EXPLAIN THIS. SO WHAT
COULD HAVE HAPPENED DURING
COBIT AND OF COURSE OUR
RETENTION- LANGUAGE THAT WE GOT
THROUGH THE BUDGET HELPS BUT
WHAT COULD HAPPEN IS A CONTRACT
EXPIRES YOU HAVE A NEW
CONTRCTOR COMING IN. AND SO
EVEN THOUGH THAT THAT WORK OR
IF THEY WORK FOR THE HALL HOTEL
WOULD HAVE RETENTION RIGHTS.
THEY THEY AREN'T BEING CALLED
BACK FOR BECAUSE THEIR CONTRACT
HAS HAS BEEN- DISMISSED IF YOU
WILL OR REPLACED. SO THAT HAS A
AFFECT ON THOSE WORKERS
HOWEVER. JUST LIKE THE
JANITORIAL WORKERS THIS IS BEEN
IN PLACE FOR TWENTY YEARS
BECAUSE LOW WAGE WORKERS ARE IN
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES AND WE
REALIZE THAT MAYBE CO THAT HAS
MADE US REALIZE THAT EVEN MORE-
THAT IT SEEMS THE APPROPRIATE
TIME TO AND WE WERE WORKING ON
THIS PRIOR TO COVE IT IT'S NOT
YOU KNOW IT JUST BE IT BECAME
MORE MAGNIFIED. THAT THERE WHEN
THERE IS A CHANGE OF CONTRACTOR
YOU'RE WORKING YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT PRIMARILY M. AS AN
IMMIGRANT WORK FORCE- PRIMARILY
AT. AS INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN
LOW. PAID JOBS WHO- BY NO FAULT
OF THEIR OWN- A NEW CAR. AND
SHOULD LEAST HAVE THE OP TO
PROVE THEMSELVES IT NOT RE. THE
HùTO KEEP EIGHTY EMPLOY. WHO
IS NOT PER. IN- AT PAR IN FACT
THE- WHO KNOWS THAT THE BEST IS
THAT IT THE HOTEL- THEMSELVES
TOO AND THEY CAN TELL AND SHARE
THAT WITH THE NEW CONTRACTOR.
THAT DOESN'T REQUIRE- THE
COMPANY TO KEEP A BAD EMPLOYEE
IF YOU WELL AND IN FACT BUT
WHAT PEOPLE MISS IN THIS ISN'T
LIKE NORMAL CONTRACTING HAS IT
WOULD SEEM. THE SUPERVISORS AND
MANAGEMENT ACTUALLY WORK FOR
THE HOTEL NOT THE CONTRACTOR-
MOST OFTEN SO THEY ARE ALREADY
HAVING THAT INFORMATION ABOUT
EMPLOYEES WHO SHOULD BE
DISMISSED AND ARE LREADY IN
THE PROCESS. OF DISMISSING
THOSE EMPLOYEES UNDER THE
PREVIOUS CONTRACT. AND
SECONDING I GUESS MISS OFTEN
REYES SO THE ISSUE AROUND.
FIFTEEN HOURS OF EMPLOYMENT-
AND THE POSSIBLE TO ME MY DO
SEPARATE OUR A DIFFERENT. LOOK
IT YOU WILL TO. THE NEXT
CLARIFYING THE LANGUAGE AS
WELL. THAT IS THE FIRST TIME
I'VE HEARD THAT ARGUMENT AND
I'M A LITTLE CONFUSED BECAUSE
ANYBODY WHO HAS- WHEN AS PART
TIME EMPLOYMENT THERE ARE MANY-WORKERS WHO WORK AT MULTIPLE
LOCATIONS IN ORDER TO. COBBLE
TOGETHER A FULL TIME SALARY-
BUT THAT LOCATION THAT THEY'RE
WORKING OUT IS CONSIDERED THEIR
JOB FOR THAT MOUNT SO- I'M
ASSUMING IT IF AN EMPLOYER. AND
EMPLOYEE WANTS TO STAY WITH A
CERTAIN CONTRACTOR AND THEY'RE
BEING MAINTAINED BY THAT
CONTRACTOR AND OTHER POSITIONS
THAT'S IRRELEVANT TO WHETHER
THEY CONTINUE TO DO THAT WORK
AT THAT. LOCATION OKAY MA'AM
YOU THAT THE LARGER CONCERNS
YOU NOTICE I MEAN AS WITH YUR
PREVIOUS BILLS THE WORLD'S
CHANGED GREAT DEAL LAST TWENTY
YEARS AGO. NUMBER SPECIALIZED
SERVICES THE IN OWN COUNTRIES
PROVIDE PARTICULAR KIND OF
NARROW SERVICES JOE TELLS YOU
ROOMS AND PARKING CARS WELL THE
YOU KNOW. MORE LIKE RESERVATION
TAKING IN. THE RESERVATION
TAKING ISN'T PART OF THE
COUNTRY SHOULD ANSWER WHY I WAS
GOING TO SAY AND I AM GRATEFUL
OR DIE GESAMTE COMMITTEE FOR
PIG SHIFTING- THE AMENDMENTS TO
CLARIFY IN THOSE AREAS BUT- YOU
KNOW THERE IS THE POSSIBILITY.
SOMEBODY WORKS IN MULTIPLE
LOCATIONS AND SO. AB IT SEEMS
CHANGE REGIONAL FIFTY HOURS IS
GOING OF A SMALL AMOUNT CUT
THAT UP SOME MORE. MAYBE THAT'S
REASONABLE TO CONSIDER SOME
CLARIFICATION. FIFTEEN HOURS
THEY HAVE TO AT LEAST WORK
FIFTEEN HOURS AT THAT PRIMARY
LOCATION AT THE PRIMARY
LOCATION HIGHER IS THAT WE ARE
SUGGEST WELL ADULT GAS I MEAN
THAT THERE WAS MISS HAWKINS
CONCERNED THAT IT WASN'T AT ONE
LOCATION MIGHT BE A MOBILE WITH
MULTIPLE LOCATIONS. BUT WE CAN
LEAVE IT I SEEM TO CONFUSE YOU
M. I AM CONFUSED A LITTLE BIT.
WE COULD TALK FURTHER WE DON'T
HAVE TO SUBMIT MY UNDERSTANDING
FROM HER FROM HER TESTAMENT
ACTUALLY IS SHE STILL HERE
SHE'S STILL HERE SO IF YOU
WOULD MIND CLARIFYING.
MEASUREMENTS SO I'M NOT
SPEAKING FOR YOU IN A WAY THAT
DOES MAKE SENSE. SO YOU KNOW
TWO OF OUR POINTS I THINK RATES
ARE UNDER THE DEFINITIONS IN
THE BILL. THERE'S KIND OF TWO
LIMITATIONS RIGHT ONE IS THAT A
CONTRACTOR MEANS SOMEONE WHO
PLAYS TWENTY FIVE OR MORE AND
IT'S NOT CLEAR THERE. WHETHER
THAT MEANS TWENTY FIVE OR MORE
PEOPLE AT LIKE ONE HOTEL OR ONE
LOCATION OR NOT AND THEN. THE
SECOND AND THERE'S NO COURT
CASES INTERPRETING THAT'S
RUNNING SHORT THE SECOND I
THINK IT IS A THE FIFTEEN HOUR
PER WEEK **** AND SUBSECTION C.
OF TEN SIXTEEN- THAT SO
ESSENTIALLY FOR AN EMPLOYEE TO
FALL UNDER THIS BILL. YOU HAVE
TO WORK A LEAST FIFTEEN HOURS
PER WEEK YOUR PRIMARY PLACE OF
EMPLOYMENT HAS TO BE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. UNDER A
CONTRACT TO PROVIDE YOU KNOW
WHAT WOULD BE AN ALCATEL
SERVICES. SO FOR EXAMPLE IF I
AM A HOTEL WORKER UNDER THIS
BILL RIGHT I PROVIDE- I DON'T
VALLEY SERVICES I GUESS AND I
WORK. FORTY HOURS A WEEK BUT I
WORK FIVE HOURS A WEEK AT ONE
HOTEL BUT RICK THIRTY FIVE
HOURS A WEEK AND A DIFFERENT
HOTEL AND THE HOTEL CONTRACTOR
I WORK FIVE HOURS A WEEK IS
CANCELED. IT SEEMS TO ME THAT I
KNOW FALL UNDER THE DEFINITION
OF EMPLOYEE. UNDER THIS. ACT
AND SO YOU KNOW I WOULD THEN.
THE NEW VALLEY AT THAT SUPPORT
TO WHERE I ONLY WORK FIVE HOURS.
WOULD HAVE STILL HAVE TO HIRE
ME AWAY. I WANNA BE CLEAR AND
NOT VETS IN THIS AN JUST TRY
TO. THERE YOU HAVE IT THAT'S
HELD OUT SERVICE WORK YOU'RE A
TRAIN AT THE LOOK. WHERE YOUR
PROVIDER THE VALLEYS SERVICES
SO THEY DO GET BROKEN BY FIVE
BUT THERE MIGHT AN EMERGENCY SO.
WE SOMEBODY HAD TO FILL IN. AB
I DON'T WANT TO I. YOU KNOW SHE
SAID SOMETHING THAT WE FOUND.
AND SHE'S NOT SURE THIS WORKS
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN EXISTENCE FOR
TWENTY YEARS AND THERE'S NO
LAWSUIT TO SUGGEST THAT IT
DOESN'T WORK. SO I AM NOT ONE
WHO'S GOING TO COME IN AND
CHANGE THE JANITORIAL
PROTECTION- THAT HAS WORKED FOR
TWENTY PLUS YEARS. AND HAS BEEN
A RESOUNDING SUCCESS IT HAS THE
SAME TYPE OF MIGRATORY NATURE
AS- CONTACTED BACK MORE SO THAN
THEY DO IN A HOTEL ASPECT. THAT
BEING SAID I'D I'D BE HAPPY TO
TALK THROUGH THAT- WE ARE
SAYING IF YOU WORK FIFTEEN
HOURS AT A SPECIFIC LOCATION
YOUR CONTRACTOR THAT. THAT
HOTEL M. THERE MIGHT BE A
SITUATION WHERE A CHAIN OF
HOTELS HAS THE SAME CONTRACTOR
THEY'RE GOING FROM HOTEL TO
HOTEL. AND THAT THAT'S SIMILAR
TO JANITORIAL WE STILL REQUIRE
THE CONTRACTOR TAKE TO OFFER-
THE EMPLOYEE SIXTY SIXTY DAYS
OF SERVICE SIXTY DAYS AFTER
THAT. PRETTY CLEAR GET RID OF.
AND AS SOON MEANS MANY FIND A
CLARIFYING- I MEAN I YOU KNOW I
STILL CONTEND HONESTLY THAT
IT'S NOT CLEAR IN THE STATUE
THAT HAS TO BE THE SAME
LOCATION AND MAYBE VALLEY WAS A
BAD. EXAMPLE RIGHT MAYBE
SOMETHING MORE APPROPRIATE
WOULD BE I DON'T PROVIDING SOME
SORT REALLY FOOD AND BEVERAGE
SERVICE OR SOMETHING- AND JUST
TO CLARIFY WHAT I SAID IS NOT
THAT THERE'S EVER BEEN QUITE
NOT BEEN CLAIMS OR LAWSUITS
IT'S NEVER. BUT THERE'S NEVER
BEEN A PUBLISHED DECISION.
CLARIFYING THIS SPECIFIC
PROVISION THAT'S WHAT I MEANT
AND AGAIN MY INTEREST HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS NOT. TO TAKE
ISSUE WITH THE BILL BUT JUST
YOU KNOW TO PLACE ON RECORD TO
IT IN THIS PARTICULAR INSTANCE.
I JUST I HAVE TO SAY FOR
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN SUCH A
SUCCESS FOR- FOR. LOW INCOME
WORKERS AT IN THE JANITORIAL-
OPPORTUNITY ACT ARE. YOU KNOW
IS THAT THAT I MEAN THERE THERE
HAS BEEN VERY AGAIN. I DON'T
KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN- MANY
LAWSUITS OBVIOUSLY ANOTHER
CLEAR FINER PUBLISHED ON THE
SUBJECT AND THAT SHOULD JUST
SHOW US WHAT A SUCCESS IT IS
JUST PICKING APART SOMETHING
THAT COULD BE A FUTURE. BECAUSE
FOR A LAWSUIT I GUESS WE COULD
DO THAT FOR EVERY BILL THAT
WHEN WE HAVE A LOT IN WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE IS NOT
CHANGING. EXISTING LAW WE'RE
TAKING THE EXISTING LAW AND
ADDING SIMILARLY SITUATED
EMPLOYEES TO THAT LAW JANITORS
AT HOTELS HAVE THIS PROTECTION.
THEY HAVE THIS PROTECTION RIGHT
NOW SO IF YOU GO TO THE- THE
SHERATON RIGHT OVER HERE YOU'LL
SEE THAT THE JANITORIAL STAFF
IS NOT HOTEL STAFF THEY
ACTUALLY WORK FOR A CONTRACTOR.
IF THE HOTEL CHANGES THE
CONTRACTOR FOR THE JANITORIAL
WORK THOSE EMPLOYEES HAVE THE
RIGHT TO STAY THERE FOR SIXTY
DAYS WITH THE NEW CONTRACTOR TO
PROVE THEMSELVES ALL WE'RE
SAYING IS. SO SHOULD THE HOTEL
HOUSEKEEPER- IT SEEMS TO ME AN
OBVIOUS THING SINCE IT'S BEEN
SO SUCCESSFUL- AND WE HAVE NO
PARAMETERS ON ON THE- THE SIZE
OF THE LOCATION OF THE JANITOR
TO WORKING THAT WE SHOULD
EXTEND THIS TO SIMILARLY
SITUATED. BY THE WAY MAINLY
WOMEN EMPLOYEES. PROJECT THAT I
GOT TAKE THAT TO MEAN YOU'RE
WILLING TO WORK FOR THE
OPPOSITION TO CLICK. I AM
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION I I'VE GOT TO BE
REALLY HONEST WITH THIS BECAUSE
I DON'T I NEVER MAKE A PROMISE
THAT I CAN'T KEEP MY I CANNOT
CHANGE THE EXISTING. CHEN CHOI
OPPORTUNITY ACT IN ANY WAY- FOR
THE PROVISIONS THAT EXISTS
THERE FOR AN ACT THAT'S BEEN SO
SUCCESSFUL AND HAS PROVIDED SO
IF YOU IN FACT NONE THEY CAN'T
EVEN COME UP WITH A SINGLE
PROBLEM THAT'S PROVIDED- AND I.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT I THINK
THEY THINK THEIR CONCERN IS
THAT AS YOU EXTEND. THE ACT
INTO OTHER VERTICALS TO JUST TO
ENSURE THAT WHERE THOSE- SORT
OF WORK FUNCTIONS MIGHT BE
DIFFERENT THAT IT'S PROBABLY
CALIFORNIA. ABSOLUTELY AND
THAT'S WHAT THE REASONS WE WORK
SO CLOSELY TIED TO FIND THOSE
THOSE OCCUPATIONS THAT LINE UP
WITH- BOTH THE WORKFORCE IN THE
TYPE OF WORK THAT ARE TO BE
DONE BY JANITORS. WHO SHOULD
THANK YOU MISTER. OKAY SIR
NEWMAN- ANY ANYBODY- SENATOR
ALSO. YEAH I WANT TO AGAIN
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS- I
SPENT SEVERAL DECADES. IN THE
HOTEL AND FOOD SERVICE
INDUSTRY. AND- OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF DECADES WE HAVE HAD
SOME VERSION OF THIS. PASSED IN
LOS ANGELES AND THE SKY IS NOT
FALLING THINGS AREN'T YOU KNOW
THERE'S NO BIRTH QUAKE IN THAT
INDUSTRY IS DOING QUITE WELL
SHORT OF THE PANDEMIC- AND IN A
NUMBER OF SITUATIONS WE SO WE
PASSED VERY VARIOUS FORMS OF A
RETENTION NORTON IS THE FIRST
WAS. OUT OF LOS ANGELES LAX AND
WHEN THOSE CON CONTRACTED OUT
WORKERS WERE CHANGED. FOR
WHATEVER DIFFERENT REASONS.
THOSE WORKERS HUNDREDS OF THEM
WERE FIRED. HUNDREDS WERE
TERMINATED IT HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH A FEW PLOYS WHO WEREN'T
PERFORMING AT PAR HUNDREDS. AND
THE HUNDREDS WHO WERE WE PLATE
WILL BE REPLACED. WHEN FROM.
SEVERAL DOLLARS AN HOUR HIGHER
THAN MINIMUM WAGE DOWN TO
MINIMUM WAGE NO HEALTH
INSURANCE NO PENSION NO NOTHING.
AND I'VE SEEN SO MANY EXAMPLES
OF THAT BEFORE THE STATE
JANITORIAL OF LAW WAS PASSED
THE CITY HAD- JANITORIAL
SERVICES IN THE AND ALL OF THE
LIBRARIES A CHANGE CONTRACTOR.
ALL THOSE WORKERS WERE FIRED
ALL OF THEM WERE TERMINATED AND
IT JUST HAS HAPPENED. OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND THE
SAME THING WITH HOTELS HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH A FEW
EMPLOYEES. WHO AREN'T
PERFORMING AT PAR THAT COULD
EASILY BE TAKEN CARE OF BECAUSE
THE HOTEL COULD TELL THE
COMPANY DOING IN CHARGE HEY
THIS IS WRONG YOU GOT TO FIX IT
IF IT'S AN EMPLOYEE. YOU GOT TO
DEAL WITH IT BUT IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN USED AS A WAY TO- FOR THE
INCUMBENT CONTRACTOR TO PAY A
LOT LESS. NO BENEFITS AND NO
ANY KIND OF PROTECTION SO I
THINK IT'S- IT'S REALLY GREAT.
TO GET A PASS A LAW LIKE THIS
PAST. THAT WOULD WOULD PROTECT
THESE- HOTEL WORKERS. I CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT THE HOTEL
INDUSTRY. I WAS ON THE
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE OF THE LOS
ANGELES. CONVENTION AND
VISITORS BUREAU FOR MANY YEARS-
AND I WILL DO EVERYTHING TO
HELP THAT INDUSTRY PROSPER. BUT
AT THE SAME TIME IT SHOULD BE
DONE ON THE BACKS OF THESE
WORKERS WHO GIVE SO MUCH WHO
WORKS SO HARD. AND JUST BECAUSE
YOU'RE GONNA CHANGE CONTRACTOR
YOU WOULD AUTOMATICALLY LOSE
YOUR JOB THAT'S JUST.
FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR SO THANK
YOU. SIX ROSALYN OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES MEMBERS
YOUR. MAKE SURE HAVE RIGHT HERE
IN THE QUESTIONS. WHAT HAPPENS-
IF THE CONTRACTOR THAT
CURRENTLY HOUSES EMPLOYEES-
THAT WORK FOR HIM OR HER. MOVE
ON WHEN HE MOVES ON TO THE NEXT
CONTRACT WHAT HAPPENS IS IT
PLEASE IF HE NEEDS THAT I'M
JUST CURIOUS TO KNOW- BECAUSE
WORKERS SOON MEAN HERE
INFERRING THAT THEY ARE
AUTOMATICALLY GOING TO BE-
UNEMPLOYED AT THIS PARTICULAR
SITE BUT WHAT HAPPENS IF THE
CONTRACTOR MOVES TO A DIFFERENT
SITE AND HE NEEDS THESE
EMPLOYEES TO GO TO THE NEXT
CONTRACT- PER SE. HOW DOES HOW
DOES HOW DO WE WORK AROUND
THAT- NOTION FOR THE NEED FOR
THE ACTUAL CONTRACTOR MOVING
FORWARD M. WELL A CONTRACTOR
OBVIOUSLY HAS NO RIGHT EVER TO
FORCE SOMEBODY TO WORK FOR THEM
THAT'S FOUNDATIONAL I THINK TO
OUR COUNTRY- BUT OBVIOUSLY IF
IT'S A CONTRACTOR THAT THE
EMPLOYEE WANTS TO CONTINUE TO
WORK FOR THE EMPLOYEE WILL MOVE
WITH THE CONTRACTOR. IF THE
EMPLOYEE AND I THINK WHAT'S
HARD FOR PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
ESPECIALLY IN THE HOTEL
INDUSTRY AND WE'VE WE'VE TRIED
TO. A TACKLE THIS RENOWNED OF
LAW. THEY HAVE WHERE ALL. THINK
OF THEM AS WELL. AT THIS HOTEL
NOT FOR THE CALL. RIGHT SO
SUPER. MAYBE AT THE HOTEL THERE
WERE IN THE UNIFORM OF THE
WHOLE. YOU KNOW I GO TO EVERY
DAY WORK FOR THE SHERATON BUT I
DON'T ACTUALLY WORK THE
SHERATON I WORK FOR A
CONTRACTOR AND ALL I'M ASKING
FROM AN EMPLOYEE STANDPOINT IS.
ARE YOU CHANGE THE CONTRACTOR
THIS IS WHERE I WORK GIVE ME
SIXTY DAYS TO PROVE MYSELF TO
THE NEW CONTRACTOR. IF I FEEL
LIKE I'M WORKING FOR THIS
CONTRACTOR IN VALLEY WAS A
GOOD. EXAMPLE IN THIS SENSE
RIGHT SO I. I HATE USING
SPECIFICS BUT YOU KNOW IT IN
VALLEY INDUSTRY THERE'S TWO OR
THREE BIG VALLEY OPERATORS
RIGHT- ONE OF THEM HAPPENS TO
BE UNION SO YOU SAY. WELL LOOK
AT THIS I HAD THIS UNION
TEAMSTER JOB WITH ACE PARKING-
THAT THE- HOTELS NO LONGER
USING THIS I'D RATHER GO. TO
THIS OTHER PLACE WITH WITH AND
BY THE WAY I PROTECTIONS
BECAUSE I'M- HAVE UNION
CONTRACTS I WILL GET OFFERED A
JOB SOMEWHERE ELSE. AND I MAY
WANT TO GO DO THAT THE THAT THE
EMPLOYEE DOESN'T HAVE TO STAY
AT THE LOCATION. HOWEVER IF
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE THAT'S
BEEN THEIR JOB TO HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY PROVE THEMSELVES
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THAT INDIVIDUAL
EMPLOYEE. WHO HAS THE LEAST
LEVERAGE IN THE SITUATION. AND
IT HAS BEEN DOING THE MOST
AMOUNT OF WORK. SO THERE'S NO-
PRIORITY AS TO WHO THE EMPLOYEE
HAS THE LOYALTY TO WHETHER IT'S
THE CONTRACTOR WHO EMPLOYSTHEM
DIRECTLY OR THE FACILITY THAT
HAS CURRENTLY THE CONTRA. WHAT
THE HELL TO PER SE OR THE
MARRIOTT IN THIS CASE SO
THERE'S REALLY WITH THIS BILL
THE WOULDN'T BE AB EIGHTY. IT
LOYALTY PRIORITY FOR THE
EMPLOYEE AS TO WHO THEY'RE
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO STAY WITH
THAT WELL I GUESS TO BE UP TO
EVERY INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYEE OF
HOW THEY FELT THAT LITTLE TEAR
WHETHER- BUT THE PROSPECTS WERE
IN EACH PLACE. OKAY. I GOTTA BE
HONEST- IT'S UNUSUAL RIGHT I
GET ACTUALLY GAVE UP AN EXAMPLE
MAYBE I SHOULDN'T OF A SERVICE
WORKER WHO MAY WANT TO MOVE
WITH THE CONTRACTOR BECAUSE THE
CONTRACTOR ACTUALLY PROVIDES
MORE THAN THAN NORMAL
CONTRACTORS IN THAT SERVICE BUT
THAT'S HIGHLY UNUSUAL- AND
USUALLY PEOPLE ARE PROUD OF THE-WORK THEY'RE DOING ANY WORK
PLACE AND WHAT THE ABILITY TO
CONTINUE THERE'S A NUMBER OF
FACTORS THAT GO INTO THAT RIGHT
AYE. I'M WORKING AT THE HILTON
BECAUSE IT'S ON THE BUS LINE
FROM WHERE I LIVE AND I HAVE TO
DROP MY KIDS OFF AND YOU KNOW
IT MAY NOT SUIT ME TO GO TO IT
AT DIFFERENT LOCATION TO WORK
AND I WANT THE OPPORTUNITY
PROVED HIMSELF SO IT IS FROM
FROM A- AT AT AN EMPLOYEE WHO
HAS VERY LITTLE LEVERAGE
OTHERWISE WHO WANTS JUST THE
OPPORTUNITYTO STAY EMPLOYED AT
THE SAME LOCATION HOWEVER IF
THERE ARE. THEY REALLY LIKE
THEIR CONTRACTOR THEIR OFFER
ANOTHER POSITION ALLOWS THEM TO
DO THAT AS WELL. FROM. OKAY
I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT THANK YOU.
ANYTHING ELSE. THANK YOU-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND- HI I JUST
WANNA SAY I THINK I'M SATISFIED
I THINK THERE'S SOME CONFUSION-
FIRST OF ALL WITH REGARD TO.
IT'S JUST IN TERMS OF THE
TESTIMONY HEARD MIXING UP
LOCATION WITH- CONTRACTOR
EMPLOYER WHICH IS TO BE WELL
DEFINED IN THE- IN THE- IN THE
BILL IN AND I THINK COULD BE
ANALYSIS DID A GOOD JOB OF.
SEPARATING THAT OUT IT ISN'T
NECESSARILY THE SAME LOCATION
IT IS THE SAME EMPLOYER
CONTRACTOR- THAT IS REALLY- AT
THE HEART OF THE MATTER HERE
IN. THE WE KNOW PUBLIC SECTOR
CONTRACTING IT'S VERY COMMON TO
HAVE THESE KIND OF RETENTION
AGREEMENTS I THINK YOU'RE
BRINGING THIS OVER INTO A
PRIVATE SECTOR. A SCENARIO WITH
THE SAME PRINCIPLES INVOLVED
OF- OFFERING RETENTION FIRST
WHEN A NEW CONTRACTOR COMES IN
SO- I AM I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THE
BILL I APPRECIATE YOU. WORKING
THROUGH AGAIN WORKING THROUGH
AMENDMENTS WITH COMMITTEE STAFF
HERE- AND GETTING THOSE CLEAR
ENOUGH FOR US TO. BE PREPARED
TO MOVE THE BILL TODAY SUCH A
MOVE BILL TODAY SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- IS THERE A MOTION-
ECONOMY OF CONFUSED GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE IT WASN'T
MY JOBS. NO I APPRECIATE AGAIN
I HAVE TO THANK YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF AND MY STAFF WHO WORKED
SO- HAN TRYING ON DEFINITIONS
AND YOU YOU KNOW SO WHEN THE
THINGS YOU REALLY HAVE TO GET
RIGHT TO MAKE SURE YOU'RE NOT
LEAVING OUT TOO MANY PEOPLE ARE
IN YOU'RE NOT BRINGING IN TOO
MANY PEOPLE SO. I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THAT I WANT TO NOTE
AS WELL- I ACTUALLY CARRIED THE
BILL FOR GROCERY WORKER
RETENTION AND THAT WAS-
ACTUALLY AT SALE OF AN ENTIRE
GROCERY STORE. WHEN A GROCERY
STORE SOLD THE WORKERS GET
SIXTY DAYS TO PROVE. THEMSELVES
TO NEW OWNER THIS MAY BE A
COMPLETE DIFFERENT OF GROCERY
STORE IT CAN. A DIFFERENT SIZE
THE GROCERY STORE- THAT WAS
PASSED AND SIGNED FIVE YEARS
AGO OKAY AND IT WAS CONSIDERED
A JOB KILLER THE TIME AND AGAIN
WE HAVE A HEARD. A PROBLEM AYE
IT'S SOUNDS GUESS AND- LIKE
SOMETHING THAT THAT'S MUCH MORE
ONEROUS THAN IT IS AND IN THIS
SITUATION WE TALK ABOUT
CONTRACTORS WHO CHANGE AND
SHIFT OFTEN- IN ORDER IN
GETTING A NEW CONTRACT WOULD
PROBABLY HAVE TO HIRE NEW
PEOPLE ANYWAY. THEY OFTEN TRY
TO HIRE NEW PEOPLE BECAUSE
IT'LL REDUCE THE COST OF THEIR
WORKFORCE- WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS
TO GIVE THESE WORKERS ARE
OPPORTUNITY. TO THEMSELVES TO A
NEW CONTRACT. AND WE'RE WE'RE
DEALING WITH THOSE WORKERS WHO
HAVE THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
LEVERAGE TO BE ABLE TO. INSIST
IF YOU WELL OR OR FORGE- A
REQUIREMENT A RELATIONSHIP WITH
A NEW CONTRACTOR AND SO GIVING
THEM THAT OPPORTUNITY JUST TO
PROVE THEMSELVES FOR SIXTY DAYS
DOES NOT SEEM LIKE A- TO ME. A
TO HONOR SITUATION. AND TODAY
IT'S PERFECT TIMING TO DO IT DO
IT QUITE FRANKLY BECAUSE IN
TODAY'S LABOR MARKET I THINK-
THE ONE. ONE THING THAT. PEOPLE
ARE SCRAMBLING FORCE MORE
SERVICE WORKERS SO. THANK YOU
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL WE
DO FROM CENTER DRAWS OVER. HE
AND WITH THAT METASOMA SHOULD
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED AND BE RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COURTESY RIGHT
COURTESY AYE OR TROUBLE. NO BUT
CHOI BOGUE NO THE REST SO. I
HAD TO WRESTLE I LAYERED. THERE
AYE NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE. OKAY
THANK YOU- THAT PASSES FORTY
ONE HAS THE BILLS OUT- WELL-
WE'RE GETTING CLEANED UP HERE
FOR ASSUME JOINS JONES SAWYER
TO COME UP- I WAS GONNA ASK-
THE CONSULTANT TO. CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FROM THE%
PREVIOUS BILL SO WE HAVE THAT
OUT OF THE WAY. MEMBER I SHOULD
SAY YEAH I KNOW WHO YOU MATH.
AB EIGHT NINETY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LAYERED HI THERE
I. OKAY IN THE FINAL VOTE AND
ISSUED A UNANIMOUS UP BILLS ON.
AB ELEVEN OH SIX SAID RENTALS
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LAYERED HI. I
THE FINAL VOTE IS ALSO
UNANIMOUS ON THE BILL SO. AB
FOUR ZERO TWO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LAYERED HI THERE I. IN THAT
MAKE SOMEONE UNANIMOUS AS WELL
AND THE BILL WAS OUT IN IF YOU
COULD CALL THE CONSENT ITEM IF
WE HAVE A MOTION ON CONSENT I
SHINE MOVERS THIS MOVE BY
SENATOR LAYERED. CONSENT H. A.
R. NINE COOPER THE MOTION IS
THAT THE MEASURE BE ADOPTED
COURTESY ALL RIGHT. COURTESY I
HOPE CHOI BOGUE. I WAS TROUBLED
BY THE RUSSELL. THE RUSSELL I
LAYERED HI THERE I NEWMAN.
NEWMAN AYE OKAY CONSENT IS OUT
ALSO ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE IN NOW
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER. I
KNOW YOU WERE HERE 2% AB EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT AND PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN THANK YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT WHICH ALLOWS HEALTH CARE
WORKERS PROVIDING DIRECT CARE
TO OVERRIDE A HOSPITAL
ALGORITHM WHEN IT'S WITHIN
THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE WHICH
INCLUDES PHYSICIAN APPROVAL AND
ULTIMATELY IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF THE PATIENT. I WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THAT THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
TO CLARIFY THIS BILL DOES NOT
ALLOW FOR THE OVERRIDE A
PHYSICIAN'S ORDERS AS WELL AS
SPECIFIES THAT SCOPE OF
PRACTICE COULD ALSO INCLUDE
APPROVAL FROM A DOCTOR OF
PODIATRIC MEDICINE REMOVED
OPPOSITION FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS
THE CALIFORNIA PROJECTED
MEDICAL SOCIAL EDUCATION. AND A
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION ALL HAVE REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION WHILE
ALGORITHMS ARE AN IMPORTANT
TOOL USED TO KEEP IT USED TO
HELP DECIDE THE BEST COURSE OF
TREATMENT FOR MILLIONS OF
PATIENTS A YEAR. IF MADE BY A
AND CPAS RATIO BIAS IN THE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY HAS WELL
BEEN DOCUMENTED. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN RESEARCHERS STUDIED
THE OPERATIVE A WIDELY USE
HOSPITAL ALGORITHM AND FOUND IT
EXHIBITED SIGNIFICANT RACIAL
BIASES WHENEVER FOR BLACK
PATIENTS TO EXTRA CARE PROGRAM
SIGNIFICANTLY FEWER THAN WHITE-PATIENTS. ALTHOUGH TECHNOLOGY
CAN COMPLEMENT AND SKIP THE
SKILLS AND DECISION MAKING OF
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS. IT IS
IMPORTANT IT IS NOT A
REPLACEMENT FOR REAL LIFE
EXPERIENCE I'VE HAD MY OWN
EXPERIENCE WITH THE
INTERVENTION OF A NURSE. IN MY
TREATMENT OF DIABETES AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW ABOUT FORTY POUNDS
LIGHTER. AND MUCH HEALTHIER AND
BECAUSE THE ADVICE OF A NURSE
SOME OF YOU MAY EVEN KNOWS THAT
THERE WAS THE DAUGHTER. OF
FORMER LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
MARIE DONNELLY BUT BUT DAUGHTER
SISTER DIMMER LINDEGAARD BERMAN
TIMELY COULD ADVISE ME. ON HOW
ON HOW TO EAT HEALTHIER DRINK
MY WATER GET MY REST GET OFFICE
DRESS WHICH WAS KIND OF HARD TO
DO HIS MOTHER TODAY. AND WITHIN
A YEAR- I WAS OFF INSULIN.
BECAUSE OF ALL THREE THE
ALGORITHM. THE DOCTOR AND A
NURSE ALL COLLABORATING
TOGETHER TO GIVE ME ADVICE
ESPECIALLY THE NURSE WHO TALKED
TO ME LIKE MY MOTHER MADE ME.
DO SOME THINGS THAT I PROBABLY
WOULD HAVE DONE. OTHERWISE TO
SAY BASICALLY SAVED MY LIFE.
BOB WE ARE THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
INCREASINGLY PASSED BILLS TO
ADDRESS IMPLICIT BIASES OF
INDIVIDUALS. SUCH AS TECHNOLOGY
BECOMES MORE MORE INGRAINED
INTO OUR SOCIETY IS ONLY RIGHT
THAT WE TAKE THE SAME STEPS TO
ADDRESS ITS LIMITATIONS AS
WELL. ESPECIALLY IF WE MOVED
TOWARD- HEALTH CARE WE'RE
TALKING TO TELEMEDICINE. WE
NEED AND REMEMBER NOT TO REMOVE
THE PERSONAL. PART OF THAT SO
IT'S TECHNOLOGY BECOMES MORE
MORE INGRAINED IN OUR SOCIETY
MAJOR HOSPITALS ACROSS THE
STATE ALREADY RECOGNIZED THIS
NEED AND HAVE INCORPORATED THE
SAME RETALIATION PROTECTIONS
THIS BILL IS CREATING INTO
THEIR OWN. POLICIES SUCH
ALTERNATELY WHEN WE ALLOW
ALGORITHMS DOCTORS AND NURSES
TO WORK TOGETHER TO PROVIDE THE
BEST CARE POSSIBLE REDUCE THE
IMPACT THE BIASES IN ALL
ASPECTS OF HEALTH CARE. WE WILL
SAVE LIVES. AB EIGHT FIVE EIGHT
PROMOTES PATIENT WELL BEING
IMPROVES PATIENT QUALITY OF
CARE BY PUTTING THE TRUST BACK
INTO THE HANDS OF THE WORKERS.
PROPERLY TRAINED TO DO THEIR
JOBS WITH ME TODAY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE THIS
TABLE JACKSON ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL'S SPONSOR. THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND JANICE
O'MALLEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH JIM
TAYLOR JACKSON IF YOU'RE- READY
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DEALERTRACK FAMILY THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
PROUD SPONSORS OF AB EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOHN
PLAYERS THAT IMPLICIT BIAS IS A
HUGE ISSUE AND HEALTHCARE.
REFORM SHAUN BIASES INHERENT IN
THE ALGORITHM YOUR- WILL. THING
FROM PUTTING PRESCRIPTION PLAN
DESIGNATING PATIENT ACUITY AND
DETERMINING WHEN YOU'RE GOING
TO BE DISCHARGED. EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT INSURANCE THE NURSE CAN
DISAGREE WITH THE CLINICAL
ALGORITHM WILL MAKE THE BEST.
DECISION FOR THEIR UNIQUE
PATIENT WITHOUT FEAR OF
PUNISHMENT FROM THEIR EMPLOYER.
SOLELY FOR THAT HM AB EIGHT
FIVE ENOUGH TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GREATER
WORKER AND GAUGE MELANCHOLIC
YOU HOSPITAL. ASKING THAT
WORKERS BE NOTIFIED WHEN NEW
TECHNOLOGY AFFECTING THEIR JOB
IS BEING BROUGHT IN. THAT
WORKERS GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GIVE INPUT ON WHAT KIND OF
TECHNOLOGY IS NOT YET. ANOTHER
FOUR YEARS PROVIDE ADEQUATE
TRAINING FOR THE NEW.
TECHNOLOGY OUR BOUND BY THEIR
LIFE. ULTIMATELY WORKING
REGULARLY IN THEIR HIGHER LOOK
MAINTENANCE OF THEIR- DD YOU
WANT RIGHT PROVIDE THE HEARING
TREATMENT POSSIBLE HOWEVER
WITHOUT A CLEARLY OUT WILL
PROBABLY PRODUCTION IN THE
BECAUSE FOR DOING. MOSTLY WOULD
HELP THEIR WORK OKAY THE TO BE
FORBIDDEN POSITION FOR THE FACT
HERE THEY ARE PROVIDING FOR
THEIR PRE. WHAT WE'RE TALKING
WIDELY ON THE LINE. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT IS NOT
BEING WORKER WOULD BE FREE OVER.
MODEL OR DISCIPLINE CALIFORNIA
HAS YOU KNOW ARE QUITE BY OVER
THEM. AND GET SOME BECAUSE WHEN
OVER LOCAL. ONE OF. AND THAT'S
ALL THE MATH TO CHANGE THE FAR.
OFF LITTLE RETAIN IT IT
DIFFICULT TO WORK- BRING AND
I'M THINK PRACTICAL. I WOULD
RATHER KNOW QUITE ALGORITHMS
AND TECHNOLOGY. MOST OVERSIGHT
PROCESS WE ARE NOT HELPFUL YOU
OFF ON HOW THE USED WHAT
IMPLEMENT I'M LIKE AFTER. WORK.
NUMBER ONE WITH FORM. ON THE
PARADE WOULD NOT WILL BE IN
YEARS BEFORE YOUR- ONE MAN THAT.
FOR THAT REASON YOU KNOW
RESPECTFUL ASK YOUR I GO ON
EACH SIDE. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK JACKSON DODGE SO MANY. IF
YOU'RE PRESSED TO YOU MAY BE.
ESCAPING CORTES AND MY THIS IS
BAILEY WITH CAL THEY FOR. I
WILL HERE IN STRONG OF A FIVE
EIGHT. ECHO THE NINETEEN. HAS
CHRIS AT THE- AND ON MY- AND
TURN OF ACTION RAINY. AND MARK.
AND BELIEVE OUR INTELLIGENCE IS
ANY SOLUTION TO GUIDE CLINICAL
DECISION MAKING PROGRESS NOVEL
DISEASE. RESULTING IN A RAPID
DISSEMINATION OF UNDERDEVELOPED
AND POTENTIALLY BY A MODEL
WHICH MAY EXACERBATE. THE
DISPARITIES GAP. THERE IS HOPE
A CAN GUIDE DECISIONS INCLUDING
THE ALLOCATION OF SCARCE
RESOURCES AND THAT'S QUITE FAR.
HOWEVER IT SHOULD NOT LIMIT THE
INDEPENDENT PROFESSIONAL
CLINICAL JUDGMENT. FOR A
HEALTHCARE WORKERS ABILITY TO
ACT AS A PATIENT ADVOCATE.
ALGORITHM SHOULD NOT DETERMINE
THE CARE NEEDED BY PATIENTS.
GIVEN THE PERVASIVENESS OF BY A
FAILURE TO PROACTIVELY DEVELOP
COMPREHENSIVE MITIGATION
STRATEGIES DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WITH
EXACERBATING EXISTING HEALTH
DISPARITIES UNDER IN THE
ADOPTION OF A AYE TOOL CAPABLE
OF IMPROVING PATIENT OUTCOMES.
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE EIGHT FOUR
COME FROM THE PAST TO MAKE SURE
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR ETHNICITY OR ECONOMIC
STATUS RECEIVE THE BEST CARE
FOR THEM. HEALTHCARE WORKERS
FROM RETALIATION ESTATE REQUEST
OVER RIGHT HEALTH INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY IN CLINICAL PRACTICE
GUIDELINE. LEEPER SAID IS PROUD
TO SUPPORT AB FIVE EIGHT AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
HONOR- EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE EIGHT
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU MISS
O'MALLEY. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES
TO TAKE A POSITION SUPPORT OF
AB A FIFTY EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT
HAVE SO PLEASE COME FORWARD AT
THIS TIME. THE SCENE NO ONE
WILL CHECK THE OVERFLOW ROOM
AND NOTE THAT NOBODY IS THERE
TO TESTIFY. AND WE WILL GO TO
THE MODERATOR KNOWN AS
MODERATOR- IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES
ON AB. EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT AM
PLEASE LET US KNOW THE NUMBER
IF ANY. THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
WELL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
PRESS ONE AND YOUR OF THE WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. BUT TEACHER THERE IS
NO ONE ACCUSED SIGNALED THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY IN THE JUST
A REMINDER BEFORE WE GO TO
OPPOSITION OF FOR THOSE THAT-
WARD HERE EARLIER BUT THERE WAS
SOME QUESTION ABOUT- SOME
TESTIMONY ON SOME EARLY BILLS
WE WILL DO AT THE END OF OUR
AGENDA TODAYIS GIVE ANYONE
OPPORTUNITY WHO WAS MISSED IN
THE EARLIER CUTE TO SPEAK JUST
BY SIMPLY IDENTIFYING THE BILL.
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION POSITION
BUT WE WILL NOT DO THAT UNTIL
WE GET TO THAT OPEN POINT ON
THE AGENDA- NOW TO OPPOSITION
WE HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS ON AB EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT
THAT IS RUNNIG FOR GOOGLE-
EVEN A SPEAK AT THIS TIME- AS I
UNDERSTAND ON THE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE WINE IF YOU
THEIR- YES I AM THANK YOU
CHAIR- GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD
EVENING- CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- RUNNING VERTICAL
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. FEATURED ON THE
CREATION OF THE AMENDMENT TO
THE BILL THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MADE BY THE AUTHOR. HOWEVER WE
REMAIN OPPOSED UNLESS THE
MANDATE- TO THE BILL- THAT IT
DECREASES EXPOSURE. TO
INCREASED LITIGATION PAYER
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION- WHICH
THE BILL CREATED BY PUTTING
CLINICAL PRACTICE- IF THE LABOR
CODE. DOCTOR WITH THAT- LIKE I
SAID- WERE RESPECTFULLY. OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AB. FIVE EIGHT-
BUT THANKS FOR YOUR TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU. YOUR TESTIMONY WILL
ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO TAKE IN OPPOSE
POSITION HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM IF SO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SCENE NO ONE. WILL CHECK YOUR
FOR ROOM SCENE NO ONE. WILL GO
BACK TO MODERNIZE MODERATOR
CHECK FOR ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON AB EIGHT FIFTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO AT THIS
TIME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS. ONE NINE
ZERO. SURE NO ONE IS SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU MODERATOR IT WILL COME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE- WOULDN'T
CHECK WITH MY COLLEAGUES TO SEE
IF ANYBODY HAS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS HERE FROM THE DAIS
SEEN NONE- YOU'RE WELCOME
BECAUSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU COMMITTEE OKAY THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY IS
THERE A MOTION ON A BE A FIFTY
EIGHT. SENATOR NEWMAN MOVES THE
BILL. THE OLD MAN CASOULOS
CRITICAL ROLE PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH COURTESY HI BUT AS THE
I. R. CHOI BOGUE NO THE CHOI
BOGUE NO FOOD RESTAURANTS. THE
REST SO I LAYERED THERE AYE
NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE. IN THE
PALACES OF FORD ONE OF BILLS ON.
H. COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IS SO WELCOME. HELLO YOU ARE
HEROES TO PRESENT AB FOR THIRTY
EIGHT. AND WE'LL GET YOU UP TO
THE PODIUM IN JUST A MOMENT TO
DO THAT. FOR MANY BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
PRESENT TO YOU AB FOUR THIRTY
EIGHT. AND EQUITY MEASURE WHICH
STANDARDIZES THE LAYOFF PROCESS
AND EXTENSIVE HEARING RIGHTS TO
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES SO THE
SAME PROTOCOLS EXIST. WILL
EXIST FOR ALL SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
CERTAINLY THERE'S A DISCREPANCY
IN THE WAY SCHOOLS CONDUCT
LAYOFF NOTICES AS OF NOW ONLY
CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES RECEIVE
A LAYOFF NOTICE OR PINK SLIP.
IF THEY DON'T RECEIVE THE
NOTICE BY MARCH FIFTEENTH AND
JOB IS PROTECTED FOR THE NEXT
SCHOOL YEAR FOR CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES ON THE OTHER HAND CAN
BE LET GO AT ANY POINT IN THE
SCHOOL YEAR WITH JUST A SIXTY
DAY NOTICE. MOREOVER
CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE
TO CONTEST THEIR LEG OFF THE A
HEARING PROCESS CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES ARE NOT AFFORDED THIS
RIGHT. PACIFIED WORKERS OF THE
MOST DIVERSE WORKFORCE ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES AND PROVIDE
CRITICAL SERVICES TO MAINTAIN
SCHOOL OPERATIONS. AB FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT WOULD ENSURE ALL
EMPLOYEES REGARDLESS OF THEIR
JOB TITLE ARE GRANTED THE SAME
LAYOFF NOTICE AND WORKER
PROTECTIONS HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ARE LIBBY
SPONSORS. GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
ADVOCATE FOR SEIU ON THE LOTUS
BUILT ON FLOTUS LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH CSEA. CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU BOTH LIBERTY SUCH AS
WE UNDERSTAND YOUR TOTAL
COVERAGE LINE IS SO YOU MAY
PROCEED. GOOD EVENING MISTER
KAREN MEMBERS WOULD BE SAID
ABOUT HALF OF AT THE AYE YOU
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
THE MEASURE. THE BILL SEEKS TO
RECTIFY ONE ELEMENT OF THE
DRAMATIC DISPARITY IN THE
UNFAIR AND IMBALANCED DYNAMIC
BETWEEN OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
THE LOWEST WAGE WORKERS AND
THEIR EMPLOYERS. ENDEMIC
BROUGHT OUT THE HEROES AMONG US
NONE OF THEM WERE KATE BUT MANY
OF WHOM WERE ONE LADY HERE THAT
BUS DRIVER UNIFORMS OR SPECIAL
ED. AIDE LANYARDS THESE ARE
CLASSIFIED WORKERS HE DIDN'T
MISS A BEAT TO THE DETRIMENT
OF. THE DOCUMENT OF THEIR OWN
HEALTH AND SAFETY TO ENSURE
THAT KIDS WHO RELY ON FREE AND
REDUCED BREAKFAST AND LUNCH FOR
THEIR VERY SURVIVAL BUT- EACH
AND EVERY DAY DURING THE THAT
MAC. AS A PARENT I CANNOT TELL
YOU HOW MANY EMAIL NOTICE THAT
I RECEIVED FOR THE PAST SIXTEEN
MONTHS. FROM THE FACT TO BE
UNIFIED NOTIFYING ME OF ANOTHER
INCIDENT THIS COLD ED AMONG
CLASSIFIED FOOD SERVICE. BUT I
CAN TELL YOU EVEN THOUGH THERE
WERE TOO MANY OF THOSE NOTICES
THE COUNT THOSE HEROES AMONG US
KEPT ON DOING THEIR JOBS AND
NOT JUST WHAT CLASSIFIED
STOCKDALE THEY ARE THE VERY
GLUE THAT KEEPS OUR EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM TOGETHER. ESPECIALLY IN
TIMES LIKE THESE BUT IT IS ALSO
ONE HUNDRED LIKE THESE THAT
THEIR LACK OF JOB SECURITY AND
UNEQUAL TREATMENT UNDER THE LAW
BECOMES SO GLARINGLY AND
OBVIOUSLY WRONG. THE OPPOSITION
WOULD HAVE YOU BELIEVE THAT
PROVIDING CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
FINALLY AND CONSISTENT NOTICE
WOULD CREATE CHAOS GOLDMAN
FAMILY YET NO SUCH SIMILAR
CHAOS ENSUES WHEN FOLLOWING
THESE PROTOCOLS FOR
CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES AND
ADMINISTRATORS. THE REAL CHAOS
IS IN THE LIVES OF CLASSIFIED
STAFF WHO CAN AS THE LOWEST
WAGE WORKERS IN THE SYSTEM
ARCHITECTED TO MANAGE WITH
SIXTY DAYS NOTICE AT ANY TIME
DURING THE YEAR I'M NOT THE
ONLY ONE THEY'RE ENTITLED TO
SIXTY DAYS NOTICE AS UNDER
EXISTING LAW THEY'RE NOT
ALWAYS. THE OPPOSITION WOULD
ALSO HAVE YOU BELIEVE IF
THAT'LL LEAD IN CALL AT THE-
WITH HEARING. APPEALS THE LIGHT
WHAT'S IN THE GLASS NOTE THAT
ONE AGAIN NOT THAT I KNOW THEY-
WITH THEIR TO. THAT HAD BEEN A-
SOUTH AND WARM FOR SUCH EXPAND
WITH BE WITHIN THEIR- AND THEY
WOULD CONTINUE TO HAVE IT
WITHIN THEIR SOUL DISCRETION TO
ISSUE ANY OF THE LAYOFF NOTICES
THAT WOULD GIVE RIGHTS HEARINGS
AND APPEALS. THIS BILL WON'T
CREATE CHAOS IT WON'T WREAK
HAVOC BUT IT WILL MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE TO THE LIVES OF
CLASSIFIED WORKERS BY ENSURING
THAT THEY NO LONGER HAVE TO
WORRY FROM ONE MOMENT TO THE
NEXT. WHETHER AND WHEN A LAYOFF
NOTICE MIKE POMPEO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE DOORS AROUND FOR
THIS IF YOU'RE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LEVINE OR
PERHAPS YOU'RE HERE PRESENT. MY
NOTES WEREN'T SO GREAT. THE
USUALLY ARE. THANK YOU LISA
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS STILL.
TARANTULA I REPRESENTS YET.
WITH THE SPONSORS OF AB FOUR
THREE EIGHT. AB FOUR THREE
EIGHT IS ABOUT EQUITY. IS ABOUT
FAIRNESS AND IT'S ABOUT DOING
THE RIGHT THING. IT'S ABOUT
PROVIDING ALL SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
WITH THE SAME WAY OFF NOTICING
HEARING RIGHT INSTEAD OF
PROVIDING ONE SET OF RULES FOR
THE HIGHEST WAGE EARNERS. AND
ANOTHER FOR THE LOWEST WAGE
EARNERS. FOR TOO LONG DISTRICTS
TO BALANCE THE BUDGET ON THE
BACKS OF CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
THE LAW IS STRUCTURED IN A WAY
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO DO THIS.
BUT IT IS TIME TO CHANGE THIS
OUTDATED. AND UNJUST LAW.
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THEY PROVIDE DIRECT
SERVICES TO OUR OUR SPECIAL
NEEDS STUDENTS THEY NEVER
STOPPED WORKING THEY PREPARED
AND DELIVERED MEALS AND
HOMEWORK TO STUDENTS WHO ATTEND
THROUGH DISTANCE LEARNING. THE
CLEAN AND DISINFECT OUR
CLASSROOMS AND SADLY. SOME OF
MY MEMBERS PAID THE ULTIMATE
PRICE. YET TWO THOUSAND
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES WERE LAID
OFF. EVEN THOUGH THE
LEGISLATURE DID NOT CUT
DISTRICT BUDGETS. TWO THOUSAND
WERE LAID OFF EVEN THOUGH THE
LEGISLATURE HAD INTENT LANGUAGE
IN THE BUDGET LANGUAGE THAT
ESSENTIALLY SAID LAYOFF. COULD
NOT OCCUR FOR CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES. TWO THOUSAND WERE
LAID OFF. WHEN NOBODY ELSE
COULD BE LAID OFF THIS IS
WRONG. THE OPPOSITION WILL
ARGUE THAT OUR MEMBERS SHOULD
NOT GET THE SAME PROTECTIONS IS
THERE MEMBERS. THAT OUR
SENIORITY RULES AND
PROBATIONARY PERIODS NEED TO
CHANGE BUT THEY FAILED TO TELL
YOU THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY
STATUTORY SENIORITY RIGHTS. WE
BARGAIN SENIORITY LOCALLY WITH
DISTRICTS WHO AGREE WITH THEM.
THEY FAILED TO TELL YOU THAT
THIS BILL HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH PROBATIONARY EMPLOYEES IN
FACT WE AMENDED THE BILL TO
MAKE THAT CLEAR AT THE REQUEST.
THEY WILL TELL YOU THAT THE
LAYOFFS ARE WORSE FOR HIGHER
PAID EMPLOYEES THAN THEY ARE
FOR LOWER PAID EMPLOYEES BUT I
AM HERE TO TELL YOU THE PAIN OF
A LAYOFF IS JUST AS.
SIGNIFICANT FOR LOWER WAGE
EMPLOYEES. THERE SOME THE SAME.
MY MEMBERS ARE NOT ASKING FOR
SPECIAL TREATMENT THEY'RE
ASKING FOR THE SAME TREATMENT
IT'S THAT SIMPLE I ASKED MY
BOAT. OKAY THINK HER TESTIMONY
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
ROOM WHO WISHES TECH SUPPORT
POSITION. ON THIS BILL. C.
KNOWN ELSE COME FORWARD WILL
CHECK YOUR FULL ROOM. THERE'S
NO ONE THERE TO TESTIFY.
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
QUEUE UP A POSSIBLE. HELLO
SUPPORT WITNESSES ON A BEFORE
THIRTY A PLACE. FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. YOU GO TO
LINE NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSION OF SPIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
SPORT. FIND. NINETY TWO. STOP
MAYOR WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THE KNOWN BY AS THE
FINAL CALL ANYONE AND WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN. ZERO MISTER CHAIR NO
ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. ARE THANK YOU
MODERATOR- LET'S MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION SIDE NOW LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES TIM
TAYLOR. HI MISTER TAYLOR YOU-MAY PROCEED- I KNOW WE HAVE
CHRIS REEF WHO'S GOING TO
FOLLOW YOU BUT YOU MAY PROCEED
NOW. ATTEMPT. TO PARDEE MATURE
THIS IS CHRIS FREE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION I BELIEVE TIM IS.
UNABLE TO MAKE IT DUE TO A
FAMILY EMERGENCY SO I'LL BE
DOING ONE SPEAKING. AT THE
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
OKAY THAT'S FINE THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING THAT YOU MAY PROCEED
NORTH. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
MEGHAN TO THE QUEEN NUMBER THE
WALLED CITY UP TO TESTIFY
BEFORE YOU TODAY. I'M CRITICAL
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL BUT
STRONG OPPOSITION TO IT BEFORE
THIRTY EIGHT. I WANT TO FIRST
THANK YOU AUTHOR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US IN THE BILL.
UNFORTUNATELY WE REMAIN
OPPOSED- BECAUSE IT STRIKES AT
THE HEART PUBLICLY INFORMED.
DECISION MAKING AND RESTRICT
THE ABILITY OF LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARDS TO MAKE. NECESSARY
BUDGET BUDGETARY DECISION. IN
DOING THE BILL ELIMINATES BIG
SIX DELAY NOTICE REQUIREMENT
FOR CLASSIFIED STAFF AND
REPLACES THAT BY ALIGNING
NOTICING REQUIREMENTS WITH THE
MARKET YOU KNOW IT'S DEADLINE.
FOR TEACHERS. WOULD ALSO HAND
CUFF FUTURE LEGISLATURES BY
MANDATING THAT ANY FUTURE
NOTICING RIGHT PROVIDED TO
TEACHERS WOULD AUTOMATICALLY
EXTEND THE CLASSIFIED THAT
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE
RIGHT. OR APPROPRIATE OR
BENEFICIAL TO CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEE. RECOGNIZING THAT
STAFF SALARIES AND BENEFITS
MAKE UP THE VAST MAJORITY OF
SCHOOL DISTRICT BUDGET.
AMOUNTING TO AS MUCH AS NINETY
PERCENT. IF ADOPTED EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO ACT UPON
YOUR THE AND THE ENTIRETY OF
ITS BUDGET A FULL THREE MONTHS
BEFORE THE STATE BUDGET IS
ADOPTED. AND NEARLY SIX MONTHS
PRIOR TO DISTRICT MAKING
INFORMED BUDGETARY PROVISION
BASED UPON IT UP AT THE BUDGET.
YOU KNOW SCHOOL DISTRICT
OPERATE AT THE MERCY OF THE
STATE BUDGET AND MARCH
FIFTEENTH DEADLINE CAN COME THE
TIME. WHEN WE ONLY KNOW WHAT
THE PROPOSED BUDGET LOOKS LIKE.
CHOIRS DISTRICT TO PREDICT WHAT
THEIR BUDGET WILL BE BASED UPON.
USING THE PROPOSED JANUARY
BUDGET WHICH DURING DOWN BUT
YEARS CAN BE DRACONIAN AND BOTH
FUNDING CUTS. AS SUCH THE FOR
MARCH FIFTEENTH REQUIREMENT
FORCES DISTRICTS TO ACT UPON
THE REALITY OF THE JANUARY
BUDGET AS OPPOSED TO WHAT THE
BUDGET WILL BE A JOB ALIVE
PERSON. OKAY THIS IS NOT
REGULATION THIS IS WHAT
DISTRICTS HAVE REGULARLY
EXPERIENCED DURING BUT DOWN
BUDGET YEARS IN THE PAST DURING
BOTH THE DOT COM RECESSION AND
THE GREAT RECESSION RECESSION
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WERE FORCED
OVER NOTICE TEACHERS DO THE
MARCH FIFTEENTH REQUIREMENTS.
IF ADOPTED BUT WE FEAR AND WE
KNOW THAT THIS BILL WILL RESULT
IN THE OVERNIGHT THING OF CLOCK
RIGHT BACK. IT ALSO BE NOTED
THAT ELIMINATING THAT DAY
LAYOFF NOTICE IN REQUIREMENT
REMOVES THE ABILITY OF
DISTRICTS TO AVOID OVER
NOTHING. CURRENTLY THE SIXTY
DAY NOTICE IS ONE THAT ALLOWS
MANEUVERABILITY AND THE ABILITY
TO MAKE PERSONAL DECISIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME WHEN WE
KNOW WHAT THE BUDGET IS AND IS
NOT ADEQUATE TO SPECULATION AT
THE HARD DEADLINE OF MARCH
FIFTEENTH. GIVE ME
CIRCUMSTANCES WE BELIEVE NOW IS
NOT THE TIME TO MAKE CHANGES OF
THIS SCALE TO THE EMPLOYMENT
PROCESS THAT OUR FOCUS SHOULD
REMAIN ON HOW WE CAN CONTINUE.
TO BEST SERVE OUR STUDENTS AND
STAFF. IN A CONSTANTLY SHIFTING
ENVIRONMENT. YOUR TIME. BUT
EVEN THREE STRONGLY URGE OUR
NOBLE. THANK YOU. ARE THE
GREATEST MONY IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN COMMITTEE ROOM WAS
TAKEN OPPOSE POSITION ON THIS
BILL. SEEING NONE- WE'RE GOING
TO CHECK. THE OVERFLOW ROOM.
SCENE AND THERE. WAS A
MODERATOR TO QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES THOUGHT TO
THIS BILL. AB FOUR THIRTY A
PLACE. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME I'M GONNA GO TO LINE
NINETY NINE. THANK YOU LEILANI
ARGONAUTICA O BEHALF OF THE C.
T. E. JPA COALITION AND THE
SCHOOLS ACCEPT LIABILITY FUND
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. BLIND
ONE HUNDRED AND. FOUR GETTING
THAT AT THE MOMENT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. FIND ONE
HUNDRED AND. ELEVEN GOOD
EVENING THIS IS DEREK CLINIC ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNTY- SUPERINTENDENT
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY EIGHT THANK.
FINE ONE HUNDRED AND. THIRTEEN
GOOD EVENING THIS IS LAURA
PRESTON WITH THE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION PINE CREEK SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JEFF FLOCK OF REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS AND THE TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT
THEM RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION. FINE. SEVENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS GOOD EVENING THIS
ANGELA READ ON BEHALF OF THE
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS- SO
CREATION THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CAREER AND
COLLEGE READINESS ORGANIZATION
WITH SCHOOL EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
WHILE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN OPPOSITION. THE DOW THANK
YOU. FINE THREE EIGHT. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANDREA
BALL ON BEHALF OF THREE
ORGANIZATIONS IN OPPOSITION THE
ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY EDUCATION COALITION.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND VERY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL HOLD SIZER ON BEHALF OF
THE KERN COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS AND THE FORTY SIX
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN KERN COUNTY
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE A FINAL CALL FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE. PRESS.
ONE ZERO. THE FUTURE THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE IS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
MODERATOR- DEPRECIATE THE
APPRECIATE EVERYON'S
PARTICIPATION THAT WAS SO. A
ROBUST THE NUMBER OF FOLKS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE ISSUE- WE'RE
GONNA COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND ASK IF THERE'S-
THERE COMMONSENSE.
PARTICIPATION FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THEMSELVES
CENTER NEWMAN HAD THANK YOU
MISTER ASSEMBLY MEMBER RASH- BY
DIE DO APPRECIATE THIS BILL I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FOR
ITSELF- GLAD TO BE A CO AUTHOR
I THINK THE WITNESS PUT IT. AS
WELL AS YOU CAN THIS IS A
MATTER OF EQUITY CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES ARE JUST AS IMPORTANT
IF NOT SOMETIMES MORE-
IMPORTANT TO THE FUNCTIONING IN
THE BENDING YOU KNOW EXACTLY
PERFORMANCE OF ALL OF OUR
SCHOOLS THEY SHOULD NOT BEAR
THE BRUNT OF BUDGETARY
DECISIONS IN THE SAME WAY THAT.
CERTIFIED EMPLOYEE SHOULD NOT-
THIS IS A FAIR AND REASONABLE
MEASURE I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT HIM
HAPPY. TO MOVE THE BILL IN THE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS. THANK YOU
SIR NEWMAN. I THINK. MEMBERS
SURE DID YOU WANT TO FOR A
CENTER WHERE I HAD A FALL SHE
ALREADY DEFERRED TO YOU SOONER
OKAY. AND SHE'S. I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR AND
IT'S I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THE
EQUITY ISSUE HERE I SERVED
EIGHT YEARS ON A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOR. AND THE ONE I WAS
IN THE LEGISLATURE THE FIRST
TIME AROUND. WE WERE RUNNING
DEFICITS WHO WERE HAVING A
ROUGH TIME FUNDING THE SCHOOLS.
AND SO BECAUSE THIS REQUIREMENT
EXISTED FOR CERTIFICATED
PERSONALS. OF THE DEFAULT FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WAS TO SEND
OUT LAYOFF NOTICES TO JUST
HUNDREDS HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE AND
THEN IF THEY GOT THE BUDGET
ALLOCATION IN THE SPRING TO
RESEND THEM I GOT TO BE THIS.
RIO DYSFUNCTIONAL SITUATION
WHERE. IT JUST ACROSS THE STATE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WERE
GETTING LAYOFF NOTICES AND THEN
THEY WERE RESCINDED ARM MAYBE
THE SNARKY WAY TO ASK THE
QUESTION IS IN THE INTEREST OF
EQUITY ARE WE EXTENDING A
DYSFUNCTIONAL SYSTEM TO
EVERYONE. A. M. THE THING ABOUT
IT IS I'M FOR THE EQUITY IN THE
SITUATION I GET THAT COMPLETELY
BUT YOU WEREN'T GOOD TIMES WE
JUST HAD THE BEST EDUCATION
BUDGET THAT WE'VE HAD. MODERN
TIMES THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S ON THE HORIZON BUT IF WE
WERE TO HAVE AN EQUAL CHECKING
OF THE EDUCATION BUDGET WHAT'S
TO KEEP THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
FROM DOING THE SAME THING OF
JUST. ISSUING 15% OF THEIR
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES LAYOFF
NOTICES AND THEN RESCINDED.
MOST OF THEM WHEN THEY GET TO
JULY. I REMEMBER THE TIMES WHEN
OURS ARE CERTIFICATED OUR
TEACHERS RECEIVE THOSE PINK
SLIPS AS WE CALL THEM YEAH AND
YOU'RE RIGHT- IT'S VERY
UNNERVING. BUT AS- THE SAME AS
DURING THAT TIME THE SAME THING
WOULD HAPPEN KNOWN AS I TOLD
THE STAKEHOLDERS MY MOTHER
CALLS IT A HOSTESS WHENEVER
THERE'S A CHANGE THERE WILL BE
CHANGE IN THE LAW. THERE HAVE
TO BE ADJUSTMENTS SO INITIALLY
MAKE THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
GOING TO OVER. NOT NOTIFY THE
CLASSIFIED BUT THE ADJUSTMENTS
WILL BE MADE AND THEY WILL MAKE
MORE INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT
WHO THEY SENT THE NOTICES TO
JUST AS THEY DO WITH THE
CERTIFICATED IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE EVERYBODY THE GET SET. AND
EVEN IF IN THE END IT THERE THE
YEAH THEY THEY DON'T SEND THE
NOTICES OUT. IF THE LEGISLATURE
DOES NOT PROVIDE AT LEAST A 2%
COLA INCREASE THE DISTRICTS CAN
THEN SEND OUT A NOTICE IF THEY
DIDN'T DO BEFORE MARCH
FIFTEENTH. THERE ARE WAYS TO
DEAL WITH THIS BUT IN THE END.
WE SHOULD NOT BE BALANCING THE
BUDGET ON THE BACKS OF THE
CLASSIFIED. EVERYBODY SHOULD BE
TREATED EQUALLY BECAUSE
EVERYBODY IS IMPORTANT TO THE
TEACHING. AND TO BE EDUCATING
OUR STUDENTS. N. I. GET THAT.
A. N. IT'S WHY I THINK N THE
END I'M GOING TO VOTE FOR THIS
BILL. A BECAUSE OF THAT EQUITY
IN IT AND IT WAS CLEAR IN MY
OWN SITUATION THE CLASSIFIED.
EMPLOYEES BORE THE BRUNT OF
SOME OF THE HARDEST WORK
WHETHER IT WAS. YOU KNOW JUST
IN THE PAPER WORK WITH REGARD
TO ENROLLMENT FOR GRADES OR- R.
OR THE MORE TRADITIONAL THINGS
OF DRIVING BUSES OR OR DOING
OTHER STUFF. THE END IS THERE
THE FLEXIBILITY ALSO THE ONE
DIFFERENCE LAWS. IS WITH THE
CERTIFICATED PERSONNEL THAT
AFFECTS SCHOOL YEAR. AND IT WAS
ALWAYS CLEAR. THAT YOU ARE NOT
MONEY TO FUND THE TEACHERS FOR
THE WHOLE YEAR OR NOT. BUT THEN
ON THE CERTIFICATED SIDE SOME
THINGS WERE EXACTLY THE SAME
WAY IF YOU WERE IN SESSION GOOD
SCHOOL BUSES FOR THE SECTION IF
YOU WERE IN SESSION YOU NEEDED
GREAT SUPPORT. BUT THERE WERE
OTHER GRANT PROGRAMS THAT MIGHT
GO PARTWAY THROUGH THE YEAR.
THIS IS ALLOW FOR THE
FLEXIBILITY OF SOMEBODY IS
GRANT FUNDED OR SOMETHING THAT.
IT GOES WITH THE LIFE OF THE
GRANT. I'M LOOKING FOR THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE I THINK
THAT IF THERE STILL ISN'T AN
ISSUE IT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS. OUR
THAT WASN'T SOMETHING THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
BUT CERTAINLY WE CAN LOOK AT
THAT. WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT PUTTING AN EXTRA
BURDEN ON THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THEY'RE HAVING TO DEAL WITH SO
MANY OTHER THINGS IN YOUR
RIGHT. THIS IS BEEN A REALLY
GOOD YEAR FOR ALL OF OUR
SCHOOLS IT'S NOT ALWAYS GOING
TO BE THIS WAY. IS THAT. WHEN
YOU'RE GOING TO GIVE OFF A
LAYOFF NOTICE GIVE A LAYOFF
NOTICE. SHOULD EVERYBODY
RECEIVE IT EQUALLY OR SHOULD IT
ONLY BE THE CERTIFICATED. AND
CLASSIFIED TO BE LEFT TO WONDER
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE OING TO
BE LAID OFF WITHOUT HAVING THE
DECENCY OF LETTING THEM KNOW
THAT THEY MAY ALSO BE LAID OFF
DOESN'T MEAN THEY'RE GOING TO
BE LAID OFF BUT THEY MAY ALSO
BE LAID OFF. IT'S JUST A NOTICE
AND IF THEY DON'T RECEIVE THE
NOTICE THEY KNOW THEIR JOB IS
SECURE. BUT THEY'RE STILL THE
IF THESE ONE OF THE COMMENTS
THAT WAS MADE BY THE
STAKEHOLDERS IS THAT WHAT IF
THE BUDGET DOESN'T PROVIDE ALL
THE MONEY WELL IF IT DOESN'T
INCLUDE THAT 2% COLA. THE
DISTRICT CAN STILL GIVE NOTICE
AFTER MARCH FIFTEENTH. OKAY
THANK YOU ARE PER SHIRT- RISA
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE WORKING
IF. IF UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
OF MERGERS THIS BILL MOVES ON.
THE ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR. WILL BUTCHER.
PALLETIZED THE QUESTION- THAT
HAS IMPOSED AND SAYS STATES
HERE- ONE ISSUE THAT I'VE HEARD
FROM MY SCHOOL DISTRICT IS THAT
THE TIMING OF PROVIDING ALL
PRELIMINARY LAYOFF NOTICES TO
EMPLOYEES ON MARCH FIFTEENTH
TEACHERS AND CLASSIFIED STAFF.
AND THIS WOULD CREATE.
ADMINISTRATIVE DIFFICULTIES
HAVE YOU CONSIDERED MOVING THE
TIMELINE FOR CLASSIFIED NOTICES
BACKED BY A FEW MONTHS- TO
BETTER ALIGN THE LAYOFF NOTICE
PROCESS WITH THE STATE BUDGET
PROCESS. IN THE PM AND THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT THE STAKEHOLDERS
DID ADDRESS WITH US. WORK BEGAN
TALKING ABOUT EQUITY FOR GOING
TO GET THE NOTICE THEY ALREADY
HAVE AN IDEA WHAT THEIR BUDGET
IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE. AND IF
THERE IS SOMETHING THAT IS
COMPLETELY UNEXPECTED THEN THEY
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE THEY THEY
ARE ABLE TO LOOK AT WHAT THE
COLA INCREASE WAS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY CAN USE A
LATER DATE. THE DISTRICTS
FRANKLY DID NOT LIKE GIVING THE
MARCH FIFTEENTH NOTICE TO THIS
TO THE CERTIFICATED EITHER. FOR
THE SAME REASON BECAUSE OF THE
BUDGET. THEY HAVE AN IDEA WHAT
THE BUDGET IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE WE'RE SAYING THAT THOSE
EMPLOYEES JOBS WILL BE
PROTECTED. THROUGH THE SCHOOL
YEAR. PARENTS WERE SAYING SAME
THINGS ARE SAYING ABOUT THE
CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES. IF WE
CHANGE THE DATE THEY'RE SAYING
AS I UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION.
BUT KEEP THE MARCH FIFTEENTH
FOR THE CERTIFICATED FOR THE
ADMINISTRATORS AND TEACHERS.
BUT FOR THE CLASSIFIED LET'S
PICK A DATE IN JUNE OR JULY.
THAT IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WE'RE TRYING TO FIND A ONE DATE
SO THAT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT IS
ABLE TO LOOK AT THEIR ENTIRE
BUDGET. AND DETERMINE WHAT IS
THE PERCENTAGE OF THE LAYOFFS
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO DO AND
THEN SEND OUT THE PROPER
NOTICES. IT IS THINKING. AS A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER RIGHT NOW.
AND I THINK IT SHOULD BE NOTED
THAT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
OPPOSITION IT'S THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE OPPOSING
IT'S NOT THE EMPLOYEES IT'S NOT
THE CERTIFICATED TO THE CSEA
MEMBERS IT'S NOT CTA. IT IS THE
ADMINISTRATORS AND  RECOGNIZE
THAT IT'S A DISTRICTS THEY HAVE
TO MAKE AGAIN LOS A HOSTESS THE
ADJUSTMENTS. ONCE THEY
RECOGNIZE WHAT THE LAWYERS THEY
WILL MAKE THE ADJUSTMENTS AND I
KNOW THEY WILL MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISIONS AND SEND THE PROPER
NOTICES TO THE PROPER NUMBER OF
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES JUST AS
THEY DO TO THE CERTIFICATED
EMPLOYEES. OKAY THANK YOU- LET
ME JUST. SAY FIRST ONE. FULL
DISCLOSURE I'M ALSO A CO AUTHOR
ON THE BILL PUT IT APPRECIATE
THINK THIS IS LONG OVERDUE AND
I THINK IF THERE WAS A TIME TO
DO IT THIS WOULD BE THE TIME
NOT TO SAY THAT IT RESOLVES ALL
THE ISSUES AND I THINK YOU CALL
THAT OUT OF THINGS- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THING SIMILAR DISCUSS
CALL THAT OUT HE DID. IT BRING
SIMPLY BRINGS PARITY. BUT WE
GOT THE SYSTEM THAT. TWENTY
NINE FIVE ICE SPOKE TO.
SPONSORS OF THE BILL IN IN IN
OTHERS. TO TRY TO GET TO THE
PROBABLY IN WHAT IT WE JUST
HANDLE THE REST OF THIS IF WE
CAN YOU KNOW AND TRY TO GET
THINGS LINED UP SO YOU DON'T
HAVE A MAY REVISE COMING OUT
THAT EVERYBODY'S ON PINS AND
NEEDLES ABOUT TWO MONTHS AFTER
THE LEAD OFF TO THE RACES ARE
DUE AND THEN. ENOUGH TO SCARE
THE HELL OUT OF PEOPLE YOU GOT
TO TURN AROUND IN MANY CASES
AND CERTAINLY SOME OF THOSE
LAYOFFS DECK PUT IN ON OFFENSE
SO MANY DISTRICTS AND SO MANY
YEARS CERTAINLY IN THE YEARS I
WAS ON THE SCHOOL BOARD. AND
MINISTERS CAME BACK AND SAID
YOU KNOW THEY DON'T SAY IT THIS
WAY BUT HISTORY JUST KIDDING WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE TO DO THAT
NOW WILL BY THAT TIME YOU'VE
LOST EMPLOYEES- YOU'VE PEOPLE
BEEN SCARED FOR ESPECIALLY IN
TOUGH TIMES TOUGHER TIMES THAT
WE'RE IN NOW. SO I THINK
THERE'S MORE WORK THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE IN THIS AREA I DON'T
THINK EVERYONE WAS IN A
POSITION TO DO THAT RIGHT NOW I
THINK THIS BILL IT'S ENOUGH
DEFINITELY DOES SOMETHING
IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF A HUGE
STEP FORWARD SAYING WILL BEFORE
WE ADDRESS ANY OTHER ISSUES
HERE LET'S GET TO PARITY FIRST
AND THEN LET'S TALK ABOUT YOU
KNOW HOW WE DEAL WITH THE REST
OF THE FALL OUT. OF THAT WE'VE
BEEN DEALING WITH FOR SO MANY
YEARS IN TERMS OF HARDSHIP ON
EMPLOYEES IN ADMINISTRATORS AND
SCHOOL BOARDS. AND SCHOOL
BOARDS HATE TO MAKE THAT
DECISION- NO THAT THERE'S A
GOOD CHANCE THAT THEY MAY NOT
YOU KNOW THEY MAY NOT HAVE TO
KEEP TOSE PINK SLIPS OUT
THERE- HE IS REALLY A TRIPLE NO
WIN AT THIS POINT BUT BUT IT
LEASES BRINGS PARITY AND I
DON'T MEAN TO MINIMIZE YOUR
BILL I THINK THE BILL'S GREAT
BUT I THINK THIS IS THE NEXT
STEP TOWARD TRYING TO GET TO A
GREATER SOLUTION AT SOME POINT
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING OF
FOREIGN- IN. WE HAVE NO OTHER
REQUEST TO BE RECOGNISED HERE
ON THE DATA SO- I DON'T BELIEVE
CENTER DRAWS OR YOU. READY TO
GO OR WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE
REALLY RECOGNIZED- I THINK
SENATOR ROSE IS TRYING TO MOVE
THE BILL. SHE'S SHE'S MOVING
THE MOVING THE BILL BUT ON YOUR
WALKING CLOSER. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIVALS. FLORIDIAN
WE HAVE A MOTION BY DORADO
INFORMATIK SOLICITOR CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY HI BUT AS THE I OR
CHOI BOGUE. NO BUT TROUBLED NOW
WRESTLE. WRESTLE I LAYERED
THERE ARE AYE NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN AYE. THE FOCUS FOR THE
ONE BILLS OUT THANK YOU BECAUSE
SOME OF. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS.
WELCOME. THE LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE. HELLO GOT YOU ALL
SET UP YOU CAN COMMENCE TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL AB SEVENTY
THREE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
MISTER CHAIR APPRECIATE YOU
HAVING ME HERE THIS AFTERNOON
AND- AND SENATORS IT'S GREAT TO
SEE EVERYBODY. AND YOU KNOW AS
AS AS WE ALL KNOW WE ARE ALL
OUT WELL WHERE IS. HAS
CALIFORNIANS THAT WE LIVE IN A
HIGHLY VULNERABLE NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT YOU KNOW EXPERIENCE
FREQUENT FLOODING DROUGHTS.
ALWAYS ON ALERT FOR THE NEXT
BIG EARTHQUAKE OR AT LEAST WE
ARE ON THE CENTRAL COAST IN THE
MONTEREY BAY- BUT WE YOU KNOW
OF. OF COURSE HERE ON.
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES ARE ALWAYS
AT HIGH RISK. SO THIS
LEGISLATION ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY THREE SIX TO BUILD ON
CAL OSHA STANDARD FOR
PROTECTING FARMING AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS FROM WILDFIRE SMOKE AN
UNHEALTHY QUALITY AIR
CONDITIONS- LAST YEAR THE
COMBINATION OF A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC THE- PRESIDENT NUMBER
OF WILDFIRES WE EXPERIENCE TO
PUT ENORMOUS STRAIN ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF PP AND MADE IT
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE. FOR
AGRICULTURAL PLAYERS TO PROCURE
SUFFICIENT QUANTITIES OF THE
RECOMMENDED AND NINETY FIVE
MASKS FOR THEIR WORKERS SO THIS
pFIRST IT WOULD ENSURE THE
STATE'S STOCKPILE AND NINETY
FIVE MASKS. WILL BE UTILIZED
AND MADE AVAILABLE FOR FARMING
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE. YOU SECOND IT PROVIDES
CAL OSHA WITH THE DISCRETION TO
DECIDE TO DEPLOY WILDFIRE
STRIKE TEAMS TO AGRICULTURAL
REGIONS IN WORKPLACES DURING
MAJOR ON HOW THE AIR QUALITY
EVENTS. AND THEN FINALLY THIRD
IT WOULD REQUIRE A CULTURE TO
PROVIDE CULTURALLY COMPETENT
WILDFIRE SMOKE SAFETY
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS AND
TRAINING FOR ALL FARMING
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS.
CALIFORNIA'S RECENT WILDFIRES
HAVE BEEN THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE
ON RECORD- AND THE SMOKE FROM
THESE FIRES IS EXTREMELY
HAZARDOUS. A RECENT STUDY FOUND
THAT TINY PARTICLES RELEASED IN
WILDFIRE SMOKEARE FACT UP TO
TEN TIMES TEN TIMES MORE
HARMFUL TO HUMANS THAN
PARTICLES RELEASE FROM OTHER
SOURCES SUCH AS EXHAUST FROM
CARS AND FACTORIES OR FROM
POWER PLANTS. AS THE NUMBER OF
UNHEALTHY AIR QUALITY DAYS
CONTINUE TO INCREASE ANNUALLY
HERE IN OUR FIRST IN THE NATION
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCING STATE WE
CAN'T STAND FOR A PHARMACOLOGIC
WORKERS TO RISK THEIR HEALTH
AND WELL BEING EVERY SINGLE
TIME THEY GOING TO THE FIELD TO
HARVEST. THE FOOD THAT WILL BE
AND ARE DEPENDENT ON. THIS BILL
WILL HELP TECH LIVES AND WILL
ENSURE A MORE RESILIENT FOOD
SYSTEM WHEN WILDFIRES INABILITY
IT INEVITABLY STRIKE AGAIN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER CHAIRMAN WILL TURN
OVER TO MARKLE AT LEAST I GOT
WHO IS ACTUALLY IN A ROOM-
HERE. TO PROVIDE SOME TESTIMONY
ALSO I BELIEVE WE'LL HAVE
VIRTUAL TESTIMONY FROM HAVE NOT
HERNANDEZ WHO'S EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA
FARMWORKERS FIND ISSUE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU OF
MISSILES RUGBY MAY PROCEED.
SERVER COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
COURSE MY- ARE THAT NAME THE
EXACT DIRECTOR OF THE COMPANY
YOU'LL COME EACH OTHER TWENTY
FOUR FOR FONG. THROUGH THE HOST
JOHN. LIVE IN THE STATE FOR WE
HAVEN'T. EIGHT HOW THOUSAND
FARMER ND WHERE MAYBE MORE
THAN. OF THEM ARE UNDOCUMENTED.
IT IS A POPULATION THAT DURING
THE CALL BUT FUNDING MAKE WAS
HEAVILY EXPOSED TO THE VIRUS
WHILE MAINTAINING OUR FOOD
SUPPLY. THEY WERE NOT JUST
ESSENTIAL LABOR FORCE THEY
BECAME A SACRIFICIAL LABOR
FORCE. TODAY WE LIVE IN THE
HISTORICAL PERIOD WHERE WE ARE
EXPERIENCING AN EXPONENTIAL
INCREASE IN WILDFIRE FREQUENCY.
WITH AN INTENSITY COSTS AND
DAMAGES ON THE MAGNITUDE NOT
SEEN BEFORE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT IS BEING
REPORTED FOR EXAMPLE THAT
IMMATURE COMEDY. AB ONE CENTURY
FIRE AVERAGE WITH SEVEN POINT
THREE FIVE PER YEAR. BUT IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THEY HAD
SIXTY NINE FIRES IN THAT ONE
YEAR ALONE. THE FARMWORKERS
FACED A SITUATION TODAY WHERE
THE WILDFIRE SMOKE INHALATION
IS INEVITABLE WHEN THEY HAVE TO
CONTINUE WORKING BEING EXPOSED
TO HEAVY SMOKE WITHOUT ADEQUATE
PROTECTION. THIS IS BRING IN A
GREATER NUMBER OF HEALTH RISKS
FOR FARMWORKERS THE CHEMICALS
POLLEN SMOKE. GET DEPOSITED IN
SOIL AND WATER ALSO. COLLATION
OF SMOKE MAY BRING ABOUT
PULMONARY DISEASES
CARDIOVASCULAR ILLNESSES AND
EXACERBATIONS OF ASTHMA. BUT
INSTALLATION RISKS INCLUDE THE
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS THAT MIGHT
BE CONTAINED IN THE EMISSION OF
ASH AND SOIL PARTICLES. DUST
DURING AGRICULTURAL ACTIVITIES.
AB SEVENTY THREE OFFERS A
SOLUTION TO THE CONDITIONS
SUFFERED BY FARMWORKERS DURING
WILDFIRES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
TO PLEASE SUPPORT AB SEVENTY
THREE SUBMITTED. BY ASSEMBLYMAN
ROBERT REVISED. PERRANCE
AFFORDABLE AN APPLE. THANK YOU
VERY FIGURES HAS MORE. THE SOME
REAL ISSUE CITY SIR LEAD
WITNESS YOU. GIVE ME THAT NAME
AGAIN- BELIEVE IT'S I HAVE NOT
HERNANDEZ- THE SECOND DIRECTOR
FOR CALIFORNIA PHARMACOPHORE
DISH OKAY MISTER NANDO'S SO IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE YOU MAY
PROCEED. YEAH I AM I AM BEING
TOLD IT'S- THE LOCAL MILLER WE
HAD MY SIMILAR I'VE MICHAEL
MILLER ARE YOU AVAILABLE TO BE
AS A LEAD WITNESS. IT YES THIS
IS MICHAEL DOLLAR OF THE
COMPANY'S OFFICIAL I GRIPPED
HOURS- ONE BIG PICTURE OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THE OPPORTUNITY
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE WHILE
WE WERE OUT OF SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY WITHIN THE SENATE OF
THE BILL BE AMENDED TO ADDRESS
OUR- MOSTLY OPTION YOUR
CONCERNS. OF THE MEMBERS THE
CARD LAST WEEK WE ARE A FULL
SUPPORT OF THE BILL OF THE
ISSUES VERY IMPORTANT BRIDGES
SO LAID OUT- BY WE HAVE YOU
KNOW OUR COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC OR WE HAVE- OF
DECORATIONS THAT ARE HELPING TO
ADDRESS THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
VACCINATION FOR WILDFIRES IN
THE WILD CARDS ARE HERE FOR A
WHILE WE DON'T COULD BE A
SERIOUS PROBLEM. AND OUR
EMPLOYERS ARE WORKING.
AGGRESSIVELY DOES TO MAKE WE
HAVE THE SUPPLY OF- AND NINETY
NOW. AVAILABLE CORN OR- AND THE
IS IMPORTANT TO US FOR THE THAT
THE HAPPY. AND LAST YEAR WE
FOUND HAS. THE BUDGET BY
GROWERS. WERE GIVING TO-
HOSPITAL FOR HEALTH CARE IN THE
WORLD AND THE NEXT. OF THE PLAN
AND THEN IF I MAY ASK WERE IN
UNIONS IN NOT. IN SMALL SUPPLY
HOME IN THE STATE HAD TO STEP
IN AND MAKE THOSE AVAILABLE
TUESDAY STOCKPILE. THIS BILL
HELPS MAKE SURE THAT SHOULD
THERE BE AN ADDITIONAL. A
SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE- A
DEPRESSION IN THE BILL ABILITY
OF MASSIVE THOSE ARE AVAILABLE
I CAN'T RESPECT. TO THE STATE
STOCKPILE. AND WILL HELP
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM AGAIN WOULD
TAKE THE OPERA FOR. WORKING
WITH US IN LAST WEEK'S NUMBERS
TO RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS MAKE
SURE IT'S CONSISTENT. WITH THE
L. REGULATIONS ARE OVER CAL
OSHA. THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
HEALTH CENTER'S BOARD. AND WE
ARE CLOSED ON THE BALLOT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND ALSOREAL
QUICKLY I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE SECRETARY FOR WORKING
WITH EVERYBODY OVER THE WEEKEND
AND THROUGH THE HOLIDAYS MAKE
SURE WE'RE ALL. I'M ABLE TO GET
ALSO BE THE FOURTH OF JULY.
BETWEEN SECRETARIES WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ALL HAVE THE INFORMATION WE
NEED. IT I JUST WANT TO
PERSONALLY THANK OUR- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- IN. DEFINITELY-
COULD TO COMMITTEES. HERE-
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO. WILL
OPPOSITE. I'M SORRY WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO BACK TE COMMITTEE
ROOM HERE AND ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WAS TAKEN UP A SUPPORT POSITION
ON THIS BILL- WHO HASN'T
ALREADY SPOKEN WE SEE KNOWN
COMING FORWARD. THE OLD FOR
ROOM HAS NO. WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR ASKED MODERATOR TO
QUEUE UP ANY UP ANY. SUPPORT
WITNESSES FOR AB SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND WE HAVE. NINE EIGHTY
THREE. GOOD EVENING MISTER
KAREN MEMBERS FROM THE COAL
MORTAL MEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT OF AB. SEVENTY THREE.
PINE. NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH- CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SPORTS. AND
A FINAL CALL FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THE FUTURE THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THEY WISH
TO SOME SPEAKING SUPPORT BROUGH
THANK YOU MODERATOR WE DO NOT
HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSING THE USTR'S ANYONE IN
THE ROOM. WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION SEEN NONE WILL GO
TO THE- OVERFLOW ROOM THERE'S
NO ONE THERE TO TESTIFY AND
RIGHT BACK TO YOU MISTER
MODERATOR. ACERCA ANYONE. WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ON THE TELECONFERENCE ON. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
PROCEDURE KNOWN AS SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR CHECKING
WILL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AND WILL GO TO SENATE EARLIER
COMMENTS YES I JUST. WANT TO
MAKE A COMMENT BECAUSE I'M
COMING OFF OF FIVE EIGHT YEARS
OF HAVING CAL FIRE IN MY
PORTFOLIO IN ONE OF THE
INTERESTING EDUCATIONAL THINGS
TO ME WAS- PURCHASED CERTAIN
IMPACTS FROM SMOKE. IN THEIR
WORK AND I MEAN THINGS LIKE.
THAT NEVER OCCURRED TO ME
BEFORE BUT IF YOU ARE NEAR
BURNING POISON OAK IT HAS VERY
VERY SEVERE. IMPACTS ON YOUR
LONGS AND THE THAT IT YOU KNOW
THAT THERE ARE WORKPLACE ISSUES
WITH REGARD TO SMOKE IN FIRE
FIGHTING LIKE THAT AND I JUST
KNOW AS SOMEBODY THAT RIDES MY
BIKE REGULARLY FOR EXERCISE ALL
THE YEARS I'VE BEEN IN
SACRAMENTO. IT'S GOTTEN
PROGRESSIVELY WORSE THE THERE
ARE JUST CERTAIN WEEKS I CANNOT
FOR HEALTH RIDE ANAEROBIC
CHOICE I HAVE A CHOICE THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK IN THE FIELD
DON'T HAVE A CHOICE- THEY'RE
OUT THERE SO. THERE'S A REASON
I THINK THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
TO THIS. BECAUSE I DON'T SEE
HOW ANYBODY COULD AND THIS IS
THE RIGHT THING AND I AND I
HATE TO SAY IT BUT I THINK OVER
TIME. EVEN GOING TO GET WORSE.
OUR END SO IT'S APPROPRIATE TO
GET THIS IN PLACE SAID AND TO
REALLY BE DOING THIS SO AS IT
GETS WORSE AND THE PEOPLE THAT
DON'T HAVE THE CHOICE. TO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO IT SO AT THE
RIGHT TIME MISTER CHAIRMAN BE
READY TO MAKE A MOTION AND I
CONGRATULATE MR RIVAS FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FOR. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
HELLO JUST SO SHE QUICK
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF SENATOR
LAYERED AND WE KNOW FROM
FIREFIGHTERS THEMSELVES
UNFORTUNATELY AND TRAGICALLY-
THE IMPACT OF THIS PARTICULAR
MATTER CARCINOGENS GIVEN US
SOME OF THE DATA THAT'S NOW OUT-
SO CLOSE COMMITTEE ON PRE IN
THE BILL FORWARD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
IT YOU KNOW- REALLY APPRECIATE
TO THE COMMENTS BUT I AS WELL
WANT TO THANK- THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE WORK ON ON ON
THIS BILL AND RESPECT THAT'S
WHEN I BOUGHT. MISTER CALDERON
MOVES THE BILL. CENTER LAYERED
MOVES A BILL OF MADAME
CONSULTANT. THE ROLL CALL
PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST THE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY ALL RIGHT. BUT AS THE
I OR CHAU BOOK. A TRAVEL GUIDE
TO WRESTLE. WRESTLE I'D LAYERED
HI. THERE I NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE.
WE HAVE A UNANIMOUS VOTE THE
BILL IS OUT. THE NEW BRINGS US
TO OUR FINAL BILL ON THE AGENDA
TODAY OR FINAL PRESENTATION MAY
BE. ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO HERE.
IS STANDING BETWEEN US AND A
WHOLE LOT OF THINGS WHO.
JOINT
EACH DO THAT SH T. CAN WAIT FOR
THE NATION TO THE- WE'RE GONNA
WE'RE GONNA GO HEAD LET ME CALL
ON THE MODERATOR. OF EARLIER
ANIMAL CENTERED WAS AWARE OF IT
BE- GIVEN HIS MULTIPLE
COMMITMENTS- EARLIER BUT WE HAD
AN ISSUE WHERE THERE WERE SOME
TECHNICAL PROBLEMS EVIDENTLY.
HAD OKAY AND THERE ARE THERE
MAY BE. WITNESSES ON PRIOR
BILLS WHO WISH TO STATE THEIR
NAME OPPOSITE THEIR OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT IN THE BILL NUMBER.
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN MAKE THAT
REQUEST AT THIS TIME. PLEASE
MAKE THE REQUEST I'M GONNA TAKE
A CHANCE HERE IN ASSUME THAT
THERE AREN'T THAT MANY OF
CALLED IN BUT THERE MAY BE A
COUPLE WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY
HAD GET THEIR- THEIR
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD SO
MODERATE HUGE ASSESS FOR ANYONE
WHO IS NOT ALREADY. EXPRESSES
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION POSITION
ON ANY BILL WE'VE TAKEN UP TO
THIS POINT. THEY MAY SPEAK AT
THIS TIME. YES THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AGAIN OUR APOLOGIES TO
ANYONE WHO WISH TO SPEAK ON
PREVIOUS BILLS. WHO WAS UNABLE
TO DO SO ALTHOUGH THEY DID
FOLLOW THE INSTRUCTIONS OF
PRESSING ONE AND ZERO AT THAT
TIME. SO AT THIS TIME- FOR
THOSE PREVIOUS BILLS FOR WHICH
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO SPEAK
HELLO. THANK YOU MAY PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO NOW. YOU'LL BE
IDENTIFYING YOURSELF IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION WHICH BILL YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF. I WILL TAKE IT
FROM THERE AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. WE'RE GONNA
GO TO LINE. NINETY FOUR. THANK
YOU MISTER TRIMMERS THIS IS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION WE
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR IT AB FOUR OH TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS. THEN
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN-
THIS IS A FINAL CALL FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO WERE UNABLE TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OR OPPOSITION TO. A
BILLS PRESENTED PREVIOUSLY-
THIS EVENING AND FOR THE
MEETING. THAT'S ONE ZERO THIS
TIME. SURE THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
HAD SIGNALED THAT THEY WISHED
THEY- ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR AND AGAIN- POSES
FOR THE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES
WE ANNOUNCED THE VERY BEGINNING
OF THIS MEETING THAT- THAT
TECHNOLOGY- AS LONG AS WE'VE
BEEN USING IT UP WITH CALLED
FOR RECALLS HAS BEEN A LITTLE
BIT OF A CHALLENGE MOSTLY IT
GOES SMOOTHLY BUT- WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE EVERYONE HAS A RIGHT
TO BE HEARD IN. THE EXERCISES
OF THEIR RIGHT TO BE HEARD AND
I THINK- PLEASE GIVING PEOPLE
AN OPPORTUNITY THIS EVENING TO
DO THAT JUST FOR THE RECORD.
HAD WE HEARD SOMETHING THAT
CAUSED SOMEONE TO WANT TO MAKE
A MOTION FOR RECONSIDERATION
THERE COULD HAVE BEEN DONE- SO
YOU'RE NEVER TESTIFYING IN VAIN
IS ALL'S COMMITTEE IS. IS
ACTUALLY IN SESSION NOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO.
WELCOME HE AND- YOU MAY PRESENT
YOUR BILL AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER TRY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT BEFORE- YOUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- LET'S START BY SAYING
THAT WE WILL- TAKE THE
UNLIMITED AUTHORS AMENDMENTS.
BALLOT THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AS
WELL- FOR THE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO HELP US MAKE A STRONGER AND
BETTER BILL. AND HIGH DO
APPRECIATE THE TIME THAT ITS
MEMBERS TAKEN TO- CONVERSE WITH
ME ABOUT THIS BILL BECAUSE-
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS. MISTAKE
BECAUSE THE COMMITTEES TIME
VERY SIMPLY. THAT WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO BANK THOSE
WHO ARE UNBANKED. OR
UNDERBANKED SO THAT WE CREATE.
A BANKING SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS
FOR NO FEES NO PENALTIES NO
OVERDRAFT COSTS WE'VE NOW SEEN.
BY THE EXTRAORDINARY PROFIT- ON
BEHALF OF BIG BANKS WHEN IT
COMES TO OVERDRAFT FEES. AND
I'VE OFTEN SAID WE GOT INTO
THIS WELL THE REASON WE GOT
INTO THIS IS BECAUSE IT'S AN
ISSUE OF EQUITY. BECAUSE WHEN A
RICH PERSON MAKES MONEY. THAT
MONEY MAKES MONEY FOR THEM WHEN
SOMEBODY LOW OF LOW INCOME WHO
IS A LOW WAGE EARNER MAKES
MONEY. THAT DOLLARS GOUGED AT
EVERY CORNER AND I'LL GIVE THE
EXPERIENCE FOR EXAMPLE SOME OF
HE NEIGHBORHOODS THAT THAT I
REPRESENT. WHEN AT PAYCHECK IS
EARNED EVEN IF FIFTEEN BUCKS AN
HOUR. IF YOU GO TO- IF YOU GO
TO YOUR LIQUOR STORE YOU GO TO
PAYDAY CASH TO GO TO ANY OTHER
PLACE THAT DOLLAR IS
CONTINUOUSLY GAS UP FIFTEEN
DOLLARS AND FIFTEEN DOLLARS. SO
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR TODAY IS
TO MOVE- IF WE'RE SUCCESSFUL
THIS COMMITTEE. IS TO CREATE
WHAT WE CALL CALVET. BECAUSE
WITH IT WHAT THIS WOULD ENTAIL
AND I'LL GIVE YOU BIG PICTURE
IN AN ACTUAL MECHANICS. HOW IT
HOW IT WOULD WORK WE ARE
LOOKING TO ESTABLISH. A
PLATFORM THAT WOULD ALLOW THOSE
WERE UNBANKED AND UNDERBANKED
WHICH IS IT WOULD. IN
CALIFORNIA TO BE ABLE TO
INVEST- IN OTHER WORDS DEPOSIT
THEIR DOLLARS- THAT PLATFORM-
WOULDN'T AND THOSE DOGS WOULD
BE MANAGED. BY A FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION- IF THAT IS A VERY
HIGH LEVEL WHICH WOULD CREATE
NO FEES- NO. COST NO PENALTIES
NOW IF WHEN WE GET THERE WILL
BE A BIT WHAT WE- INSIDE IN THE
BILL THAT WE- A- MARK ANALYSIS.
THIS MARKET AND NOW- WHAT'S-
WOULD DO ONE OF TWO THINGS. OR
THREE THINGS. ONE IT WILL TELL
US THAT WHAT IF WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS ACCURATE. HI THAT WE
THAT WE WOULD COME BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE- BEFORE THE
RESPECTIVE COMMITTEES AND ASKED
FOR THE ABILITY TO MOVE
FORWARD- A PROCEED. IF WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS NOT ACCURATE-
THEN THE SUCH AS ME BUT DOES NO
WE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO PROCEED-
WITH A BANK CAL THAT'S NOT
GONNA WORK OUT. HOWEVER ALSO WE
COULD MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
US AND SAY THIS IS THIS IS A-
THESE ARE RECOMMENDATIONS PUT
FORTH WE'D BE ABLE TO CHANGE
SOMETHING ONLINE SO VERY
SIMPLE. WOULD BE ABLE TO DO A
MARKET ANALYSIS AND THEN
PROCEED WITH SETTING UP- CAL
BANK. AND MISTER CHAIR LET'S
SAY A LOT OF OTHER THINGS BUT I
KNOW IT'S LATE IN THE EVENING.
ALSO WON'T BE RESPECTFUL TO
COMMITTEES TIME. ABBOTT. AND WE
HAVE TO- PRESENTERS. WE HAVE
RENEE- BAYARDO FROM SLU
CALIFORNIA AND JULIA- CENTER
VIA FOR THE FIGHT FOR FIFTEEN.
A BIGGER SHARE. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU I WILL GO AHEAD AND CALL IN
THE FIRST ON. SUPPORT READ
SUPPORT WITNESS RICK RENEE
BAYARDO IF YOUR PRESENT ON THE
TALKER OFFICE WHEN YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER
CARROLL TRIANGLE QUICKLY I KNOW
IT IS LATE IN THE DAY. OR
NIGHT. YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA WE
ARE ONE OF THE SPONSORS ALONG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
BANKING ALLIANCE IN THE
CALIFORNIA REINVESTMENT.
COALITION THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO AT THE ARE
YOU. I KNOW THAT THE OPPONENTS
THEY WANNA TALK ABOUT THE FIVE
POINT 6% OF UNBANKED IN
CALIFORNIA. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KIND OF DIG INTO
THAT DEEPER. BUT WHAT WE'RE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT ARE BLACK
AND LATINO HOUSEHOLDS WERE
FIFTEEN POINT 2% OF BLACK
HOUSEHOLDS. AND 40% LATINO
HOUSEHOLDS ARE UNBANKED BROUGHT
TO TALK ABOUT A PROBLEM WITH
THE POOR WERE TWENTY THREE
POINT 9% OF HOUSEHOLDS MAKE
LESS THAN FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. ARE COMPLETELY
UNBANKED ADULTS SIXTEEN POINT
2% OF THOSE MAKING FIFTEEN TO
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ARE ON
BANK THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
REALLY. DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTS CERTAIN COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA WE THINK THAT IT IS
A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM THAT
DESERVES THE LEGISLATURE'S
ATTENTION- AND FOR THAT REASON
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT- WHEN
IT'S TIME. TO VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER TURNER. OKAY
YOU FOR TO. DO WE HAVE- CHIU.
SARAVIA YES ONE OF THE ONLY
NUMBER THAT I'M YOUNG SO YOU'RE
NOT ALONE IN MY LOOK. ANDREA
EVEN A LITTLE TROUBLE CONTINUES
IN THE CAPITAL HELLO ARE YOU IN
A CLEARLY ALLEN PRESIDENT THEY
SEE IT AWHILE AND I LOOKED AT
IN THE COMING UP YOU KNOW AND I
KNOW THAT MANY A MINIMAL AMOUNT
IS THAT IS THERE AND YOU LOOK
AT A LOT IN COMMON YOUNG
CHILDREN BUT AMERICANS THAT
WILL INFLUENCE BUT ALSO ONE
DON'T ECONOMIC BENEVENTO
BACCHANAL BITING LOOK AT THE
LIVING. ANY OPINIONS YEAH. I'M
BILLION A MONTH ELEMENT LONG.
ELEMENTS I DON'T BELIEVE I
THOUGHT I YOU CAN I AND- THE
NUMBER A LOT OF TIME I DON'T
KNOW WILL NOT THAT MEAN.
MICHAEL KEMPER. THEY CALL ME
THAT I BE THAT. HELLO THIS.
GOING TO ALLOW YOU BY HOLDING A
LIST- OKAY JOHN ON IN AND ONLY.
MODELS AND I DO AND I WAS ONE I
WENT TO SOME MEDICAL I DON'T
LAWCENTER YOU SEE A THREE.
IT'LL DOUBLES AT THEM. THANK
WHEN BRIAN I'M GOING ON ANY
KIND OF MIDDLE INITIAL. BUT NOT
ONE THAT'LL MEET WHEN DOES KNOW
THE AND OF THE LETTER. THAT WE
OPEN. TO PEOPLE THAT ARE THE
MEANING OF BANKS. I WANT
LETTING MEANS A LITTLE- YEAH.
AND THEN THE MEAL ACADEMY LONG
ON THE LOWER AND NOT IN. THE
COMMENTARY MANBHUM NOT AS WELL
COURTS HAVE THEY. WHEN IN THE
BOTTOM. THANK BY THE MOTHER
THERE RECEIVING. YOU AT THE END
BOTTOM HIS OTHER THAT I HOPE
YOU LOCAL. ONE MILLION SEVEN
MEDICAL BELIEVE OUR DRY PULLING
CASTLE ON THE EVEN IF I DON'T I
MEAN THE ACTUAL. I DON'T KNOW A
LOT OF MOTHER. YOUR AVAILABLE
OUT OF THE COMMUNITY LOCAL
MILITANTS INTO COMMITTEE LOCAL
HUMANOID BECAUSE I'M NOT DONE
THEN AND- I WANT WHO. IT ONE
THOUGH I'M A LITTLE BIT ON THE
BUNGLED UP WHATEVER TAKE A-
SIMPLEMENTE LOOK ON THE BALLOT
COMING UP AMBIENT. ITS
POTENTIAL BENEFITS FAMILY OF
THE ONES. AND ICMP. ASSEMBLY
BELIEVABLE A MANY ABSOLUTE WE
DON'T. FEEL NEW AND SALAS I
LOOK AT IT BECAUSE ONE GUY
COMES UP AS A MOTHER MY OTHER
THING THERE IS A- LOT BUT IN
THE EARLY ONE. EVERYONE DOES
THAT YOU SEE IF THEY- HAVE ANY
ECONOMIC A COLOMBIAN CALIFORNIA
BUT I'M HUSSEIN. THAT AREA I'M
FAMILIAR MORE LET ME A LOCAL.
ACTUALLY YOU. THEN THINK. AND
I'M GOING TO HOLD ON. THE
INDEPENDENT OKAY APPLE YOU I
MEAN THE HAVE BEEN VERY AT THE
END. OF. NAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN. I NUMBER
BUT NOT FORGET FROM BET THREE
INCLUDED IN THAT I PROJECTED IN
A UNION. ACROSS WALKING FIVE
WILL. I NEED THE MINIMUM WAGE
FOR THE INDIA. OKAY ME FLAT FOR
EVERY STANDING UP EIGHT SIX. WE
SEE A BIG DIFFERENCE LAST BY
BANKING BANK INCREASE WILL RELY
ON. I HAD AN ACCOUNT WITH BANK
ABOUT MAKING TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. GET MORE HELP GETTING MY
ACCOUNT IS TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS.
BECAUSE I CAN MEET THE BANK
MINIMUM BALANCE REQUIREMENTS I
THANK. BUT DON'T ASK SOMEONE TO
GET MY AT MY BANK ACCOUNT OPEN.
THAT SAID DID HE EIGHTEEN
CONGRESS ENOUGH THOUGH IT MY DO
YOU THINK. THAT SHE'S THANK TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. I HAVE BEEN IN
MY LIFE WAS BEING FOR. EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED MAY NOT SOUND LIKE A
LOT TO YOU BUT THE LARGEST
BASIC EMERGENCY WALK ON THE
DOOR AT. EIGHT FOR FIFTEEN DAYS
OF FULL TIME WORK. I WE I COULD
SAY BAG WITH HOT YOU THE
MORNING I LAW TO SAY FOR A HOME
FOR MY GRANDCHILDREN. BLOODED
KILLER YOU KIMMEL PAINFUL. I
WILL PROBABLY USE THAT MONEY ON
THE BASICS MY FAMILY NEEDS TO
SURVIVE- DELIVERY MEDICATION MY
DAD. IN A TIGHT. FOUR FIVE
WORKING IF YOU LIKE I WILL IT I
HEATING OFF AT WALK IN WHEN WE
GO TO GOD IT. BANKING SEEDS AND
BEEN CAUGHT UP OUR HEAD. WE DID
WHAT WE NEED AB ELEVEN SAID
SEVEN PHOTO QUESTIONS HAVE THE
OPTION TO GET RID. THANK YOU IT
THAT MANY HIGH GET INCOME
PEOPLE THANK BANK OF GRANTED.
A. B. ELEVEN SEVEN SEVEN WHAT
HAS ARGUED THAT MINE ARE THE
TOP DO AN MEET. I YOU BOTH IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU UNDER
CONCLUDES THE LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES INCLUDING THE
TRANSLATION- US FIGURE THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WAS SPEAKING SUPPORT THE BILL.
SEEN NONE WILL CHECK YOUR FULL
ROOM ASCENA AND THERE WAS A
MODERATOR QUEUE UP ANYONE ON A.
B. ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN IN
SUPPORT. SURE WE DO HAVE AT
LEAST- FOR- FOR PEOPLE WHO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
THOSE OF YOU WHO YOU WISH TO
SPEAK PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO. ONE TO GO TO ONE ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHERE MEMBERS CRYSTAL HE
DOCKED ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES AND SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WHY. NINETY
FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MURS MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO EXPORT. LINE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN. GOOD EVENING CHAIR
MEMBERS MANY MINING'S TRINITY
TRAN AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC BANKING
ALLIANCE AT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
REINVESTMENT COALITION AND OVER
TWO HUNDRED NATIONAL DAY
WANTING COMMUNITY INTEREST
MORGAN IDEATION IN ADDITION TO
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED DELEGATES
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
EIGHTY ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN
ENERGETIC COMMITTEE ABOUT. I
THANK YOU. BLIND. ONE HUNDRED
NINETEEN. GOOD EVENING HEARING
MEMBERS AMY HìNH SHAKE WITH
WILDCAT CONSULTING REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. FIND ONE HUNDRED AND.
FIVE JOSHUA TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMITTEE THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THE FINAL CALL FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. SURE THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL COME TO
OPPOSITION THERE IS NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS. ON THIS
BILL. ANYONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. THE C. NONE. NO
ONE IN THE OVERFLOW ROOM IMPACT
YOU MODERATOR- SHE PLEASE ONE
MORE TIME TO QUEUE UP
OPPOSITION THIS TIME FOR A BI
ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN IF THERE
IS ANY. I THINK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. GOING TO GO
TO LINE. SEVENTY SIX. PINE
SEVENTY SIX SURE ONE IS OPEN.
GRAYSON LANE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
ANYONE ELSE FINAL CALL FOR
THOSE WHO. BUT ANYONE ELSE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK NOT POSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE HAS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK ALL RIGHT THANK YOU-
WELCOME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANYONE ON THE COMMITTEE WISHES
BEING CENTERED. YES SIR- IT IT
WAS INTERESTING BECAUSE AT
FIRST I WAS CAMPAIGNING FOR THE
SENATE SEAT THIS IS ONE OF THE
ISSUES I WAS ASKED ABOUT ALL
OVER THE PLACE THERE WAS REAL
INTEREST ON THE CENTRAL COAST
IN. IN HAVING A PUBLIC BANK AND
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE STEPS
WERE HI SALUTE THE AUTHOR FOR
SCALING BACK IN THE SENSE THAT
THIS IS A MARKET ANALYSIS AND
THIS REALLY MAKES THE CASE IN
OUTLINES THE PROBLEMS AND- HE
IS FORTY YEARS AGO I WAS PART
OF A SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE.
THAT HAD A SIMILAR ASPIRATION
AND SO WE FROM THE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CREDIT UNION AND
NOW THERE'S I THINK THIRTEEN OR
FOURTEEN THOUSAND MEMBERS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ASSETS TO DO CENTS
CREDIT TO PEOPLE THAT WOULD NOT
OTHERWISE HAVE IT IT'S ONE
PERSON ONE VOTE SO IT'S NOT
MERGING AND MOVING OUT OF THE
AREA IT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
TRULY COMMUNITY BASED AND BEEN
PART OF IT I THINK IT'S IN THAT
SPIRIT. THAT THERE IS A LOT OF
SUPPORT FOR THIS SO I THINK
IT'S REALLY APPROPRIATE TO GIVE
THE AUTHOR A CHANCE TO MAKE
THIS WORK HE'S TRYING TO DO IT
IN A WAY THAT HAS A MARKET
ANALYSIS AND AT THE RIGHT TIME
ALL BE. HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL.
FOR ANYBODY ELSE THE NEWMAN. AT
THANK YOU MISTRESS OR JUST WANT
TO ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF SENATOR- ANDERSON
WOMEN I WANT TO COMMEND YOU I
WAS I WAS COMPLIMENTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
EARLIER FOR THE LENGTH OF HER
SUPPORT LIST. I THINK YOU FIFTY
THREE EXCEEDED. THAT AND ALL
TIME RECORD IN MY EXPERIENCE
WAS REALLY IMPRESSIVE BUT- ALL
KIDDING ASIDE I DO APPRECIATE
WE'RE TRYING TO DO I THINK
THERE IS. A TREMENDOUS NEED NOT
JUST JUST TO GIVE. OUR LOW WAGE
CALIFORNIA'S ACCESS BUT
CONFIDENCE. IN THEIR ABILITY TO
SAVE- SHOULD LEAD TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY. THANK YOU
ANYBODY ELSE WISH TO SPEAK AT
THIS TIME AMENABLE SURE. HELLO
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
REACHING OUT AND- TRYING TO
SUGGEST ANY OF THE CONCERNS OR
QUESTIONS THAT WE MAY HAVE
INDIVIDUATED PRECIADO THAT
EFFORT- DID I UNDERSTAND
CORRECTLY HERE THAT THE STUDY
WOULD COST ABOUT A MILLION
DOLLARS. THE I DON'T THINK WE
PRICE TAG TO STUDY- BUT IT IS
GOING TO TAKE SOME RESOURCES TO
DO BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY IT
ALLOWS US TO DO THE MARKET
ANALYSIS THAT WOULD. THAT WOULD
EITHER TELL US THAT WERE
ACCURATE OR NOT ACCURATE- AND
WE WERE SUGGESTING THE- THAT
BANK CAL WILL DO. THE STUDY TO
START OVER- THE OTHER CONCERN I
HAVE. WITH THIS- WOULD BE- AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS JUST
FOR THE STUDY ON THIS RIGHT.
BUT THERE'S A COUPLE DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE BILL MEANT MANSA
RESEARCHER I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT.
I THINK THE ANSWER TO THIS
ISSUE IS ABOUT. ITS CUSTOMER IN
OUR HOUSE TO ASK THE TEARS
ABILITY BECAUSE- PRECIADO-
BLOOD IS A COUPLE DIFFERENT
PIECES OF THE BILL HAN MAN MY
PLEASURE- THERE IS A MARKET
ANALYSIS- AND THE OTHER
COMPONENTS OF THE BILL SO IF
THE MARKET ANALYSIS- WHICH-
WOULD DETERMINE WHETHER WE ARE
ACCURATE. NOT ACTORS OR MAKE
SUGGESTIONS TO THE PROCESS.
WILL COME BACK BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE THE LEGISLATURE
THEM WOULD HAVE THE ABILITY- TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT TO
PROCEED FORWARD. AT THE TIME
AND IF IT DOES PROCEED FORWARD
AND WE WOULD BE ABLE TO AND
THEN ENACT- BANK CAL AS I
MENTIONED. SEVEN AS YOU-
DRESSING THE ISSUE OF THE
BANKING- PROBLEM THE COST OF
DOING BUSINESS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR MANY EVERITT AND
SHE LEVEL WAGE EARNERS. HOW DO
OUR COMMUNITY BANKS- FIT INTO
THAT SCHEME AND UNDERSTANDING.
AND I'M GLAD YOU ASKED A
QUESTION BECAUSE IN MY CLOSING
THOSE GAPS IN THE IN THE SAME
SPIRIT THAT MY COLLEAGUE IN
NORTHERN CAPE- MY CENTER IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA MENTION THE
SAME REASON CHINESE WHAT
COMMUNITY BANKS HAVE DONE A
GREAT JOB. AS HAVE CREDIT
UNIONS AND I SAID THAT IN EVERY
SPEECH EVERYWHERE THIS PROVIDES
ONE OTHER ALTERNATIVE FOR FOLKS
WHO ARE UNBANKED OR UNDERBANKED
TO HAVE THE ABILITY- TO GO TO
THIS PLATFORM AND THE BANK AND
YOU LOOK A WOOD I CAN'T SUGGEST
TO BURKE YOU KNOW WHO DOES THE-
BUT LOW WHO TORTURES- THE WORK
BUT THEY HAVE THE ABILITY- TO
COMPETE FOR THE WORK TO BE ABLE
TO THE BUT THE- THE BACK IN
FINANCIAL SERVICES SO THEY FIT
RIGHT IN. INTO THE MISSION AND
THE SPIRIT OF TRYING TO BANK
THOSE WERE BANKED AND
UNDERBANKED- BOTH COMMUNITY
BANKS. CREDIT UNIONS AND- WHAT
WE'RE TRYING. TO DO HERE WITH
BANK- BANK CAL. SEVEN MY SHORT
PERIOD OF BEING IN THE
LEGISLATURE AS YOU. PROBABLY
ALREADY KNOW OF ONLY BEEN HERE
FOR FIVE SIX MONTHS OF BELIEVE
HAVE. FAMOUS THE CHANNEL FOR
SIX MONTHS OR SIX MONTHS OR SIX
MONTHS- I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE
TO SIT ON THE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS- COMMITTEE AND ONE
OF THE CONCERNS I'VE SEEN- MIND
YOU I BELIEVE IN SMALL
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE SAVE I SEE
THE ISSUES THAT HAPPEN WHEN WE
JUST BECOME BIGGER AND BIGGER-
AS FAR AS NOT BE ABLE TO BE-
EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE WHEN IT
COMES TO BANKING- COMPONENT SO
I UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERNS AND
THIS IS WHY I WAS ASKING ABOUT
COMMUNITY BANKS AND CREDIT
UNIONS IS THAT I TRULY
APPRECIATE THIS EFFORT IN THE
PRIVATE INDUSTRY- REASON BEING
IS THAT BECAUSE OF. JUST MY
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME BEING HERE
SEEING HOW WE- HAVE HAD SUCH
ISSUES WITH BOTH
ADMINISTRATIVELY AND
FINANCIALLY BE ABLE TO CONDUCT
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA IS A
STATE A STATE AGENCIES I HAVE
SEVERE CONCERNS ABOUT HAVING
THE STATE COME UP WITH A
BANKING SOLUTION OR BANKING
MODEL FOR OUR STATE. AND THIS
IS WHERE I PERSONALLY FEEL
THAT- PRIVATE INDUSTRY HAVE
COULD BE MORE EFFECTIVE IN
CONDUCTING THAT AND I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE- COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR COMING TOGETHER AND
CREATING PRIVATE BANKS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE ARE
ADEQUATE UNBANKED HER
UNDERSERVED AND THAT NOTION AND
I WOULD BE AN ABSOLUTE ADVOCATE
N. IN IN TRYING TO PURSUE THAT
BENNY VERSUS HAVING THE STATE
COME INTO THIS SPACE WHERE-
TRADITIONALLY WE HAVEN'T BEEN
VERY EFFECTIVE THIS STATE
AGENCIES OR BOARDS IN IN IN
DOING BUSINESS SPECIALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO FINANCES EDT JUST
TO MENTION ONE ONE ASPECT ON
THAT. AND THE THOUGHT THAT THE
STATE WOULD COME INTO THIS
SPACE MAKES IT INCREDIBLY
NERVOUS- ON. THAT ENDEAVOR IN
SO. I CANNOT AT THE TIME SO THE
BILL BUT I WOULD BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO WORK TO SEE HOW WE
COULD. WORK IN ADVOCATE IN
PRIVATE SPACE- AND BRINGING
PEOPLE TOGETHER IN IN REALLY-
CREATING BANKS BECAUSE BANKS
THIRTY PRIVATE ONES WE ALWAYS
THINK. BIG BANKS BUT- AS I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE STERN BANKS ON
A SMALLER SCALE PRIVATELY AND
WORKING COMMUNITIES AND SO I
WOULD BE AN ADVOCATE. ON THAT
ENDEAVOR. MEMBERS SPONSOR
TERROR THE TO GIVE DELAY IN
**** ME ONE IS INCLUDED IN YOUR
CLOSER THINK WE'RE WE'VE
CONCLUDED COMMITTEE COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU AND I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE CONTRACT I
MEAN THIS IS WHAT THIS IS WHAT
MAKES A LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
WORK IS THAT WE CAN HAVE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION- BUT IT
HELPS TO MAKE IT A BETTER BILL
BECAUSE I HAVE TO TRUST THE
QUESTIONS IN PREVIOUS
COMMITTEES- THERE WERE- TOUGH
QUESTIONS REGARDING- WHETHER
THIS MAKES SENSE WITH IT WAS
NEEDED. AND EVEN TO SOME OF
YOUR QUESTIONS I MIGHT POINT
OUT OF THE MARKET ANALYSIS WILL
WE SAY YOU KNOW THAT IT AND
SECTION SEE THAT ANNOUNCES THAT
THE CAL OF THE POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE UNBANKED
AND THE REASON FOR WHICH THEY
ARE ON BANK IN THE RESULT- THAT
THAT. THE SOME OF THE- INDUSTRY
TO YOU SUGGESTED IS DOING IN
THE IN A PROPER JOB I DON'T
BELIEVE SO BUT IT MAY RESULT IN
THAT BUT IT ALSO MEANS ON THE
FACT THAT THEY'RE NOT IN THE
ANSWERS WOULD BE QUESTION-
CERTAINLY QUESTIONS WOULD BE
ANSWERED WITH A MARKET
ANALYSIS. WE TAKE A LOOK AT
OTHER THINGS LIKE THE
AVAILABILITY OF PARTICIPATING
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS WHETHER
THIS WORK COULD BE DONE OR NOT-
DENOUNCES OF ADVANTAGES R
DISADVANTAGES COMPARED TO THE
PRIVATE SECTOR ALTERNATIVES SO
WE LOOK TOWARDS DOING THAT BUT
ALSO I WOULD SAY THAT I WANT TO
BE CLEAR THAT WE ARE NOT
ESTABLISHING. A STATEWIDE BANK-
OR A DEPARTMENT RATHER A
PLATFORM- THAT HAS BEEN PROVEN
TO WORK- CAN. WE MAY DISAGREE
RIGHT BUT LET BUT- CAL SAVE. IT
A PLOT. THAT LOOK VERY SIMILAR
LIKE THIS WHERE THERE IS A
PUBLIC PLATFORM. WHERE PEOPLE
CAN SAVE THEIR DOLLARS. AND
THE- AND PRIVATE INDUSTRY IS
THE BACKSIDE OF IT THAT MANAGES
THE DOLLARS AND IN IN THE WAY
THAT WE'RE LOOKING- IN THE
STEPS IN THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
BANKING- OPTION ACT WHICH- IS
IN EFFECT- CAL BANK SO. I WOULD
SAY THAT THERE IS THAT THERE IS
A NEED AND- I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR. THAT WHAT I IT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO- IN- IS
ESTABLISHED THIS. FOR THE SAKE.
OF PEOPLE NOT FOR THE SAKE OF
PROFIT. AND I WANNA BE VERY
CLEAR THE BIG BANKS ARE DOING
THIS IN A PROVIDED SERVICES.
BUT ULTIMATELY IT'S- IT'S A FOR
PROFIT. AND IT'S FOR WALL
STREET. AND WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
DO THAT. MUCH LIKE THE WORK OF
COMMUNITY BANKS. MUCH LIKE THE
WORK OF CREDIT UNIONS- WE ARE
ALSO LOOKING TO ESTABLISH. THE
ABILITY FOR PEOPLE. TO BE BANG
TO UNDERBANKED OR UNBANKED. AND
WEBER WE BELIEVE THAT THAT IT
IS ESSENTIAL- TO HAVE A SYSTEM.
A FINANCIAL SYSTEM THAT CHARGES
NO PENALTIES. NO FEES. NO
OVERDRAFT PROTECTION I'M SORRY
NO OVERDRAFT FEES AND WE JUST
SAW SOME OF THE BIGGEST BANKS
MAKE HISTORIC AMOUNTS OF
DOLLARS ON OVERDRAFT FEES.
DURING THE TIME THAT PEOPLE ARE
SUFFERING- INSTANCE SO WHAT I
WOULD ARGUE. IS THAT THAT I
WOULD CONTINUE TO WANT TO TALK
TO YOU BUT IT'S VERY. VERY
CLEAR WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
AS A COMPARED TO THE MISSION.
THAT A BIG BANK IS TRYING TO
DO. AND THEY HAD AND I WOULD
ARGUE THAT THERE'S A NECESSARY
MISSION. TO COMPLEMENT THE GOOD
WORK THE COMMUNITY BANKS AND
CREDIT UNIONS ARE DOING TODAY.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE BEFORE YOU
ARE PRESENTING AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN- WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC BANKING ACT.
AND REALLY CAN'T SEE MORE THAN
THAN TO RISK TO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF A MISTER TO WHO CAN
PRESENT BECAUSE THE SENATE
RULES ONLY ALLOWS ONE
PERCENTER. BUT WHO WHO ALSO
WORKED ON. AB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN
TO ESTABLISH CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
BANKS UP AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- DIFFERENT PIECE
LEGISLATION DIFFERENT WORK. BUT
BUT IT CAME OUT OF NECESSITY
BECAUSE OF FINANCIAL SYSTEMS
ARE NOT WORKING AND I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE OVER AND OVER OVER.
BIG BANKS NOT DOING THIS- OUT
OF THE GOODNESS OF THE HEART.
I'M SURE THERE'S GOOD PEOPLE
WHO WORK IN THEM BUT IT'S
PROFIT DRIVEN WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE. TODAY IS ESTABLISH
A DIFFERENT SORT OF BANKING
SYSTEM. FOR THE INTEREST OF
PEOPLE NOT PROFIT OR OR
STAKEHOLDERS OR WALL STREET
STAKEHOLDERS THAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE. AWESOME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AT
RESPECTFULLY LAST WHEN I BUILT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
TO SHEER PASSION FOR THE ISSUE.
THE SENATOR ALSO I'M SORRY.
COULD I JUST MAKE A QUICK CALL.
HE GIVE. YOU KNOW THE THERE WAS
A STATEMENT MADE BY SOMEONE I
DON'T KNOW IF IS THE AUTHOR
SOMEONE ELSE I HEARD. AND THAT
IS THAT. THESE FEES. ARE NOT
BEING PAID BY THE WEALTHIER
PEOPLE. YOU KNOW THE FEES OVER
YOU KNOW OVERDRAFT ALL THESE
WAYS AND- PENALTIES-
TRANSACTION SERVICES ATM
SERVICES ALL THAT IS BEING PAID
BY PEOPLE WHO HAVE LESSER
MONEY. AND IT'S JUST CRAZY BUT
THE MORE MONEY YOU HAVE THE
LESS LIKELY IF AT ALL THAT YOU
WILL EVER PAY ANY OF THESE
FEES- SO WORKING PEOPLE WHO ARE
REALLY TRYING TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES WORK REALLY HARD EVERY
SINGLE PENNY COUNTS. FIVE
DOLLARS TO GET YOUR MONEY OUT
OF THE BANK IS A LOT OF MONEY
TIMES CYBERMAN MUCH MANY TIMES
YOU DO THAT SO. THAT'S WHAT
CONVINCES ME IF THE PRIVATE
SECTOR WANTED TO DO THIS NOBODY
WOULD GET IN THEIR WAY NOBODY
WOULD GET IN THEIR WAY THEY ARE
FREE TO DO THAT TODAY WITH OR
WITHOUT A. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN THEY COULD DO IT THEY DO
NOT WANT TO DO IT. BUT THEY
WILL STAND IN THE WAY OF OTHERS
TRYING TO DO IT AND I THINK
THAT'S A REAL PROBLEM THAT WE
NEED TO COME FACE TO FACE SO I
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU SENATOR-
APPRECIATE YOUR CLOTHES AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR PASSION FOR THE
ISSUE AND- WE HAVE A PROMOTION
BY SENATOR NEWMAN. AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND- CALL THE
ROLL CALL VOTE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
COURTESY OF THE ARTIST THE I.
OF CHOI BOGUE NO THE TROUBLED
NOW WRESTLE. BUT AS I LAYERED
HI. THERE I NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE
MORRELL FORTY ONE VOTE THE BILL
WAS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU EVERYONE WHO
TESTIFIED TODAY FOR THOSE WHO
TRIED TO AS FAR WANTED TO SPY
WERE UNSUCCESSFUL FOR ANY
REASON PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SUBMIT YOUR TESTIMONY IN
WRITING A DELIVER PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE TO DO THE
SAME WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
THEIR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION
WAS ALONG HEARING- EVEN FOR US.
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK- THE
MODERATOR FOR DOING A
TREMENDOUS JOB. JUGGLING THINGS
AND YOU KNOW KEEPING US ON
TRACK KEEPING THINGS SORTED
OUT- THIS WAS COMMITTEE STUFF-
HOMA THANK YOU AND YOUR ENTIRE
TEAM FOR DOING A GREAT JOB
AGAIN FOR A FEW MINUTES TO TURN.